ON THE ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE ON
HIGHER EDUCATION TO ORDER. I AM
CHAIR OF HIGHER EDUCATION
ASSEMBLY MEMBER JOSE MEDINA.
THIS HEARING IS TIMELY. IT WAS
ONLY RECENTLY THAT I LEARNED OF
CS USE QUANTITATIVE REASONING
ADMISSION PROPOSAL. WHEN. I
FIRST LEARNED OF THE PROPOSAL I
WAS VERY SURPRISED. WHY AND I
AS CHAIR OF THE HIGHER
EDUCATION COMMITTEE BEEN MADE
AWARE OF THE PROPOSAL BY CSU.
THEN I FOUND OUT. OF FROM MY
COLLEAGUES THAT MOST OF THEM
WERE NOT AWARE OF THIS PROPOSAL
EITHER. WELL THERE BEEN A FEW
OTHER IMPORTANT TOPICS THAT I
HAD PLANNED TO HEAR HAVE
HEARINGS ON I MEAN LEAD CHANGE
MY PLANS SO THAT THE COMMITTEE
COULD CONVENE A HEARING. ON
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITIES
QUANTITATIVE REASONING PROPOSAL.
I THINK THAT IT'S SIMPLY THAT
IMPORTANT. THE GOAL OF THIS
HEARING IS TO LEARN DIRECTLY
FROM THE CSU THE RATIONALE
BEHIND THE PROPOSAL. LEARN WHAT.
IF ANY UNINTENDED UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES COME WITH THIS
PROPOSAL AND TO HEAR FROM THE
STAKE HOLDER GROUPS. I
UNDERSTAND THAT THAT THIS
PROPOSAL HAS NOT NECESSARILY
BEEN A COLLABORATIVE EFFORT.
BETWEEN THE CSU AND STAKEHOLDER
GROUPS. I WILL BE LISTENING TO
HIM TO LEARN WHY. I TRUST THAT
AT THE END OF THIS HEARING WE
WILL BE ABLE TO WALK AWAY
HAVING HAD A COMPREHENSIVE
CONVERSATION AND MOVING FORWARD
WE'LL KEEP THE LINES OF
COMMUNICATION OPEN. WITH ALL
INVOLVED. AND LET ME JUST TO
REITERATE A LITTLE BIT. ON THAT
AS AS I SPEAK. WITH MY OWN
COLLEAGUES IN BOTH THE ASSEMBLY
AND THE SENATE. I FIND OF.
THEIR OWN SURPRISE. OF THE CSU
PROPOSAL. AS I SPOKE WITH MY
OWN A SUPERINTENDENT A
RIVERSIDE UNIFIED. ALSO NOT NOT
AWARE AND SO I A I DO VERY
STRONGLY BELIEVE THAT THIS
HEARING IS IMPORTANT. WITH THAT
LET ME INVITE UP TO THE TABLE.
CHRISTOPHER CALVET HELLO DAN.
THERE'S NO ONE ELSE OKAY. RIGHT
TO THE AUDIENCE BEFORE YEAH TO
THE AUDIENCE WANNA MAKE
EVERYONE AWARE THAT THERE'S
AGENDA AND PERTINENT MATERIALS
FOR THIS HEARING CAN BE FOUND
ON OUR COMMITTEE WEBSITE OF FOR
THOSE OUT IN THE AUDIENCE AND
FOR THOSE LISTENING YOU CAN
FIND THE MATERIALS. OUR
COMMITTEE WEBSITE. WE AND WE
HAVE ASSEMBLY MEMBER MCCARTY IS
JOIN THIS AND LET ME GO TO HIM
FOR ANY OPENING REMARKS YEAH
THANK YOU WELL I LOOK FORWARD
TO HEARING FROM OUR OUR FRIEND
IN OUR MAYOR OF THE CITY WAS
SACRAMENTO BY THE WAY
CHRISTOPHER KAMAL BY DID WANT
TO NOTE THAT MANY MANY YEARS
AGO IN A LIFETIME AGO HE HAD
YOUR JOB HE WAS THAT HE WAS THE
CHIEF CONSULTANT. FOR THE
ASSEMBLY HIGHER IT COMMITTEE
UNDER THEN CHAIR TOM HATED WHEN
THEY CREATED THIS COMMITTEE SO
HERE YOU ARE MANY YEARS LATER
BUT THIS IS AN IMPORTANT TOPIC
AND A THANK YOU MISTER MEDINA
FOR KIND OF FRAMING THE ISSUE
IS NOT SOMETHING THAT WE WILL
VOTE ON THE LEGISLATURE IT'S
KIND OF BELOW THE RADAR THIS
YEAR'S U. TRUSTEES CERTAINLY
HAVE A HAVE A BIG DEBATE AND A
VOTE ON THIS IN THE COMING
MONTHS BUT THIS CERTAINLY HAS
AN IMPACT. ON FUTURE
GENERATIONS OF HIGH SCHOOL
STUDENTS AND I THINK WE OUGHT
TO HAVE A ROBUST PUBLIC AIRING
OF THE TOPIC TODAY I'M I'M I'M
FRANKLY WIDE OPEN ON THIS ISSUE
I'M VERY CURIOUS TO HEAR THE
PROS AND THE CONS I KNOW I'VE
HEARD A LOT OF THE ISSUES FAR
AS HOW THIS WOULD HAVE AT A
DETRIMENT TO THE OUR OUR
STUDENTS AND COMMUTER CROSS
CALIFORNIA SOME REALLY HOPING
TO HEAR FROM THE CSU TODAY. AND
HERE THERE PERSPECTIVE IN THE
RATIONALE BEHIND IT SO THANK
YOU FOR A FOR PUTTING THIS
TOGETHER CHEN MEDINA AND LASTLY
THIS IS AN ISSUE IF IT GOES
THROUGH I KNOW WILL HAVE SOME
FINANCIAL IMPACT NOT JUST ON
THE CSU BUT SCHOOL DISTRICTS
HAVE TO IMPLEMENT THIS. IS OUR
NEED FOR MORE COURSE OFFERINGS
AND FEATURES A BILL THAT. KATE
PULLED DISTRICTS READY STRAPPED
IN THE FIRST PLACE AND YOU KNOW
DURING THE BUDGET COMMITTEE
SERVING WITH YOU ON MY
COMMITTEE YOU KNOW THIS. TO THE
WILL HAVE TO BET YOU LOOK AS
WELL SO. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MISTER MCCARTY. AND WITH THAT
LET ME ALSO WELCOME. CHRIS TO
THE DYESS. WHO CHRIS THE
PROFESSOR ENDOWED CHAIR AND
PROFESSOR PUBLIC POLICY. AND
ADMINISTRATION AT CSU
SACRAMENTO. AND BEFORE YOU
BEGIN. ANNOUNCER ALREADY. OKAY.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR IT IS A
PLEASURE TO BE BACK AT THE AT
THE COMMITTEE I WANT TO CLARIFY
ALSO THAT I'M I'M HERE NOT ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITY OF BEEN A FACULTY
MEMBER THERE FOR ABOUT FIVE
MINUTES AND HAVE PLAYED NO ROLE
IN THE DEVELOPMENT OF THE
PROPOSAL BUT I'M I'M I'M I'M
I'M VERY UP A PLEASE BE BACK
WHERE WE ARE ABOUT TO CELEBRATE
THE SIXTIETH ANNIVERSARY OF THE
ELIGIBILITY POLLS FOR
CALIFORNIA HIGHER EDUCATION THE
MASTER PLAN ITSELF THE NATIONAL
PRIOR TO CHRISTMAS WAS A WAS
FINALIZED IN NINETEEN SIXTY BUT
IT WAS IN THE FIRST WEEK OF
NOVEMBER NINETEEN FIFTY NINE.
THAT THE AGREEMENT WAS REACHED
ON THE ELIGIBILITY RULES
PROPOSED BY THE CHANCELLOR OF
THE CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY
AT THE TIME WE ARE ARMS ARE
THAT THAT THAT THE PRESIDENT
DISCUSS STATE AT THE TIME AS A
WAY TO MANAGE DOWN AND ROLL
MINTS AT BOTH UC AND CSU AND TO
DIVERGE AT THE TIME FIFTY
THOUSAND STUDENTS TO THE
CALIFORNIA COMMITTEE COLLEGES
SYSTEM AND THE RESERVE IT
BACKWARDS OF THE PERIOD OF
IMMENSE GROWTH IN HIGHER
EDUCATION IN CALIFORNIA AND THE
MASTER PLAN STUDY COMMITTEE
WHICH IS INDEPENDENT OF THE
LEGISLATURE BUT THE
LEGISLATURE'S WATCHING
CAREFULLY. OUTSIDE ONE OF ITS
PRINCIPAL TASKS THAT DEALING
WITH ENROLLMENT SEARCH THAT THE
FIRST OF THE TIDAL WAVES AND
ELIGIBILITY POOLS WERE
CONSTRUCTED IN A WAY THAT WOULD
REDUCE THE TOTAL AMOUNT OF
ENROLLMENT AT YOU SEE AND THIS
YEAR THAT WAS REALLY BILLS WERE
NEW IN NINETEEN FIFTY NINE BUT
THE ROLE OF THE OF THE SYSTEMS
IN IT IN AFFECTING TWELVE
EDUCATION WAS WAS NOT THE
ORIGINAL SITUATION IN
CALIFORNIA EIGHTEEN SEVENTY
NINE ACTUALLY PROVISION THAT
PROHIBITED IT WOULD HAVE A
PROHIBITED SUB TO IT DID NOT
ALLOW FOR OF THE LEGISLATURE TO
APPROPRIATE ANY MONEY FOR A.
PUBLIC HIGH SCHOOLS IN
CALIFORNIA. OF THE CONSTANTLY.
LEGISLATURE TO APPROPRIATE
MONEY FOR HIGH SCHOOLS. DURING
THAT PERIOD HIGH SCHOOLS
EMERGED NONETHELESS A FULLY
FUNDED BY LOCAL PROPERTY TAXES.
AND FROM THE BEGINNING IN THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA WAS
HEAVILY INVOLVED IN IN THEIR
CONSTRUCTION. IN IN IN IN IN
THEIR SERVICES. AT BEGINNING IN
THAT JUST BEFORE THE TURN OF
THAT CENTURY. UC FACULTY BEGAN
TO A CREDIT. HIGH SCHOOLS IN
CALIFORNIA THIS BEFORE WASCO
ACCREDITATION OR ANYTHING ELSE
SO WAS THE UNIVERSITY
CALIFORNIA THAT SET THE
STANDARDS FOR. ALL THE ALL THE
COURSES FOR GRADUATION AND
ULTIMATELY FOR PREPARATION. AND
THE EQUIVALENT OF WHAT WE THINK
OF TODAY'S ATG. WAS IN SOME
SENSE EVEN MORE SPECIFIC BACK
THAT THE IN ITS FIRST THEN THE
FIRST VERY ITERATIONS. SO
RATHER THAN THE GENERAL THINGS
THAT WE THINK ABOUT TODAY THE
UNIVERSITY SAID YOU MUST HAVE
COMPLETED LADY OF THE LAKE.
MERCHANT OF VENICE PLUTARCH'S
LIVES. ARITHMETIC INCLUDING THE
METRIC SYSTEM BUT NOT
NECESSARILY PROFIT LOSS IN
TAXES. QUADRATIC EQUATIONS BUT
NOT THE MEASUREMENT OF A
CIRCLE. GEOGRAPHY AT LEAST AS
IT'S USED IN THE FIRST GRADE.
LOTS AND LOTS OF GREAT LOTS AND
LOTS OF LATIN. PHYSICS BUT ONLY
TALKS VERY MENTALLY L. ALONG
WITH CHEMISTRY BIOLOGY
TRIGONOMETRY PHYSIOLOGY OR IF
NONE OF THOSE FREE DRAWING. SO
THE LEGISLATURE AT THE
UNIVERSITY FROM THE VERY
BEGINNING HAS BEEN VERY
INVOLVED IN DETERMINING. THE
CURRICULUM A NOT JUST OF THE
SCHOOLS BUT OF THE CLASSES
THEMSELVES OF DATING BACK TO
THE TURN OF THE- TWENTIETH
CENTURY. BUT I'M AND CONTINUED
FOR QUITE A LONG TIME IN THE
NINETEEN EIGHTIES THE
UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA BEGAN
WHAT WHAT WAS THE EIGHT AFTER
CORMAN'S AND STATE AS A TO F.
FOR DECADES AND DECADES AND
DECADES UNTIL BECOMING A TO G.
AT THE LATTER PART OF THE LAST
CENTURY. AND THOSE EIGHT EVER
COURTS HAVE LARGELY STAYED THE
SAME FROM THAT FROM THAT
PERIOD. AND ALTHOUGH. WE MAY
NOT THINK ABOUT THE OF THE
LEVEL OF RIGOR OF SCIENCE IN
EVANS BACK THAT THERE WERE
QUITE A FEW DISSERTATIONS AND
STUDIES DONE BY THE-
PRESIDENT'S OFFICE BY THE
ACADEMIC SENATE AND- KILLER AT
THE TIME. OF THE RELATIVE.
VALUE OF SUCH COURSES FIRST.
AID VERSUS OTHER WAYS OF.
ADMISSION OTHER WERE NO TESTS.
STANDARDIZED TESTS AT THAT
POINT THOSE WERE TO COME
RELATIVELY SOON. BUT THE
SUBJECT MATTER COURSES CAME
ABOUT SHORTLY AFTER THE
ACADEMIC SENATE BECAME
RECOGNIZED AS THE PRIMARY
SOURCE OF GOVERNANCE AROUND
ADMISSIONS. NOW TODAY WE TAKE
THAT LARGELY FOR GRANTED BUT IN
IT WAS A NIGHT IT WAS IN THE
NINETEEN TWENTIES BUT
SPECIFICALLY IN ABOUT NINETEEN
TWENTY. THAT THE BERKELEY
REVOLUTION CREATED WHAT TODAY
IS OUR MODEL OF ECONOMIC SHARED
GOVERNANCE IN CALIFORNIA. IN
EDUCATION POLICY IN ADMISSIONS
WERE SPECIFICALLY ASSIGNED TO
THE UNIVERSITY TO THE YOUR
ACCOUNT FOR HIS ACADEMIC SENATE
AT THAT PERIOD. ABOUT THAT TIME
IS WHEN THE CSU STARTED TO
CONGEAL AS A STATE COLLEGES
UNDER THE STATE BOARD. AS WELL
BUT DID NOT HAVE THE SAME
STRUCTURE BACK IN OF ACADEMIC
OF SHARED GOVERNANCE AT THAT AT
THAT POINT. AND THROUGH THAT
PERIOD. BOTH THE CONSTITUTION
OF EIGHTEEN SEVENTY NINE AND
ALL OF THE STATUTES THAT SET UP
SEE IT'S OF THE STATE COLLEGES
ALL WERE INSISTENT THAT THERE
SHALL BE NO POLITICAL OR
SECTARIAN INFLUENCE. ON THE TO
CALIFORNIA OR THE CALIFORNIA
STATE UNIVERSITY THE LANGUAGE
IS MOSTLY THE SAME IT'S JUST
UC'S LANGUAGES IN THE
CONSTITUTION. BUT THE NOTION
AROUND AUTONOMY OF THE SYSTEMS
AND THE THEY'RE SETTING OF
ACADEMIC MATTERS IN ADMISSIONS
WAS LARGELY DELEGATED EVEN AT
THAT STAGE TO THE TO THE
INSTITUTIONS. I'M THEMSELVES
AND THEN BEGINNING IN THE
NINETEEN TWENTIES TO THE
ACADEMIC SENATE. BY THE TIME
THAT THE MASTER PLAN CAME
AROUND. THAT SYSTEM WAS
STARTING TO BURST SCHOOLS WERE
SAYING IT'S NOT FAIR FOR THE
UNIVERSITY TO BE ACCREDITING US
WE DO OTHER THINGS AND JUST
SENSE OF FOLKS UP TO COLLEGE.
WATCH ACCREDITATION WAS CREATED
ABOUT THE SAME TIME AS THE
MASTER PLAN ITSELF I'M IN THE
EARLY PART OF THE NINETEEN
SIXTIES OF THE HIGH SCHOOLS
THEMSELVES WITH A CREDIT EACH
OTHER. AS OPPOSED TO THE TO THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA. AND
OTHERS ARE SAYING IF YOU FINISH
A HIGH SCHOOL DEGREE A HIGH
SCHOOL DIPLOMA CALIFORNIA
SHOULD BE ENTITLED TO GOON TO
THE UNIVERSITY. AS A PET JUST
AS A MATTER OF POLICY. SO THE
MASTER PLAN CAME ABOUT IN THE
QUIRK OF HISTORY AS IT HAD CAME
ABOUT RIGHT AT THE POINT OF THE
TIDAL WAVE. AND SO OF THE
FOUNDING DOCUMENTS ESSENTIALLY
OF THE KEEP POLICIES IT'LL
DRIVE ADMISSIONS TODAY WERE SET
UP IN A PERIOD OF IMMENSE.
GROWTH AND A HIGH DEGREE OF
PROJECT. SCARCITY RIGHT SO IT'S
IMPORTANT JUST REMEMBER THAT
THOSE CONDITIONS ARE WHAT WHAT
FRAME EVERYTHING. THAT HAS
HAPPENED SINCE THAT TIME. SO
THE MASTER PLAN. SET THE
ELIGIBILITY POOLS OF ONE THIRD
FOR CSU AND TWELVE AND A HALF
PERCENT OR ONE EIGHT FOR THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA. THOSE
WERE REDUCTIONS FROM THE FROM
THE POOLS FROM WHICH THE IN THE
TWO UNIVERSITIES WERE ADMITTING
STUDENTS PRIOR TO THE MASTER
PLAN. SO THE MASTER PLAN THAT
TODAY WE LARGELY CELEBRATE AS
A- THAT YOU KNOW IF THIS GRAND
GLOBAL A STEP FORWARD FOR
ACCESS AND EXCELLENCE. ITS
PRINCIPAL FEATURE WAS TO REDUCE
ACCESS TO THE TO PUBLIC
UNIVERSITIES IN IN THE CREATION
OF THE COMMITTEE CALLED SYSTEM
SO. CSU ELIGIBILITY WAS ABOUT
FORTY PERCENT. AT THAT 45% AT
THAT TIME AND YOU SEE
ELIGIBILITY WAS A FIFTEEN IN
THE MASTER PLAN TURN THOSE
NUMBERS DOWN AND SAID. BECAUSE
IT'S SO EXPENSIVE AND BECAUSE
WE WANT TO PRESERVE THE QUALITY
OR THE ELITE NATURE OF THESE
INSTITUTIONS DEPENDING ON YOUR
POINT OF VIEW. WE'RE GOING TO
RE DIRECT STUDENTS TO THE
COMMITTEE COLLEGES WITH THE
IRON CLAD PROMISE IN THE MASTER
PLAN THAT THERE WILL BE.
SEAMLESS EASY SIMPLE TRANSFER
SYSTEM. THAT WILL MAKE IT AS
THOUGH NOBODY IS A AS A WE
CHANGE NOTHING IT'S SIMPLY THAT
WILL BE A- MORE COST EFFECTIVE
INSTITUTION. SO THAT WAS THE
PROMISE. OF THE MASTER PLAN AND
THESE ELIGIBILITY INDEXES. TO
KEEP THINGS TO REMEMBER FROM
THE MASTER PLAN THAT ONE IT
NONE OF THIS WAS WRITTEN IN THE
STATUTE. EVERYTHING OF MOST
EVERYTHING ELSE IN THE IN THE
MASTER PLAN IS IN THE STATE LAW
IT WAS CONTAINED IN THE DOT AND
DOT AND THE DON HOW ACT ENACTED
BY THE LEGISLATURE TO GREAT
ACCLAIM. BUT REALLY SOME WAYS
ONE OF THE MOST IMPORTANT
FEATURES OF MASTER PLAN WAS
NEVER CAUGHT UP. NOT ACCIDENT
THE LEGISLATORS HAD MANY MANY
DANCERS AND- SEVERAL REVIEWS OF
THEM. TO PLAN AND- IT EVER.
PARTICULARLY IN CANADA I'M
PLANNING CHECK I'M AS- A MEMBER
PRESS AND SALAS IN. TWO
THOUSAND AND TWO PLAN BY STE.
FROM THAT POOL. IT'S ONLY BEEN
A CULTURAL CHANGE SINCE THAT
TIME THAT WEEK WE INTERPRET NOW
IT'LL ELIGIBILITY MEAN YOU'RE
GUARANTEED. NOT LEGALLY BUT
YOU'RE GUARANTEED TO BE ABLE TO
GO TO THESE INSTITUTIONS IF YOU
ARE IN THE TOP ONE THIRD IN THE
TOP ONE EIGHT THAT WASN'T A
FEATURE OF THE ORIGINAL MASTER
PLAN. A MATCH BUT WAS ALSO
BEING CONSTRUCTED AT ABOUT THE
TIME THAT THE STANDARDIZED TEST
MOVEMENT WAS HAPPENING ACROSS
THE COUNTRY AND IN CALIFORNIA.
BOTH THE YOU SEE AND THE
CALIFORNIA STATE COLLEGES WERE
LARGELY REJECTING THE TEST
APPROACH THEY BOTH BELIEVED
THAT THEIR COURSE REQUIREMENTS
FOR YOU SEE IT WAS ESSENTIALLY
THIS EIGHT F. EIGHT A. G.
COURSE SEQUENCE THAT YOU'RE
STILL TALKING ABOUT TODAY. FOR
CSU WITH SOMETHING DIFFERENT
BUT CLOSE THEY BELIEVE THAT
THOSE WERE THAT THEIR
REQUIREMENTS AND GRADES FROM
HIGH SCHOOL WHERE A NOT FOR AND
THAT THEY WERE CORRELATED. A
WHAT THEY CORRELATED WELL WITH
STUDENT PERFORMANCE IN THE
FRESHMAN AND SOPHOMORE YEARS.
BUT THE TENSION AND BECAME HOW
DO YOU ACHIEVE THESE REDUCED
ELIGIBILITY POOLS AND THERE ARE
THREE PRINCIPAL COMPONENTS TO
THAT A ONE OF WHICH SHE IS YOU.
KNOW MORE OF ONE COMBINATION OF
WHICH CSU INVENTED SO THE FIRST
IS THE IS THE TEST SCORE AND
THE GPA REQUIREMENT WHICH- WE
NOW WE NOW IT'S TAKEN FOR
GRANTED THAT THAT'S AND IT'S AN
INDEX. TO FEED IN IN A GRADE
AND YOU'VE DONE YOUR GPA AND
YOUR FEET IN YOUR TEST SCORE
AND THE INDEX OF THAT
DETERMINES WHETHER OR NOT
YOU'RE YOU'RE ELIGIBLE. THAT'S
NOT FROM THE MASTER PLAN ITSELF
THE MATCH POINT IT SPECIFY HOW
ELIGIBILITY WAS TO BE.
CALCULATED BUT THAT CA
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY
CREATED THAT INDEX ITSELF AND
YOU SEE FOLLOWED SHORTLY.
SHORTLY THEREAFTER AND THE
OTHER REQUIREMENTS SEPARATE
FROM THE INDEX IS THE COURSE
PAT REQUIRE THAT YOU MUST
COMPLETED THE WORD THAT THE
COURT SCHOOLS COURSE. AND THEN
WERE EIGHT EVAN TODAY. EIGHT A
G. AND THEY ARE INDEED.
DETERMINANTS OF ELIGIBLE SHE
BOTH OF THAT IN ORDER TO BE
ELIGIBLE. THE REASON WHY THIS
IS IMPORTANT. DO YOU THINK WHEN
I GET TO THE WRAP UP IS THAT.
INCREASING THE TEST SCORE
VERSES INCREASINGTHE GPA
REQUIREMENT SO IF YOU HAVE A-
JUST A NOTE SUPPORT BUT WE'LL
GET PRACTICE QUANTITATIVE
REASONING HERE. IF YOU HAVE TO
MEET IF YOU'RE TRYING TO GET TO
A 33% TARGET. AND YOU'RE
CURRENTLY AT THIRTY FOUR THIRTY
FIVE OR THIRTY EIGHT OR 40% IN
ORDER TO. REDUCE THAT THE THREE
TOOLS THAT WE HAVE HAD OUR TO
INCREASE THE NUMBER OF COURSES.
INCREASE THE GPA REQUIRED OR
INCREASE THE TEST SCORE
REQUIRED. AND SO AT A IF THAT
EQUATION IS GOING TO STAY THE
SAME THEN YOU DON'T HAVE FOUR
DEGREES OF FREEDOM. YOU CANNOT
PICK AN ELIGIBILITY TARGET PLUS
A TEST SCORE TARGET PLAZA. GPA
TARGET PLUS OF COURSE START
EVEN SOMETHING HAS TO VERY BE
VARIABLE. AND SO THIS IS BEEN
THE CONSTANT DEBATE SINCE THE
NINETEEN SIXTIES. AND IN THE
STATE IS ONE OF THE REASONS
WHY. ABOUT THE- UC AND THEN AND
LATER ON SEE IF YOU JUST
DETERMINE TO MOVE WITH THE
SUBJECT COURSE PATTERN AT THE
WEIGHT IN THE WAY THAT IT IS.
IS THAT THE ACADEMIC SENATE AND
UNIVERSITY MINISTRY. AND
LEGISLATORS ALL AGREED THAT IT
POLITICALLY EASIER TO DO THAT
THAN TO RACE THE TEST SCORE
REQUIREMENT OR THE GPA REPORT
OR THE GPA. CUT OFF SUPPORT.
AND SO THAT THIS THIS THIS
TENSION BETWEEN THESE DIFFERENT
FORMS OF ELIGIBILITY WAS BAKED
INTO THAT PLAN. BUT REMEMBER
IT'S BASIC MAKING THAT PLAN
BECAUSE THE PLAN. A FIRM REALLY
WHICH WAS INTENDED WHICH HE OF
A REDUCTION IN TOTAL IN TOTAL
OUT AND TOTAL ACCESS TO THE TO
THE SYSTEM. NOW FROM THAT FROM
FROM THE POINT OF THE
ACCREDITATION BY THE
UNIVERSITY. THE TWO PUBLIC
UNIVERSITY. OF HIGH SCHOOLS THE
TO PUBLIC UNIVERSITY OF AT
SIGNIFICANT EFFECT. THE CARD
LIMóN EXPECTATIONS OF THE CAKE
SYSTEM AND AT EACH POINT WHEN.
THE SUBJECT MATTER PATTERN WAS
CREATED. ALTHOUGH IT AT THAT
TIME IT WILL. WELCOME BY K.
TWELVE EDUCATION BECAUSE IT WAS
AT LEAST LESS RESTRICTIVE THAN
LADY OF THE LAKE IN THE
MERCHANT OF VENICE AND NOT NOT
TEACHING THE- CIRCUMFERENCE OF
THE CIRCLE. SO IT WAS A
RELAXATION OF THE OF THE- OF
THE HEAVY HANDED. CURRICULUM
AND INTERFERENCE OF THE
NIVERSITY AT THAT TIME. BUT
SINCE THAT POINT THAT THE
DEBATE HAS BEEN ABOUT ADDING
ADDITIONAL COURSES. AND ITS
IMPACT ON THE ON THE ABILITY OF
KATE WILL TO DELIVER. ON THE
ADVISABILITY OF WHETHER CABLE
SHOULD CHOOSE THAT PATTERN. AND
WHETHER OR NOT STUDENTS CAN CAN
CAN COOK. COMPLETED AND- AND SO
THAT THIS HAS BEEN THAT THE
DEBATE BEFORE THE LEGISLATURE
EVERY TIME WHEN THE WHEN THE-
WHEN THE- UNIVERSE A CALIFORNIA
AND SEE IF. THE DOCTOR THE
ELIGIBILITY INDEX THAT CSU HAD
PIONEERED. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
VASCONCELOS AND ASSEMBLY MEMBER
ASSEMBLY ONE TREATY HUGHES IS
THE CHAIR OF. THIS COMMITTEE.
HELD A LOT OF HEARINGS ON THAT
TOPIC SAYING THAT THE
ELIGIBILITY INDEX ITSELF THAT
COMBINATION. SCORES AND GPA WAS
GOING TO DRAMATICALLY REDUCE.
ACCESS FOR UNDER REPRESENTED
STUDENTS. AT THAT TIME AND THEN
THEY HELP THE ANOTHER SET A
LEGISLATOR HELD AN EQUIVALENT
HEARING THE FOLLOWING DECADE
WHEN CSU TURN THOSE. MARMOTS
UP. AND K. TWELVE A AND YOU'LL
HEAR A LOT. OF DEBATE
IMPERFECTIONS IN. CASCADE WILD.
IN GENERAL I HAVE TO MOST OF
THE CHANGE. ALTHOUGH OVERTIME.
AND SO HAVE STUDENTS A PART OF
THE PART OF THE POLICY QUESTION
THAT THAT YOU FACE IS. WHETHER
NOT THEY SHOULD. AND WHERE
THAT'S ADVISABLE. I THINK I
POINT OUT IT WHICH IS OFTEN
LOST IN THIS DISCUSSION IS
THAT. IT HAS WORKED IN THE
REVERSE TO. SO WHEN THE WHEN
THE K. TWELVE SAYS WHEN KATE
TWELVE DETERMINE. THEIR IN THE
FORTHCOMING CORD DROPPED THE
DROP FOR THE ELEVENTH GRADE
ASSESSMENT. THE CS USE ABILITY
TO OFFER THE EARLY. DEMOCRATS
OUT. ALSO DISAPPEARED SORT OF
UNBEKNOWNST TO THEM. AT AT THE
LAST. MOMENT THE ADOPTION OF
THE CALIFORNIA HIGH SCHOOL EXIT
EXAM WHICH HAD. TAX EVASION
RATES ALSO AFFECTED
ELIGIBILITY. NOW WHY BECAUSE
WHEN YOU WHENEVER YOU WERE YOU
AFFECT THE GRADUATION RATE.
YOUR AFFECTING THE L. BECAUSE
THE ELDERLY RATE IS JUST IT IS
A RATE. WE TEND TO THINK ABOUT
ELIGIBILITY BEING ABOUT A GROUP
OF PEOPLE. WHICH IT IS OF
COURSE BUT IT IS ALSO ABOUT THE
NOMINATOR OF THE HIGH SCHOOL
GRADUATION RATE. IT'S OF THEIR
FEWER HIGH SCHOOL GRADUATES
BECAUSE OF MORE PEOPLE CANNOT
GET TO THE DIPLOMA DUE TO THE-
HIGH SCHOOL EXIT EXAM. A LARGER
SHARE OF THEM ARE LIKE ARE
GOING TO BE ELIGIBLE. FOR THE
ADOPTION OF THE HIGH SCHOOL
EXIT EXAM WHICH WAS NOT A
COLLABORATION AMONG EDUCATION
VERY FEW THINGS EVER ARE
BETWEEN K. TWELVE HIGHER ED.
AFFECT DROVE UP THE ELIGIBILITY
RATE WHICH THEN FORCED YOU SEEN
SEATS YOU TO THINK ABOUT
WHETHER OR NOT. THEY NEED TO
INCREASE THEIR ADMISSION
STANDARDS IN ORDER TO DEAL WITH
THAT. THE COMBINATION OF BOTH
OF THOSE DRAMATICALLY CUT
AFFECTED. THE AMOUNT OF PEOPLE
IN THE ELIGIBILITY PULLS BUT IT
IS IMPORTANT TO DISTINGUISH
BETWEEN. THE SIZE OF THE POOL
AND THE RATE THE NUMBER THAT IT
IS RELATIVE TO THAT. 33% THAT
IS IN THAT IS IN THE MASTER
PLAN. SO THAT THAT THAT THAT'S
COME BACK AND FORTH BETWEEN
BETWEEN THIS AND EVEN THE H. AG
FOR ALL MOVEMENT. ON THAT
THAT'S WHAT MUCH OF CALIFORNIA
THE LAST FIFTEEN YEARS. HAS
THAT SAME EFFECT TO THE EXTENT
THAT EVERY STUDENT IN SAN JOSE.
OR LOS ANGELES OR SAN FRANCISCO
IS EXPECTED TO COMPLETE. A TO
G. CORRECT I'M FOR YOU TO SEE
AN FOR CSU. THAT IF EVERYONE
DOES AT THE GRADUATE THEN
BECOMES NO LONGER A SORT
MACINNES. FOR L. ELIGIBLE.
DETERMINAR GREAT I BY. A AND
SCORES. SO I BET BYE BACK NOT
GIVING YOU ANY ANSWER. TO
SIMPLY TO POINT OUT THIS THIS
FUNDAMENTAL TENSION THAT EXISTS
ON TWO LEVELS ONE IS BETWEEN.
BETWEEN GPA TEST SCORES AND THE
SUBJECT PATTERN AND THE SECOND
IS THE TENSION BETWEEN. ACCESS
AND THE ELIGIBILITY THE IDEA OF
THE ELIGIBILITY POOLS AS A
STATE POLICY UNCODIFIED STATE
POLICY REDUCES THE TOTAL AMOUNT
OF ACCESS TO HIGHER EDUCATION
SAID THE UNIVERSITY SYSTEMS IN
IN CALIFORNIA. THE GOVERNANCE
ISSUES HAVE ALSO CHANGED SO IN
THE IN THE NINETEEN SIXTIES
DURING THE MASTER PLAN PROCESS
IT WAS THE TWO ACADEMIC
SENATE'S OF THE INSTRUCTIONS
THAT STILL HAD PRIMACY OVER
ADMISSIONS POLICY. THAT'S ONE
OF THE REASONS WHY THE
ELIGIBILITY POLLS WERE NOT PUT
INTO STATUTE WAS THERE WAS A
RECOGNITION BY THE LEGISLATURE
AND BY. THE BOARDS OF THE
REGIONS IN THE TRUSTEES THAT
THAT THAT EL ADMISSIONS WHAT'S
FUNDAMENTALLY AN ACADEMIC
POLICY MATTER AND THEREFORE
SHOULD BE IS A SHOULD BE
PROTECTED AGAINST INTERFERENCE
BY. THE BY THE PLEASURE IN THE
IN THE SEVENTIES HOWEVER AS
MORE CAMPUS IT BECAME IMPACTED
ACADEMIC SENATE'S COULD NO
LONGER CONDUCT ALL OF
ADMISSIONS POLICY PRACTICE BY
THEMSELVES. AND SO DID THE
DELEGATION OF DECISIONS ABOUT
WHO TO SELECT FROM THE
ELIGIBILITY POOL AT BERKELEY OR
UCLA OR AT SAN DIEGO STATE
BEGAN TO BE DELEGATED FROM. THE
ACADEMIC SENATE STATEWIDE DOWN
TWO CAMPUSES AND THE ROLE OF
THE ADMINISTRATION IN
ADMISSIONS POLICIES AND
IMPLEMENTATION STARTED TO RISE
AND SO THAT TODAY IT'S A MIX OF
BOTH THE SENATE'S PLAY A
SIGNIFICANT ROLE IN. THE IN THE
BROAD POLICY OF ADMISSIONS BUT
THERE IS A SIGNIFICANT
ADMINISTRATIVE ROLE IN IN IN IN
IN IN IN THEIR IMPLEMENTATION
AND THE CHOICES THAT ARE MADE.
THE SECOND THING THAT OCCURRED
TO THE SECOND AB PATTERN THAT
OCCURRED WAS IN THE SEVENTIES
AND EIGHTIES A STRONG EFFORT BY
MEMBERS OF LEGISLATURE TO IT TO
ENCOURAGE DIVERSIFICATION OF
THE MISSIONS POOL. THAT WAS AN
ISSUE IN NINETEEN IN THE
SIXTIES BUT BUT RELATIVELY
RELATIVELY MODEST IN THE
SEVENTIES AND EIGHTIES IT
BECAME A SIGNIFICANT ISSUE THE
LEGISLATURE PASSED. A
CONCURRENT RESOLUTIONS AND ONE
STATUTE SORT OF ESTABLISHING
THAT IT WAS THE GOAL THAT THIS
THAT THE TWO UNIVERSITIES
SHOULD STRIVE TO APPROXIMATE A
REFLECT ON THE POPULATION OF
CALIFORNIA POPULATION HIGH
SCHOOL GRADUATES. IT AT
DIFFERENT TIMES THEY THEY DID
NOT CHOOSE. TO PASS A LAW
MANDATING A SPECIFIC SET OF
ADMISSIONS POLICIES BUT THEY
SAID. THAT AS A AS AN IMPORTANT
WAS THE FIRST TIME THE
LEGISLATURE HAD SERIOUSLY BEEN
INVOLVED IN ADMISSIONS POLICY.
IN QUITE A LONG TIME AND THEN
MORE PERHAPS MORE NOTORIOUSLY
AT THE TURN OF THE CENTURY
WHEN. IF THE REGION'S A
PARTICULAR SB ONE THE READ WHEN
THE REGION'S ADOPTED THEIR
POLICY TO ESSENTIALLY TO REVOKE
ALL OF THE AFFIRMATIVE ACTION
POLICIES. IN AN EXECUTIVE ORDER
BY THE GOV BY GOVERNOR WILSON
AT THAT TIME ESSENTIALLY
ORDERING HIGHER EDUCATION TO
STOP USING RACE AS A FACTOR IN
ADMISSIONS. CAUSED OTHER TO BE
BOTH SIGNIFICAN ABOUT PUT WHAT
WHAT THE CONSTRUCTION MIKE
CONTEMPLATED POLITICAL
INTERFERENCE IN EMISSIONS BUT
ALSO A LOT OF PUSH BACK ABOUT
THAT IT THAT THAT QUESTION AS
WELLSO. THE LESSON AROUND GOOD
GOVERNANCE IS THAT THE ECONOMIC
SENATE'S AND FACULTY OF
TRADITIONALLY HAD THAT RESPOND
TO BE THEY CONTINUE TO DO SO.
BUT THERE HAVE BEEN ON ALL
SIDES OF THIS OF THIS QUESTION
THERE HAVE BEEN SOME. SOME
ABRASIONS AROUND THE EDGES SO
IF. I COULD JUST LEAVE IT THAT
THAT THAT THAT THINK THINK
THINK THE TO KEEP POLICY
QUESTIONS I THINK THAT THAT
THAT OUR THAT OUR HEAD OF YOU
BRIT LARGE AGAIN I'M I'M NOT AN
EXPERT ON THAT YOUR ISSUE AT
ALL. ONE IS THERE THE ROLE OF
THE UNIVERSITIES IN. THE
GUIDANCE OF K. TWELVE UP BOTH
DISTRICTS AND SCHOOLS BUT ALSO
STUDENTS AND EXPERIENCES IN THE
CHOICES THAT THEY ARE MAKING IN
K. TWELVE. AND THE THERE THE
RECORD IS. IS NEXT AND POSITIVE
AND NEGATIVE ALL THE WAY
THROUGH HISTORY BUT THERE'S BUT
THIS IS A POLICY CHOICE FOR THE
LEGISLATURE TO BE CONSIDERING.
AND THE SECOND IS. IS THE ARE
THE ELIGIBILITY PULLS
THEMSELVES AND- WE HAVE AS WITH
WE'VE TAKEN AS THE AS THE
GOSPEL BUT NOT GOSPEL ENOUGH TO
WRITE THE STATUTE. THAT NO
MATTER WHAT WE WILL ALWAYS BE
SETTING THE POOL OF BY A YOUNG
BE OF YOUNG PEOPLE CALIFORNIA
THAT CAN GOING TO THE TO
UNIVERSITIES BASED ON. A FIXED
PROPORTION OF HIGH SCHOOL
GRADUATES NO MATTER HOW WELL
PREPARED THEY ARE. NO NO MATTER
HOW MUCH MORE ADVANCED THEY
MIGHT BE FROM A GENERATION AGO
WE'RE ALWAYS GOING TO HAVE THIS
FIXED LIMITATION FROM THE
TWELVE AND HAVE IN THE THIRD.
BACK IN THE NINETEEN EIGHTIES
TREES USE KERRY. LEGISLATION TO
CHANGE THE TWELVE AND A HALF
215% AND. 33% OF THE TO THIRTY
FIVE. THE LEGISLATURE IS DOLLY
WITH THIS ISSUE BEFORE BUT THE
COST IMPLICATIONS ARE NOT.
TRIVIAL EITHER AND SO. THE
POLICY QUESTIONS BEFORE YOU
REALLY IS. THAT FUNDAMENTAL IS
ONE OF THEM IS THIS FUNDAMENTAL
QUESTION ABOUT THE ELIGIBILITY
POOLS BECAUSE WE DON'T DEAL
WITH THEM. THEN YOU WILL
CONSTANTLY DEALING WITH WELL
WHAT ARE THE RATIONING
MECHANISMS WHAT ARE THE SORTING
MECHANISMS IF IT'S NOT SUBJECT
COURSES. IS A G. P. A.'S BUT
NOT GPA SHOULD BE TEST SCORES.
AND ALL OF THEM HAVE SOME
CHALLENGES THAT ARE FOR OR IN
FRONT OF YOU SO. THANK YOU FOR
HAVING THIS CHEN HAPPY TO TAKE
ANY QUESTIONS IF YOU HAPPEN.
GOOD LUCK. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. OF FOR YOUR
INSIGHTFUL AND EDUCATIONAL
PRESENTATION. AS CHAIR OF
HIGHER EDUCATION I HAVE VISITED
MANY CSU CAMPUSES. AND I AFFIRM
THE WORK OF THE DEDICATED
FACULTY ADMINISTRATION AND
STAFF WELL IT MISSION NUMBERS
REFLECT THE GROWTH AND CSU I
KNOW THAT MANY STUDENTS WERE
ELIGIBLE WERE TURNED AWAY. DUE
TO CAPACITY ISSUES. KNOWING
THAT WE WANT KNOWING THAT WE
WANT MORE STUDENTS TO EARN A
COLLEGE DEGREE. DOCTOR GO BALD
AND DO YOU BELIEVE THERE IS
ROOM AND CSU TO ACCEPT MORE
STUDENTS. AND IF SO IS THERE A
WAY THAT WE CAN CREATIVELY
UPDATE THE MASTER PLAN TO
CHANGE THE NEEDS FOR THIS
CENTURY AND THE DIVERSE
POPULATION OF STUDENTS WE NOW
HAVE. THE ADDICT WHAT WHAT WE
WHAT WE LEARNED DURING THE
NATIONAL IMPAIRED AND SENSES
THAT THE SYSTEMS ARE SCALABLE
I'M AT THE ELIGIBILITY LEVEL
INTO THE WHETHER OR NOT YOU CAN
CREATE MORE SAN DIEGO STATES IN
UCLA'S STRESSED OUT OF WITH THE
SNAP OF FINGERS IS A- THAT'S A
DIFFERENT QUESTION. BUT IN
TERMS OF THE ELIGIBLE IT'S
SERVING THE ELIGIBLE GRADUATES
IN CALIFORNIA IN SOME WAY THE
OVER AND OVER AGAIN THIS THE
STATE AND THE SYSTEMS HAVE HAVE
PROVEN THAT THEY CAN'T SCALE.
AND IN THE IN THE TIDAL WAVE TO
WHEN THAT WAS APPROACHING AND
THE LEGISLATURE'S GRAPPLING
WITH EXACTLY THE SAME ISSUES AS
I SAID CENTER ASSEMBLYMEMBER
HUGHES DID CARRY LEGISLATION TO
EXPAND ELIGIBILITY POLLS AND AT
THAT TIME BOTH THE UNIVERSITY
CALIFORNIA AND THE CALIFORNIA.
STATE UNIVERSITY CAME FORWARD
WITH WITH BURKE WITH PLANS TO
CONSTRUCT MANY MORE CAMPUSES
YOU SEE THREE AT ONCE IN THE IN
THE NINETEEN NINETIES NOT THAT
ALL RIGHT GOT REDUCED AND
MERCED. BUT THE POINT IS THAT
THE POLICY CONVERSATION
WHIZZING WAS FULLY ENGAGED
BETWEEN STATE GOVERNMENT AND
THE TO UNIVERSITY SYSTEMS ABOUT
THEIR ABILITY TO SCALE TO THINK
ABOUT SOMETHING OTHER THAN JUST
THE MAGIC ARBITRARINESS OF THE
OF. THE OF THE 33% ELIGIBILITY.
FOR NINETEEN SIXTY. AND ONE
MORE QUESTION I WAS A HISTORY
TEACHER. AT THE AT THE HIGH
SCHOOL. AND AS I LOOK AT UNITED
STATES HISTORY. AS IT PERTAINS
TO THE RIGHT TO VOTE. IN THE IN
THE UNITED STATES IT HAS BEEN A
MOVEMENT FROM VERY LIMITED. TO
EXPAND IN THE RIGHT TO VOTE
RIGHT GOING FROM JUST PROPERTY
OWNERS WHITE PROPERTY MAIL
OWNERS OF PROPERTY. RIGHT TO
GIVING AFRICAN AMERICAN MEN.
WOMEN THE RIGHT TO VOTE
EXPANDING THAT RIGHT I HAVE
SEEN IN CALIFORNIA AND THE
UNITED STATES THE SAME KIND OF
TRAJECTORY. IN WHO DO WE THINK
WOULD BENEFIT FROM GOING TO
COLLEGE. RIGHT WHEN COLLEGES
WERE FIRST CREATED. WE HAD YOU
KNOW HARVARD IN THE IVY LEAGUE
IN PRINCETON WHERE IT WAS.
BASICALLY WEALTHY MAN WHAT THE
AGAIN WEALTHY WHITE MEN GOING
TO COLLEGE WE'VE EXPANDED THAT
AND WE'VE DONE THAT
HISTORICALLY. THE SAME
PROJECTOR. EXCEPT FOR THE YOU
KNOW MAYBE THAT THAT AS YOU
POINTED OUT THAT TIME IN
CALIFORNIA'S HISTORY WHERE WE
WENT BACK ON DIVERSITY WITH THE
BACCHAE DECISION AND PROP TWO
OH NINE. IT'S BEEN A MOVEMENT
THAT DIRECTION. WOULD YOU LIKE
TO WAY AND COULD YOU WEIGH IN
ON WHAT YOU THINK THIS A
PROPOSAL BY CSU WHICH WAY DOES
THAT MOVES. NO I DEFINITELY
WOULD NOT LIKE TO WAIT. WAIT
WAIT WAIT IN ON ON ON THAT
POINT BUT IF YOU YOU KNOW I
MENTIONED EARLIER I THINK THAT
IF EVERYONE IN SAN JOSE OR LA
OR THE DISTRICTS THAT HAVE
ADOPTED A TO G. FOR ALL IF
EVERYONE COMPLETES A TO G. AND
GRADUATES AND ACHIEVE THAT GPA.
AND TEST SCORE STAYED THE SAME
THEN WHAT IS THE POLICY BASIS
FOR SAYING THAT I'D SMALLER
PERCENTAGE OF THEM SHOULD NOT
BE GOING ON TO UNIVERSITY I
THINK THAT'S THAT IN OTHER THAN
THE PARTICULAR CONDITIONS OF
NINETEEN FIFTY NINE IN NINETEEN
SIXTEEN CALIFORNIA TERMS OF
TAXATION AND- THE WAR AND
EVERYTHING ELSE WHAT OTHER
REASON IS THERE. OF FOR DOING
THAT SO IT I THINK IN SOME SUCH
AS IT'S EVEN WORSE THAN WHAT
YOU'VE DESCRIBED IN THAT IN
THAT STUDENTS HAVE BEEN
STUDENTS FROM THE FROM THESE
VARIOUS BACKGROUNDS IN PLACES
IN CALIFORNIA HAVE BEEN
ACHIEVING AT LEVELS THAT. ARE
TWENTY OR THIRTY OR FORTY OR
SIXTY YEARS AGO WOULD HAVE BEEN
SEEN AS NICK NICK YOU KNOW NEAR
GENIUS ACHIEVEMENTS THE LEVEL
OF BOTH SUBJECT MATTER
COMPLETION GRADES AND TEST
SCORES. AND YET WE HAVE
PRODUCED IN WITH KEPT UP WE'VE
ARTIFICER MARK ARBITRARILY KEPT
DOWN THE TOTAL NUMBER SO WHAT.
YOU'RE SAYING IS THAT WHILE
ACHIEVEMENT HAS GONE UP. THE
NUMBER OF STUDENTS WHO WERE
ELIGIBLE AS REMAIN SOMEWHAT
CONSTANT. YES THAT BUT BY
DEFINITION IT'S IF YOU IF YOU
LOOK AT THE AT AND I'M I'M
SORRY I DON'T HAVE A WHITE
BOARD BUT- I MEAN IF YOU LOOK
AT THAT AND MA'AM I'M SURE
SOMEBODY ELSE BY THE TESTIMONY
LATER BUT IF YOU LOOK AT THE
TRAJECTORY OF STUDENT
ELIGIBILITY OVERTIME. WELL I
MEAN WHAT YOU SEE IS THERE IS A
RISE AS STUDENT AT SCHOOLS AND
STUDENTS ACHIEVE. HIGHER AND
HIGHER LEVELS OF EXPECTATIONS.
SCORES GRADES AND COURSE
COMPLETIONS. RISING AND GETS
ABOVE 33% OF THE THIRTY FIVE IS
A THIRTY SIX. AND THEN OF
POLICY THAN A SOMETHING CHANGES
EITHER THE INDEX GOES UP TEST
SCORES AND GPA OR OF COURSE
GETS OR OR TWO OR THREE GETS
ADDED. AND IT IMPLEMENTS. AND
IT'S OUR STRIDES BACK AGAIN.
AND THEN IT HAS TO BE KEPT
UNDER CONTROL THAT IMPLEMENTS
AGAIN IT'S A THIS IS THE STORY
OF. OF ADMISSIONS. IN SOME
SENSE IT'S A ADDS THAT HAPPENED
A BOTH UC AND CSU BUT IT'S A
STARKER PICTURE AT CSU. BECAUSE
WHAT WE'VE SEEN OVER TIME IS
THAT STUDENTS. STERN TO SCHOOLS
HAVE DONE HAVE HAVE RESPONDED
BETTER TO SEE IF YOU. THAT THAT
THEIR LEVEL THEIR RATES OF
IMPROVEMENT. IN IN A TREATMENT
ALONG WITH MANY OF THESE
INDICATORS HAVE BEEN BETTER
THAN YOU SEE AND SO. SEE IF YOU
EVERY TIME THEY'VE MADE ONE OF
THESE CHANGES STUDENTS HAVE.
FIRST DECLINE IN THE REBOUND
AND GOD EVEN FARTHER WHERE'S
THE UC LINE IS MUCH MORE SMOOTH
WITH OTHER OVERTIME. YEAH THERE
HAS BEEN A SIGNIFICANT INCREASE
IN IN IN IN ACHIEVEMENT MARRIED
WITH CHANGING THE DEMOGRAPHY OF
CALIFORNIA. THAT TOGETHER WOULD
HAVE PRODUCED A MUCH LOW IF YOU
SAID HERE'S THE STANDARD THE
STANDARD OF ACADEMIC SUCCESS NO
PREPARATION. NINETY STATE THAT.
TODAY WOULD HAVE BEEN MANY MANY
MANY TENS OF THOUSANDS MORE
STUDENTS WHO WOULD BE WHO WOULD
MEET THAT STANDARD. BUT. NOT
ELIGIBLE BE IT'S AN ARTIFICIAL.
IT'S AN ARTIFICIAL REYES. YEAH
I KNOW CAN GO FOR THIS FOR. A
COUPLE HOURS THAT BUT I'M
INTEREST THE NEXT POINT BUT I
GUESS THIS REALLY IS THE KEY
QUESTION IS THAT. IS POINT.
THEY WERE TALKING ABOUT TODAY
AWAY TO RATION ACCESS. OR IS IT
REALLY. A TOOL TO HELP THE
STUDENTS ARE GOING TO CSU.
GRADUATE IN FOUR YEARS. HAVE A
REALIZATION WITH THE ECONOMIC
NEEDS OF OUR GRADUATES BUT HE
HAS NOT LOST UPON YOU THAT THAT
REPORT THAT I THINK SEE IF THEY
GIVE US A COUPLE. YEARS AGO
TALKING ABOUT. AT A TIME WHEN
THE UNIVERSITY IN OUR- STUDENTS
ARE ARE THE MOST DIVERSE EVER
IS THIS TIME WORST SCHOOL IS.
YOU KNOW THE MORE EXPENSIVE
THAN EVER. IT'S MORE MORE
DIFFICULT TO GET INTO THE
UNIVERSITY SETTING. BUT BUT I
THINK THAT IF YOU LOOK AT THAT
THE DEGREE. GAP WHERE WE NEED
MORE MORE COLLEGE GRADUATES.
AND MORE AND MORE STUDENTS ARE
GRADUATING THROUGH HIGH SCHOOL
WITH THEIR A TO G. REQUIREMENTS
IT IT IT TALKS ABOUT. YOU KNOW
DO WE NEED TO RE LOOK AT OUR
THOSE 33% NUMBERS. ARBITRARY
AND I THINK THAT WHAT WHAT THIS
PROPOSAL SOME WOULD SAY IS THIS
JUST A WAY. TO MANAGE WITHIN
THE 33% RIGHT. IN OTHER WORDS
IF YOU HAD IF THE IF THE CAT IF
A WHAT IF WE IF WE WERE. HAD
MONEY TO ACCEPT ALL ELIGIBLE
STUDENTS AND HAD A POLICY THE
DICK THAT ACCEPTED. THE TOP 50%
WOULD BE REALLY BECOMING FOR
WITH THIS PROPOSAL. AND I GUESS
THAT'S FOR THE NEXT PANEL BUT.
YOU WANT TO FIND UPON THAT YEAH
I MEAN I THINK THAT THE END OF
IT THAT IS A PART OF THE
QUESTION I DON'T HAVE THE
ANSWER TO THAT BUT YOU'RE BUT I
BUT I DO WANT TO UNDERSCORE
YOU'RE YOU'RE EXACTLY RIGHT
BOTH OF THESE FACTORS ARE IN
PLACE SO YOU'LL HEAR. THE AND I%
WAS REALLY NOT THE ONLY THING
DRIVING THIS QUESTION
PREPARATION AROUND QUANTITATIVE
REASONING IS ALSO AND DO YOU
KNOW TO BE BALANCED AND THAT
THAT THE HISTORY OF THIS AS HAS
BEEN THAT STUDENTS HAVE. TWO
TWO EIGHT TWO EIGHT EIGHT
NONTRIVIAL EXTENT ADJUSTED AND
MET THE EXPECTATIONS THAT HAVE
BEEN RISEN HAVE RISEN EVERY
SINGLE TIME. WHETHER OR NOT
IT'S SHOULD BE THE CSU BOARD
THAT MAKES THAT DETERMINATION
FOR SCHOOLS AND FOR AND FOR
YOUNG PEOPLE AND WHETHER OR NOT
WHILE THE BOLLOCKS DIPPING YOU
KNOW WHO'S WHO'S LOST THROUGH
WHO FALL THROUGH THE CRACKS
OTHER STILL POLICY QUESTION FOR
YOU. BUT BOTH OF THESE BOTH OF
THESE ARE IN PLAY BECAUSE THAT
THAT THE CHANCE IF YOU IS
SIGNIFICANTLY ABOVE
INTELLIGIBILITY TARGET TODAY
AND SO IF THEY DON'T USE
COURSES AND YOU DON'T CHANGE
THE ELIGIBILITY POOLS. THE
UNDER UNDER THE MASTER PLAN
THEN UNLESS A NEW A NEW
RATIONING DEVICES IS ADMITTED
AND THEN THEN WE'RE INVITING
THEM TO SAY THAT THAT THE TEST
SCORE. A THRESHOLD OR THE GPA
THRESHOLD SHOULD SHOULD GO UP
ON ABSENT A NEW TOOL. OKAY
THANK. YOU WELL THANK YOU FOR
COMING BACK. TO THE CAPITAL.
CHECK WE WILL THEN BRING UP.
THE NEXT PANEL. LOOKING INTO
THE QUANTITATIVE REASONING AND
SEE AS USE RATIONALE BEHIND THE
PROPOSAL SO I'D LIKE TO INVITE
UP NATHAN EVANS CHIEF OF STAFF
AND SENIOR ADVISER ACADEMIC AND
STUDENT AFFAIRS JAMES MINOR
ASSISTANT VICE CHANCELLORS
SENIOR STRATEGIST FOR ACADEMIC
SUCCESS AND INCLUSIVE
EXCELLENCE. AND MARK HE. BUT
KEEP THE GRANT MY CHINA GRAY
KNOWN SHY THANK YOU SYSTEM VICE
CHANCELLOR EDUCATOR PREPARATION
AND PUBLIC SCHOOL PROGRAMS.
WELCOME THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
NATHAN EVANS AND I SERVE AS
SAID CHIEF OF STAFF AND SENIOR
ADVISER FOR ACADEMIC AND
STUDENT AFFAIRS AT THE
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY
OFFICE THE CHANCELLOR JOINING
ME THIS AFTERNOON AS YOU'VE
HEARD DOCTOR MARKET AGREE NOT
SHIRE SYSTEM BY CHANCE A
PREDICATE OUR PREPARATION AND
PUBLIC SCHOOL PROGRAMS AND DR
JAMES MINOR SYSTEM VICE
CHANCELLOR AND SENIOR
STRATEGIST WE ARE DEEPLY
APPRECIATIVE OF GERMANY AS
INTEREST IN THIS TOPIC AND FOR
CONVENING THIS HEARING TODAY.
AS THE LARGEST AND MOST DIVERSE
FOUR YEAR PUBLIC UNIVERSITY
SYSTEM IN THE NATION THE
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY. IS
COMMITTED TO COMPLETELY
ELIMINATING EQUITY GAPS. THE
GAPS BETWEEN DEGREE PAYMENT FOR
STUDENTS FROM HISTORICALLY
UNDER REPRESENTED COMMUNITIES
IN THEIR PEERS AT ALL LEVELS OF
THE UNIVERSITY. ONE OF THE
GREATEST HURDLES TO COLLEGE
DEGREE ATTAINMENT IS A STUDENTS
LEVEL OF ACADEMIC PREPARATION
FOR COLLEGE LEVEL COURSEWORK
UPON ENTRY. AND US IT WAS THE
FIRST AREA OF FOCUS FOR US IN
THE TWENTY IN TWENTY FIFTEEN AS
PART OF GRADUATION INITIATIVE
TWENTY TWENTY FIVE.
QUANTITATIVE REASONING SKILLS
ARE NECESSARY FOR THE TWENTY
FIRST CENTURY LEARNER. AND TO
BE SUCCESSFUL IN THE EMERGING
AND CHANGING FUTURE OF WORK NO
MATTER THE JOB OR BUSINESS
SECTOR. SIMPLY PUT QUANTITATIVE
REASONING IS THE ABILITY AND
THE PRACTICE OF THINKING AND
REASONING ANALYTICALLY AND
INTELLIGENTLY ABOUT
MEASUREMENT. DIMENSIONS
DESIGNED CAPACITY OR
PROBABILITY BOTH PERSONALLY AND
PROFESSIONALLY THROUGHOUT LIFE
TODAY. MORE IMPORTANTLY IT'S AN
INCREASINGLY COME IN IN A MORE
INCREASINGLY COMPLEX FUTURE OF
WORK IN SOCIETY. I WANT TO
REITERATE THE QUANTITATIVE
REASONING IS NOT NECESSARILY
SYNONYMOUS WITH MATHEMATICS ALL
TOO OFTEN WE'VE HEARD THIS
DISTILLED INTO A CONVERSATION
ABOUT A FOURTH YEAR OF MATH AND
THAT IT IS NOT. RATHER IT'S THE
CONFLUENCE OF CRITICAL THINKING
MATHEMATICS AND REAL WORLD
APPLICATION. QUANTITATIVE
REASONING SKILLS REPRESENT ONE
OF THE GREATEST DISPARITIES
AMONG INCOMING COLLEGE STUDENTS
TO OFTEN QUANTITATIVE REASONING
PREPARATION DISPARITIES IN K.
TWELVE SCHOOLS EXACERBATE
EQUITY GAPS THE PAULA STUDENTS
TO COLLEGE. AND INFLUENCE THEIR
ACADEMIC AND CAREER OPTIONS.
STUDENTS WITH ADDITIONAL
QUANTITATIVE REASONING
PREPARATION HIGH SCHOOL IN
EVERY REGION OF THE COUNTRY AND
ACROSS ALL ETHNIC GROUPS
EXPERIENCE GREATER SUCCESS IN
COLLEGE. THIS PREPARATION ALSO
PREPARE STUDENTS FOR THE WORK
FORCE REGARDLESS OF THEIR FIELD
OF INTEREST. THE C. ISSUES
ABILITY TO PRODUCE A GREATER
NUMBER OF DIVERSE COLLEGE
GRADUATES PREPARED FOR A RANGE
OF PROFESSIONS IS NOT ONLY
IMPORTANT FOR THE INDIVIDUAL
STUDENTS BUT ALSO FOR THE
FUTURE OF CALIFORNIA. IMPROVING
STUDENT SUCCESS AND CLOSING
EQUITY GAPS ACROSS A LARGE
UNIVERSITY SYSTEM REQUIRES
COURAGEOUS LEADERSHIP AND BOLD
ACTION THAT ADVANCES THE METRIC
MISSION OF THE INSTITUTION. THE
PROPOSAL THAT WOULD BE BEFORE
THE BOARD OF TRUSTEES WILL HELP
ACHIEVE EDUCATIONAL EQUITY BY
ENSURING THAT A GREATER NUMBER
OF STUDENTS FROM ALL
BACKGROUNDS ARRIVE AT THE C.
ISSUE BETTER PREPARED FOR A
DIVERSE RANGE OF MAJORS AND
CAREER PATHS. THE GOAL IS TO
EXPAND ACCESS AND EQUITY FOR
ALL STUDENTS TO ACHIEVE THEIR
PERSONAL AND PROFESSIONAL GOALS
RATHER THAN LIMITING THEIR
OPPORTUNITIES AT THE POINT OF
COLLEGE ADMISSION BECAUSE OF
LIMITED PREPARATION. FOR
PARTICULAR MAJORS DURING HIGH
SCHOOL. THE C. ISSUE HAS A LONG
HISTORY OF WORKING CLOSELY WITH
OUR K. TWELVE PARTNERS IN
COMMUNITY COLLEGE PARTNERS TO
PUT IMPROVE ACCESS AND SUCCESS
IN COLLEGE. FROM A
GROUNDBREAKING HIGH SCHOOL
SENIOR ENGLISH COURSE CO
DEVELOPED MORE THAN A DECADE
AGO BY SEE ISSUE IN HIGH SCHOOL
FACULTY. NOW OFFERED A MORE
THAN A THOUSAND HIGH SCHOOLS
STATEWIDE TO THE MORE THAN
SEVENTY MILLION ANNUAL
INVESTMENT IN K. TWELVE
OUTREACH. TO SEE ISSUES
EDUCATIONAL OPPORTUNITY PROGRAM
WHICH IS CELEBRATING ITS
FIFTIETH YEAR. OUR COMMITMENT
AND PARTNERSHIP TO ADDRESS
EDUCATIONAL EQUITY ARE EMBEDDED
IN THE MISSION INTERACTIONS
EACH DAY. IN THE COURSE OF ALL
OF OUR COMMENTS TODAY MY
COLLEAGUES AND I WILL PROVIDE
AN OVERVIEW OF THE PROPOSED
CHANGE IN FIRST YEAR ADMISSION
REQUIREMENTS BEGINNING IN%
TWENTY TWENTY SIX. UNDER
CONSIDERATION BY THE BOARD OF
TRUSTEES. SURE THE CONTEXT ON
THE RESEARCH DATA AND RATIONALE
UNDERPINNING THE PROPOSAL.
ADDRESS THE INPUT ANTICIPATED
AT IMPACT ON FUTURE STUDENTS.
AND PROVIDE AN OVERVIEW OF
EXISTING AND PLANNED SUPPORTS
FOR SCHOOLS AND STUDENTS
UNDERTAKEN BY THE SEA ISSUE.
LET ME BEGIN WITH THE PROPOSAL
ITSELF. AS YOU'VE HEARD AND YOU
KNOW THIS CSU AND UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA CURRENTLY REQUIRE A
MINIMUM OF FIFTEEN SUBJECT
AREAS FOR ADMISSIONS. AS A
FIRST YEAR STUDENT FOLLOWING
HIGH SCHOOL KNOWN TODAY AS A
THROUGH G. REQUIREMENTS. THESE
SUBJECT AREAS INCLUDE FOUR
YEARS OF ENGLISH THREE YEARS OF
MATHEMATICS TWO YEARS OF
SCIENCE TWO YEARS OF SOCIAL
SUCH SOCIAL STUDIES OR HISTORY.
TWO YEARS OF A LANGUAGE OTHER
THAN ENGLISH ONE YEAR OF VISUAL
PERFORMING ARTS AND ONE
ADDITIONAL COLLEGE PREP
PREPARATORY ELECTED. AGAIN THIS
TOTALS FIFTEEN SUBJECT REQUIRE
REQUIRED OVER FOUR YEARS OF
HIGH SCHOOL. OF IMPORTANT NOTE
THE AVERAGE BOTH MEDIAN AND
MEAN. NUMBER OF EIGHT THREE G.
COURSES COMPLETED BY STUDENTS
WHO ENROLL AT THE CSU TODAY IS
ALREADY TWENTY ONE COURSES. SIX
MORE THAN THAT MINIMUM. THE CSU
IS PROPOSING TO REQUIRE THE
COMPLETION OF ONE QUANTITATIVE
REASONING COURSE. BEYOND THE
EXISTING TO YOUR SCIENCE
REQUIREMENT AND THE THREE YOUR
MATH REQUIREMENT. FOR A TOTAL
OF SIXTEEN A TO G. COURSES SO
EFFECTIVELY WE'RE ASKING
STUDENTS WITHIN THAT TWENTY ONE
COURSE AVERAGE. TO ADJUST THAT
REMAINING FIVE COURSES TO TAKE
ONE QUANTITATIVE REASONING
WITHIN THOSE. THE PROPOSED
REQUIREMENT COULD BE FILLED
WITH AN ADDITIONAL HI YEAR OF
HIGH SCHOOL SCIENCE. AND
ELECTED WITH QUANTITATIVE
REASONING FOUNDATIONS SUCH AS
PERSONAL FINANCE DATA SCIENCE
OR COMPUTER SCIENCE OR A MORE
TRADITIONAL MATHEMATICS COURSE
BEYOND ALGEBRA TWO LIKE
STATISTICS THERE ARE A NUMBER
OF EXAMPLES IN THE HAND OUT WE
SHARED. IT CAN ALSO BE MET WITH
A QUANTITATIVELY BASED COURSE
OFFERED TO CAREER TECHNICAL
EDUCATION LIKE AGRIBUSINESS
GAME DESIGN SPORTS MEDICINE OR
ACCOUNTING. OR TO DO ONE MOMENT
IN PARTNERSHIP WITH LOCAL
COMMUNITY COLLEGES ONLINE
VERSIONS OF COURSES MAY ALSO BE
AN OPTION FOR MANY STUDENTS.
THE IDEAS THAT HIGH SCHOOL
STUDENTS TAKE THE NEXT
APPROPRIATE QUANTITATIVE
REASONING COURSE DISTRICT IN
PREPARATION FOR COLLEGE LEVEL
COURSE WORK AND CAREER
READINESS. BASED ON THEIR
INTERESTS. AND WHILE IT WOULD
BE RECOMMENDED THAT THE
STUDENTS TAKE THE COURTS IN
THEIR SENIOR YEAR IT WOULD NOT
BE REQUIRED PROVIDING
FLEXIBILITY TO STUDENTS AND
SCHOOLS. I WOULD ALSO LIKE TO
EMPHASIZE TO IMPORTANT OTHER
POINTS ABOUT THE PROPOSAL.
FIRST THE REQUIREMENT WOULD
TAKE EFFECT AND SEVEN YEARS FOR
ENTERING NEW FIRST YEAR COLLEGE
STUDENTS AND FALL TWENTY TWENTY
SIX. THOSE STUDENTS ARE IN SIX
GRADE TODAY. ADDITIONALLY BASED
ON THE CONSULTATION WITH
STAKEHOLDERS OVER THE PAST YEAR
AND A HALF AND CONSISTENT WITH
CAST CHANGES IN ADMISSIONS
REQUIREMENTS. THE CSU WILL
PROVIDE AN EXEMPTION FOR ANY
STUDENT WHO IS OTHERWISE
ELIGIBLE FOR ADMISSION WHO
COULD NOT FILL THIS NEW
REQUIREMENT DUE TO LACK OF
RESOURCES AND COURSE
AVAILABILITY AT THEIR HIGH
SCHOOL. IN PARTNERSHIP WITH THE
UC AND THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT EDUCATION SCHOOLS
WITH LIMITED QUALIFYING COURSE
OFFERINGS IN TWENTY TWENTY SIX
WOULD BE PRE IDENTIFIED. AND
STUDENTS ATTENDING THESE
SCHOOLS WILL BE AUTOMATICALLY
WAIVE THE REQUIREMENT IF IT IS
NEEDED. THIS WILL AUTOMATE THE
EXEMPTION FOR STUDENTS APPLYING
FROM THE SCHOOLS ELIMINATING
THE NEED FOR INDIVIDUAL
STUDENTS TO SEEK OUT SUCH A
WAIVER. IT'S IMPORTANT TO
RECOGNIZE HOWEVER THAT AS WITH
THE INITIAL IMPLEMENTATION OF A
TO G. REQUIREMENTS WAIVERS
WOULD BE PHASED OUT OVER TIME.
IT'S ALSO IMPORTANT TO NOTE
THAT HAPPENED CSU GRADUATES
ARRIVE AS TRANSFER STUDENTS AND%
THUS THE PROPOSAL WOULD NOT
HAVE ANY IMPACT ON TRANSFERRED
MISSION OR FOR TRANSFER
STUDENTS THEMSELVES. WITH THIS
WITH THE CONTEXT THE PROPOSAL
ITSELF I'LL NOW TURN TO DR
MARKET AGREE NO SHIRE. TO
ADDRESS THE ORIGINS AND INTENT
OF THE PROPOSAL GET A. THANK
YOU NATHAN AGAIN MY NAME IS
MARK HIT A CAR NO SHIRE AYE
SERVICES SYSTEM VICE CHANCELLOR
FOR EDUCATOR PREPARATION OF
PUBLIC SCHOOL PROGRAMS IN THE
CSU. IN REALITY THE DISCUSSION
REGARDING PRE COLLEGE ACADEMIC
PREPARATION NECESSARY FOR
ACADEMIC AND STUDENT SUCCESS IN
THE CSU HAS BEEN AN ONGOING
CONVERSATION FOR DECADES AS YOU
HEARD EARLIER THE CURRENT A
THROUGH G. REQUIREMENTS FOR CSU
ADMISSION. HAVE REMAIN
UNCHANGED FROM MORE THAN TWENTY
YEARS YET THE PREPARATION
NEEDED TO BE SUCCESSFUL IN A
RANGE OF DEGREE PROGRAMS THE
WORK FORCE AND VIRTUALLY EVERY
ASPECT OF LIFE HAS CHANGED FOR
THIS GENERATION OF STUDENTS.
EVEN AFTER THE ADOPTION OF THE
MINIMUM A THREE G. HIGH SCHOOL
COURSE REQUIREMENTS MORE THAN
TWENTY YEARS AGO BOTH THE C.
AND C. ISSUE AND YOU SEE HAVE
RECOMMENDED THAT STUDENTS
EXCEED THOSE MINIMUMS. TO BE
BEST PREPARED FOR DIRECT DEGREE
COMPLETION AND ACCESS TO THE
BROADEST RANGE OF MAJORS
SPECIFICALLY BOTH SEGMENTS HAVE
RECOMMENDED THAT STUDENTS
COMPLETE FOUR YEARS OF
MATHEMATICS SINCE THE EARLY TWO
THOUSANDS. IN ADDITION IN THE
EARLY TWO THOUSANDS THE CSU IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION ONCE
THE EARLY ASSESSMENT PROGRAM
WHICH USE THE STATE SUMMIT OF
HIGH SCHOOL ASSESSMENT. THEN
THE STAR EXAM AND NOW THE
SMARTER BALANCED ASSESSMENT TO
PROVIDE AN ADDITIONAL SIGNAL OF
COLLEGE READINESS IN ENGLISH
AND MATHEMATICS DURING THE
JUNIOR YEAR OFHIGH SCHOOL. AS
PART OF THAT PROGRAM THE
MAJORITY OF STUDENTS WHO TOOK
THAT ASSESSMENT WERE ENCOURAGED
AND INCENTIVIZED TO TAKE A
SENIOR YEAR MATHEMATICS COURSE.
RECOGNIZING THE INCONGRUENCE
ADMISSION CRITERIA AND COLLEGE
READY YES THE STATE WIDE
ACADEMIC SENATE AT THE CSU OR
OFFICIAL FACULTY GOVERNANCE
BODY. CREATED A TASK FORCE IN
TWENTY FOURTEEN TO EXAMINE
ACADEMIC PREPARATION AND
QUANTITATIVE REASONING. THE
TASK FORCE INCLUDED AMONG
OTHERS THEN LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR
GAVIN NEWSOM AND FORMER
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION DEPUTY SUPERINTENDENT
KERIK ASHLEY. AFTER TWO YEARS
OF EXTENSIVE CONSULTATION AN
INVESTIGATION ONE OF THE FOUR
RECOMMENDATIONS OF THE TASK
FORCE WAS TO REVISE
QUANTITATIVE REASONING
REQUIREMENTS FOR CSU ADMISSION.
THE RECOMMENDATION CALLED FOR
REVISED POLICY THAT EVALUATES
THE GENERAL QUANTITATIVE
REASONING ABILITY OF STUDENTS
AND TRAIN AND GRADUATING FROM
THE CSU. THE CSU SYSTEM HAS
ALREADY ADVANCE OTHER
RECOMMENDATIONS FOR THEIR
REPORT FOR EXAMPLE AT THE TIME
OF THE REPORT NEARLY ONE THIRD
OF REGULAR ADMITTED CSU
STUDENTS WERE ARRIVING UNDER
PREPARED FOR COLLEGE LEVEL
MATHEMATICS AND QUANTITATIVE
REASONING COURSES. THE STUDENTS
WERE RELEGATED TO NON CREDIT
DEVELOPMENTAL AGES EDUCATION
COURSES OTHERWISE KNOWN AS
REMEDIAL COURSES COSTING THEM
ADDITIONAL MONEY LENGTHENING
THE TIME TURNER DEGREE AND
ESSENTIALLY EXCLUDING THEM FROM
ANY SCIENCE TECHNOLOGY
ENGINEERING AND MATHEMATICS OR
STEM DEGREE PROGRAMS. THE
STUDENTS WERE
DISPROPORTIONATELY AFRICAN
AMERICAN AND LATIN X. IN
RESPONSE THE CSU OFFICE OF THE
CHANCELLOR ISSUED EXECUTIVE
ORDER ELEVEN TEN IN AUGUST
TWENTY SEVENTEEN. IT ADDRESS
THREE MAIN ISSUES FIRST IT
CHANGE THE WAY THIS IS TO
ASSESS STUDENTS AT ENTRY AND
PLACE THEM IN FIRST YEAR
COURSES SECOND IT STRENGTHENED
THE EARLY START PROGRAM TO
ALLOW STUDENTS. WHO NEED
ADDITIONAL SUPPORT TO EARN
CREDIT IN THE SUMMER BEFORE
THEIR FIRST TERM AND THIRD IT
ELIMINATED STANDALONE
DEVELOPMENTAL EDUCATION COURSES
ALSO KNOWN AS REMEDIATION. WELL
THE FIRST YEAR OF EXECUTIVE
ORDER ELEVEN TEN IMPLEMENTATION
HAS SHOWN POSITIVE OUTCOMES FOR
STUDENTS THE POLICY WAS NEVER
INTENDED TO BE THE SOLE
COUNTERBALANCE FOR STUDENTS
ARRIVING. UNDERPREPARED FOR
VARIOUS COLLEGE LEVEL
QUANTITATIVE REASONING COURSES
THE C. ISSUES COMMITMENT IS TO
MEET STUDENTS WHERE THEY ARE
AND TO WORK SYSTEMATICALLY TO
INCREASE THE LEVEL OF ACADEMIC
PREPARATION AND COLLEGE
READINESS FOR ALL INCOME IN
STUDENTS. THE PROPOSED
QUANTITATIVE REASONING A MISH
REQUIREMENT AS A PROGRESSIVE
STEP IN ENSURING EQUITY AN
AUTHENTIC ACCESS FOR ALL CSU
STUDENTS. THE PROPOSAL IS NOT
INTENDED TO CURTAIL ACCESS OR
CHANGE THE COMPOSITION OF THE
CSU STUDENT POPULATION INSTEAD
IS IT IT IS INTENDED TO ENSURE.
THAT ALL STUDENTS WHO ENTER THE
CSU OR THE MOST PREPARED TO BE
SUCCESSFUL IN THEIR COURSE WORK
SO THAT THEY MAY PARTICIPATE IN
A RANGE OF MAJORS AND CAREER
FIELDS. AT THE CSU THE DATA ARE
CLEAR THAT ADDITIONAL
QUANTITATIVE REASONING
PREPARATION IN HIGH SCHOOL
LEADS TO GREATER SUCCESS IN
COLLEGE THIS IS TRUE WHETHER
STUDENT MAJORS IN ART
ENGINEERING COMMUNICATIONS
BIOLOGY OR DESIGN. IF WE
APPLIED THE PROPOSED
REQUIREMENT TO THE ENTRANT
CLASS A NEW FIRST YEAR STUDENTS
AND FALL TWENTY EIGHTEEN ONE
YEAR AGO. 91% OF THE MORE THAN
SIXTY THREE THOUSAND HAD
FULFILLED THE REQUIREMENTS. 91%
WITH THE VAST MAJORITY FOR
FILLING THAT REQUIREMENT TO THE
COMPLETION OF A FOURTH YEAR
MATH FOR THOSE WHO DID NOT THE
IMPACT IS EVIDENT YOU CAN FIND
A SUMMARY OF THAT IN OF THIS
INFORMATION ON THE HANDOUT THAT
WAS DISTRIBUTED. THIS IMPACT IS
SHOWN IN FIRST YEAR TO SECOND
YEAR RETENTION RATES AND FOR
YOUR GRADUATION RATES AND IT'S
SIX YEAR GRADUATION RATES.
STUDENTS WHO COMPLETE AN
ADDITIONAL YEAR QUANTITATIVE
REASONING BIT SCIENCE OR
MATHEMATICS ARE RETAINED AND
GRADUATED GREATER RATES IN
THOSE STUDENTS WHO ONLY
COMPLETE THE MINIMUM NUMBER OF
A THROUGH G. COURSES. THIS IS
TRUE FOR LAD NEXT STUDENTS FOR
AFRICAN AMERICAN STUDENTS
INDEED FOR ALL STUDENTS THANK
YOU. LOOKING AT FIRST YEAR
RETENTION STUDENTS WHO
COMPLETED AN ADDITIONAL YEAR IN
QUANTITATIVE REASONING HIGH
SCHOOL WERE RETAINED IN THEIR
SECOND YEAR AT A RATE AT A RATE
ELEVEN PERCENTAGE POINTS HIGHER
THAN THOSE WHO ONLY COMPLETED.
THE MINIMUM A THREE G. COURSES.
85% VERSUS 744% FOR AFRICAN
AMERICANS. EIGHTY FIVE VERSES
74% FOR AFRICAN AMERICAN
STUDENTS THE IMPROVEMENT WAS
80% VERSUS 73% AB FOR LATIN
NEXT STUDENTS EIGHTY THREE
VERSUS 71% WE ALSO SEE THE
IMPACT ON GRADUATION RATES BOTH
FOUR YEAR AND SIX YEAR FOR SIX
YOUR RATES THE ONES ON WHICH
EQUITY GAPS ARE MEASURED WE SEE
GRADUATION RATES TWELVE POINTS
HIGHER FOR STUDENTS WHO
COMPLETED AN ADDITIONAL
QUANTITATIVE REASONING COURSE
WAS SIMILAR GAINS FOR AFRICAN
AMERICAN ELEVEN POINTS. AND
LATIN NEXT STUDENTS TEN POINTS.
LET ME PAUSE HERE TO ADDRESS A
CONCERN THAT HAS BEEN RAISED
REGARDING THE POTENTIAL
DISPARATE IMPACT OF THIS POLICY
ON BLACK AND BROWN STUDENTS.
THE CSU HAS LONG MONITOR THE
ETHNIC AND RACIAL COMPOSITION
OF OUR STUDENTS AND CHANGES
WINCH WHICH IMPACT THIS.
INCLUDING CHANGES TO FEDERAL
REPORTING REQUIREMENTS
REGARDING HOW STUDENT RACE AND
ETHNICITY INFORMATION IS
REPORTED PUBLICLY. IN TWO
THOUSAND NINE THE FEDERAL
REPORTING REQUIREMENTS FOR
SUSAN ETHNICITY AND RACE
CHANGED WHEN WE EXAMINE THE
ETHNICITY OF STUDENTS IN TWO
THOUSAND SIX PRIOR TO THE
CHANGE AND COMPARATIVE TO
TWENTY NINETEEN. THE FEDERALLY
REPORTED PERCENTAGE OF AFRICAN
AMERICAN STUDENTS IN THE CSU
WOULD APPEAR TO DECLINE FROM 6%
TO FOUR PERCENT. HOWEVER IF WE
TAKE A DEEPER LOOK INSIDE THESE
NUMBERS WE SEE THAT THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT COLLECTS DATA FOR
BOTH BLACK HISPANIC AND BLACK
MULTIRACIAL STUDENTS CATEGORY
COMBINATIONS THAT DID NOT EXIST
PRIOR TO TWO THOUSAND NINE.
CHANGE IN THOSE STUDENTS NO
LONGER WOULD WE- BE REPORTED
UNDER BLACK OR AFRICAN AMERICAN
CATEGORY. IF WE CONSIDER THIS
CONTEXT THE TRUE SHARE OR
PERCENTAGE OF BLACK STUDENTS IN
THE C. ISSUES UNDERGRADUATE
DEGREES SPEAKING STUDENT
POPULATION STANDS AND 6% AT
STANDS AT 6% AND HAS NOT
CHANGED SINCE TWO THOUSAND SIX.
IN REALITY TWENTY SEVEN
THOUSAND AFRICAN AMERICAN
UNDERGRADUATE STUDENTS FROM
ROLL THIS FALL TWENTY NINETEEN.
COMPARED TO TWENTY ONE THOUSAND
AND TWO THOUSAND AND SIX.
WITHOUT EXCEPTION CSU STUDENT
OUTCOMES DATA SHOW THAT
ADDITIONAL QUANTITATIVE
REASONING PREPARATION IN HIGH
SCHOOL IS LINKED TO SUCCESS IN
COLLEGE NO MATTER STUDENTS FEEL
THE STUDY NO MATTER THEIR
CAREER CHOICE ADDITIONAL
QUANTITATIVE REASONING
PREPARATION IS CRITICAL. THIS
IS A PARTICULARLY TRUE FOR HIGH
DEMAND SCIENCE TECHNOLOGY
ENGINEERING AND MATHEMATICS
COLLECTIVELY KNOWN AS STEM
CAREERS. THESE ARE HIGH PAIN IN
DEMAND JOBS BETWEEN TWENTY
FOURTEEN AND TWENTY TWENTY
FOUR. STEM OCCUPATIONS IN THE
UNITED STATES ARE EXPECTED TO
GROW BY NEARLY NINE PERCENT.
THESE ARE CAREERS THAT
CALIFORNIA'S STUDENTS WANT TO
PURSUE. ACCORDING TO A TWENTY
SEVENTEEN A C. T. REPORT 52% OF
ALL A. C. TESTED STUDENTS IN
CALIFORNIA. INDICATED AN
INTEREST IN PURSUING A CAREER
AND STEM HOWEVER ONLY 31% MET
MET THE ACT BENCHMARK FOR
COLLEGE READINESS AND STEM. AND
WHEN EXAMINED BY ETHNICITY TO
PROTECT THE PICTURE IS WORSE
ONLY 11% OF BLACK NECKS AND 10%
OF AFRICAN AMERICAN HIGH SCHOOL
GRADUATES IN CALIFORNIA WE'RE
PREPARED TO PURSUE STEM MAJORS
IN COLLEGE WHAT THIS TELLS US
IS THAT THE DOORS TO STEM
CAREERS ARE ESSENTIALLY CLOSE
TO STUDENTS. AND PRIMARILY
STUDENTS OF COLOR BEGINNING IN
MIDDLE AND HIGH SCHOOL. THIS
TREND CONTINUES THROUGH COLLEGE
AT THE CSU DISPARITIES IN STEM
GRADUATES EXISTS DESPITE
PROGRESS IN CLOSING EQUITY
GAPS. CONSIDER THE PERCENT OF
STUDENTS EARNED A BACHELOR'S
DEGREE IN A STEM FIELD WITHIN
EACH ETHNIC GROUP IN 20171824%
OF ASIAN STUDENTS. AND 23% OF
WHITE STUDENTS EARNED A
BACHELOR'S DEGREE IN A STEM
FIELD. HOWEVER ONLY 14% OF
LATIN NECKS AND 10% OF AFRICAN
AMERICAN STUDENTS EARNED A
SIMILAR DEGREE. QUANTITATIVE
REASONING PREPARATION IN HIGH
SCHOOL IS AN IMPORTANT STEP IN
A LIMITED ELIMINATING THIS
DISPARITIES. SUPPORTING
AUTHENTIC ACCESS TO STEM MAJORS
IN CAREERS BY ENSURING STUDENTS
ARRIVE AT COLLEGE BETTER
PREPARED ACADEMICALLY TO PURSUE
THESE FIELDS. WITH THIS CONTEXT
IN MIND HOW DO WE ENSURE THAT
SUCH A CHANGE REQUIREMENTS DOES
NOT IMPACT THE STUDENT'S IS
MOST INTENDED TO SUPPORT.
THROUGH CONSULTATION
PARTNERSHIPS OF KICK P. K.
TWELVE SCHOOL DISTRICTS AND
CAREFUL CONSIDERATION WE HAVE
DEVELOPED THE PROPOSAL TO
ENSURE IT DOES NO HARM TO
STUDENTS FROM A HISTORICALLY
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES. FIRST
MANY CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
DISTRICTS HAVE GRADUATION
REQUIREMENTS TODAY THAT ALIGN
WITH THE CSU PROPOSAL IF WE
LOOK AT THE TWENTY LARGEST
SCHOOL DISTRICTS IN CALIFORNIA.
MORE THAN ONE THIRD TODAY HAVE
HIGH SCHOOL GRADUATION
REQUIREMENTS AT A LINE WITH THE
CSU QUANTITATIVE REASONING
PROPOSAL THIS INCLUDES FOUR OF
THE FIVE LARGEST DISTRICTS IN
THE STATE INCLUDING SAN DIEGO
LONG BEACH OAK GROVE AND FRESNO
UNIFIED AS WELL SAM OR DID YOU
KNOW OAKLAND AND STOCKTON. AT
THE OTHER END OF THE SPECTRUM
SEVERAL THE STATE'S SMALLEST
SCHOOL DISTRICT ALSO CURRENTLY
HAVE GRADUATION REQUIREMENTS
THAT ALIGN WITH THE CSU
QUANTITATIVE REASONING PROPOSAL
AS WELL. THE STUDENTS IN THESE
DISTRICTS INCLUDED BAKER
VALLEY. TOOL LAKE IN FERNDALE
WITH GRADUATING CLASSES SMALLER
THAN FIFTY STUDENTS GRADUATE
HAVING ALREADY FOR FILLED THE
PROPOSAL REQUIREMENTS. EVERY
STUDENT GRADUATING FROM THOSE
DISTRICTS HAS ALREADY FOR FILL
THE QUANTITATIVE REASONING
REQUIREMENTS. SECOND EVERY
COMPREHENSIVE CALIFORNIA HIGH
SCHOOL TODAY OFFERS AT LEAST
ONE QUALIFYING COURSE AND ALL
BUT SIX SIXTEEN SCHOOLS OFFER
AT LEAST THREE COURSES WITH
MOST OF THOSE SIXTEEN BEING
SMALL CHARTER SCHOOLS. WE HAVE
ALSO IDENTIFIED TWENTY ONE
DISTRICTS IN THE STATE IN WHICH
SUFFICIENT CLASSES AND COURSE
SECTIONS EXISTS BUT THE COURSE
TAKING PAT. THE COURSE TAKING
BEHAVIOR STUDENTS IN THESE JUST
WOULD NEED TO CHANGE OVER THE
INTERVENING SEVEN YEARS. AND
FINALLY AS PREVIOUSLY MENTIONED
IN TWENTY TWENTY SIX SHOULD
STUDENT NOT HAVE ACCESS TO A
COURSE TO THE RESOURCES OF
THEIR HIGH SCHOOL. THEY WILL
RECEIVE AN EXEMPTION LET ME BE
COMPLETELY CLEAR UNDER THIS
PROPOSAL NO STUDENT WOULD BE
DENIED ACCESS TO THE CSU
BECAUSE THEY COULD NOT TAKE A
QUANTITATIVE REASONING COURSE
THROUGH NO FAULT OF THEIR OWN.
DURING BOARD OF TRUSTEES
MEETINGS OVER THE PAST EIGHT
MONTHS WE'VE DISCUSSED WHAT
THIS PRACTICALLY WOULD MEAN
TODAY AT A VARIETY OF TYPES OF
CALIFORNIA HIGH SCHOOLS. WE
EXAMINE COURSE CATALOGS AND A
THROUGH G. LISTS FOR SCHOOLS
RURAL SUBURBAN AND URBAN
SPENDING THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND HERE'S WHAT WE
FOUND. AT FORTUNA HIGH SCHOOL A
SMALL RURAL SCHOOL IN HUMBLE
COUNTY THAN A ROLLS FEWER THAN
A THOUSAND STUDENTS. AND WE'RE
MORE THAN HALF OF THE STUDENTS
QUALIFY FOR FREE AND REDUCED
PRICE MEALS. A REVIEW FOUND
THAT A STUDENT IN ROLE TODAY
WOULD HAVE FIFTEEN COURSES
AVAILABLE TO FILL THE
QUANTITATIVE REASONING
REQUIREMENTS. THIS INCLUDE
COURSES SUCH AS GREEN
TECHNOLOGIES STATISTICS AND
ANATOMY AND TWO COURSES OFFERED
THROUGH DOING MOMENT WITH THE
CALLER REDLANDS. PROGRAMMING
FUNDAMENTALS AN INTRO TO GAME
DEVELOPMENT. NEXT AT RIVER CITY
HIGH SCHOOL JUST A FEW MILES
FROM HERE IN WEST SACRAMENTO
APPROXIMATELY 644% OF THE
SCHOOLS TWO THOUSAND THREE
HUNDRED STUDENTS. ARE ELIGIBLE
FOR FREE AND REDUCED PRICE
LUNCH MEALS. AT RIVER CITY
STUDENTS TO ROLL TODAY HAVE
TWENTY NINE COURSE OPTIONS TO
FILL THE QUANTITATIVE REASONING
REQUIREMENTS. THIS INCLUDE
COURSES SUCH AS HUMAN BODY
SYSTEMS DIGITAL ELECTRONICS AND
COURSE ENTITLED FARM TO FORK.
TURNING OUT OF THE CENTRAL
VALLEY WE DID A SIMILAR REVIEW
OF COURSE OFFERINGS AT FRESNO
HIGH SCHOOL IN FRESNO COUNTY.
WERE APPROXIMATELY TWO THOUSAND
TWO HUNDRED STUDENTS ARE
ENROLLED AND ABOUT 85% ARE
LATIN NECKS AFRICAN AMERICAN OR
NATIVE AMERICAN STUDENTS AND
87% OF THE STUDENTS QUALIFY FOR
FREE AND REDUCED PRICE MEALS. A
STUDENT ATTENDING HIGH SCHOOL
HERE TODAY WOULD HAVE THIRTY
SEVEN CLASSES THAT COULD FILL
THE PROPOSED REQUIREMENTS. THIS
INCLUDES GENERAL COLLEGE
PREPARATORY CLASSES HONORS
CLASSES INTERNATIONAL
BACCALAUREATE COURSES AP
CLASSES REGIONAL OCCUPATIONAL
PROGRAM COURSES AND A WORK
BASED LEARNING COURSE. IN THE
HEART OF LOS ANGELES UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT AT SOUTH KATE
SENIOR HIGH NEARLY THREE
THOUSAND STUDENTS ARE ENROLLED.
86% OF WHO ARE ELIGIBLE FOR YOU
FOR FREE AND REDUCED PRICE
MEALS A STUDENT TAKING COURSES
AT SENIOR SOUTH GATE SENIOR
HIGH TODAY WOULD HAVE AT LEAST
SEVENTEEN DIFFERENT COURSES
THAT THEY COULD. TAKE TO FILL
THE QUANTITATIVE REASONING
REQUIREMENTS. THIS INCLUDE
COURSES RANGING FROM EXPLORING
COMPUTER SCIENCE TO BIOLOGY
LIVING EARTH TO TRANSITION TO
COLLEGE MATH AND STATISTICS. A
TRANSITIONAL MATH SCORES THAT
WAS DEVELOPED IN CONJUNCTION
WITH C. H. CSU NORTHRIDGE. AND
FINALLY IN THE INLAND EMPIRE.
WE REVIEW COURSE OFFERINGS OF
MARTIN LUTHER KING HIGH SCHOOL
IN RIVERSIDE COUNTY WHERE MORE
THAN THREE THOUSAND ONE HUNDRED
STUDENTS ARE ENROLLED IN ABOUT
HALF OR LESS NEXT STUDENTS. A
STUDENT ATTENDING HIGH SCHOOL
HERE WOULD HAVE TWENTY NINE
DIFFERENT CLASSES THAT COULD
FILL THE PROPOSED REQUIREMENT.
THIS INCLUDES CLASSES LIKE GAME
DESIGN SPORTS MEDICINE IN
MARINE BIOLOGY. THE INFORMATION
I HAVE SHARED THIS FAR
REFERENCES TODAY'S ENVIRONMENT
THE DATA DEMONSTRATING THE
IMPACT OF QUANTITATIVE
REASONING FOR TODAY'S STUDENTS
AND THE ACCESS ALREADY
AVAILABLE AND HIGH SCHOOLS
ACROSS THE STATE. YET THE
PROPOSED CHANGE REQUIREMENTS
WOULD TAKE EFFECT IN SEVEN
YEARS FOR THE GRADUATING HIGH
SCHOOL CLASS OF TWENTY TWENTY
SIX. THIS TIME WINE WAS
SELECTED FOR SEVERAL REASONS
FIRST IT ENSURES THAT ANY
STUDENT ALREADY IN HIGH SCHOOL
AT THE POINT OF ADOPTION WOULD
SEE NO CHANGE IN EXPECTED
REQUIREMENTS. SECOND GIVING
THIS GIVES STUDENTS GIVEN THAT
STUDENTS ARE OFTEN BEGINNING
BOTH TRADITIONAL INTEGRATED
MATH CURRICULUM MORE FREQUENTLY
IN MIDDLE SCHOOL. IT ALLOWS
STUDENTS FAMILIES AND SCHOOLS
TO CONSIDER MULTI YEAR PLANNING
FOR SUCH A REQUIREMENT. AND
FINALLY IT PROVIDES SUFFICIENT
TIME TO FURTHER INVEST
RESOURCES AN OUT REACH TO BUILD
ADDITIONAL CAPACITY IN SCHOOLS
AND COMMUNITIES. IN WHICH IT
MAY MOST BE NEEDED. DURING THE
PAST TWO YEARS OF CONSULTATION
WE RECEIVE FEEDBACK THE P. K.
TWELVE SCHOOL DISTRICTS MIGHT
NOT BE ABLE TO DEVELOP THE
COURTS CAPACITY IN HIGH SCHOOLS
TO MEET THE SUBMISSION
REQUIREMENTS. WE HAVE LISTENED
TO THIS FEEDBACK AND KNOWLEDGE
THE IMPLEMENTING THIS
REQUIREMENT WILL BE A
COLLECTIVE EFFORT. AS WAS THE
CASE WITH THE A THREE G.
REQUIREMENTS THIRTY YEARS AGO
THIS PROPOSAL WOULD REQUIRE P.
KILLED P. K. TWELVE SCHOOLS TO
MAKE CHANGES TO THEIR COURSE
OFFERINGS. BUT CSU FACULTY AND
STAFF WILL CONTINUE OUR WORK
WITH THESE DISTRICTS AS
PARTNERS OVER THE NEXT SEVEN
YEARS TO ENSURE THEY ARE READY
FOR THE TWENTY TWENTY SIX
IMPLEMENTATION YEAR. WE WILL
USE THE SUCCESSFUL EXPOSITORY
READING AND WRITING CURRICULUM
OR E. OR W. C. AS A MODEL TO
EXPAND COURSE AVAILABLE
AVAILABILITY IN CALIFORNIA HIGH
SCHOOLS. THE E. R. W. C. NOW
OFFERED IN MORE THAN A THOUSAND
HIGH SCHOOLS PROVIDE SENIORS
THE OPPORTUNITY TO COMPLETE A
FOURTH YOUR COURTS IN ENGLISH
LANGUAGE ARTS. THE COURSES WERE
CO DEVELOPED BY CSU IN HIGH
SCHOOL FACULTY AND CAPACITY WAS
EXPANDED BY COLLABORATIVE WE
WORKING WITH COUNTY OFFICES OF
EDUCATION A PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT AND CURRICULAR
INTEGRATION. WE WILL FOLLOW THE
SAME MODEL AND BUILDING MORE
TEACHING CAPACITY WHERE IT IS
MOST NEEDED INDEED THIS WORK
FOR QUANTITATIVE REASONING HAS
ALREADY BEGUN. SINCE TWENTY
SIXTEEN CSU FACULTY AND STAFF
HAVE BEEN WORKING WITH THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION. AND PK TWELVE A
COMMUNITY COLLEGE PARTNERS TO
DEVELOP A BRIDGE OR
TRANSITIONAL COURSE FROM HIGH
SCHOOL TO HIGHER EDUCATION.
THROUGH THE CALIFORNIA
MATHEMATICS READ READING THIS
CHALLENGES WHICH INITIATIVE OR
CMR CI. THESE COURSES PROVIDE
AN ADDITIONAL WAY FOR STUDENTS
TO MEET THE PROPOSED
QUANTITATIVE REASONING
PARLIAMENT. AND THESE COURSES
CAN BE FOUND ACROSS THE STATE
FROM NEVADA COUNTY IN THE NORTH
TO SAN DIEGO COUNTY IN THE
SOUTH. THESE PARTNERSHIPS WERE
A DIRECT RESULT OF A TEN
MILLION DOLLAR LEGISLATIVE
INVESTMENT IN IMPROVING THE
TRANSITION BETWEEN HIGH SCHOOL
AND COLLEGE IN TWENTY
SEVENTEEN. IT IS THIS EXACT
TYPE OF SUPPORT FROM THE
LEGISLATURE AN ADMINISTRATION
THAT WOULD SUPPORT THE
CONTINUATION AND THE SCALING.
OF THIS IMPORTANT WORK IN THE
FUTURE. CURRENTLY THROUGH
PARTNERSHIP AMONG CSU CAMPUSES
AT MONTEREY BAY NORTHRIDGE
SACRAMENTO SAN BERNARDINO
POMONA LONG BEACH SAN JOSE AND
SAN DIEGO NEW PILOT
TRANSITIONAL COURSES EXIST IN
MORE THAN A HUNDRED AND SIXTY
CALIFORNIA HIGH SCHOOLS WITH
MORE THAN TEN THOUSAND STUDENTS
PARTICIPATING IN THESE COURSES
ANNUALLY. WE WILL CONTINUE
CONTINUE TO SUPPORT THESE
COURSES AND WORK WITH DISTRICTS
AND COUNTY OFFICES OF EDUCATION
TO EXPAND THIS COURSE
OFFERINGS. BEGINNING WITH THE
DISTRICTS WE HAVE IDENTIFIED AS
MOST IN NEED OF ADDITIONAL
CAPACITY. EARLIER THIS YEAR THE
CSU AND THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION
EXECUTED A NEW DATA SHARING
AGREEMENT TO SUPPORT OUR WORK
AROUND QUANTITATIVE REASONING.
THIS AGREEMENT IS HELP US
REFINE THE PROPOSAL AND WILL
DIRECTLY SUPPORT OUR CSU CAMPUS
AND SYSTEM PARTNERSHIPS WITH
LOCAL SCHOOL DISTRICTS DURING
IMPLEMENTATION. IN ADDITION A
CREW IN ADDITION TO CURRICULAR
SUPPORT THE CSU IN THE STATE
CAN CONTINUE TO INVEST IN
GROWING THE NUMBER OF NEW
PROTECTORS PRODUCED BY THE
STATE PARTICULAR IN MATHEMATICS
SCIENCE AND OTHER HIGH NEED
AREAS. CSU CHANCELLOR TIM WHITE
HAS COMMITTED AN ADDITIONAL TEN
MILLION ADDITIONAL INVESTMENT
OVER THE NEXT FOUR YEARS. TO
PREPARE MORE TEACHERS IN STEM
FIELDS THIS INVESTMENT IS ON
TOP OF THE TWO POINT SEVEN
MILLION CURRENTLY INVESTED EACH
YEAR BY THE CSU. ON AVERAGE THE
CSU CURRENTLY PREPARES ABOUT A
THOUSAND NEW MATHEMATICS
MATHEMATICS AND SCIENCE
TEACHERS EVERY YEAR. MANY OF
THESE TEACHERS GO ON TO TEACH
IN THE STATE'S HIGH NEED
SCHOOLS WERE 25% OR MORE. OF
THESE STUDENTS COME FROM
FAMILIES BELOW THE POVERTY LINE
AND MATHEMATICAL ACHIEVEMENTS
RATES ARE SIGNIFICANTLY BELOW
THE STATEWIDE AVERAGE WE
ANTICIPATE THIS NUMBER WILL
INCREASE WITH INVESTMENT OF
ADDITIONAL FUNDS TO ENROLL MORE
TEACHER CANDIDATES. AND FINALLY
THE CSU WILL CONTINUE TO OFFER
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT AND IN
SERVICE OPPORTUNITIES TO HELP
CURRENT P. K. TWELVE TEACHERS
DEVELOP AND IMPLEMENT CURRICULA
FOR QUANTITATIVE REASONING
COURSES. MANY OF THESE
OPPORTUNITIES WILL BE CONDUCTED
BY THE CSU CENTER FOR THE
ADVANCEMENT OF INSTRUCTION AND
QUANTITATIVE REASONING. AT THIS
TIME NOW TURN TO MY COLLEAGUE
DR JAMES T. MINOR TO CONCLUDE
OUR PRESENTATION. THANK YOU
MARQUITA A GOOD AFTERNOON I
KNOW MY COLLEAGUES OF SHARED A
SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF
INFORMATION AND- DURING THAT
TIME AND I PROMISE YOU THAT MY
PORTION OF THE TESTIMONY IS
MUCH SHORTER. BUT I WANT TO
SUMMARIZE BRIEFLY JUST A FEW
KEY POINTS THAT I THINK ARE
IMPORTANT TAKEAWAYS FIRST. IS
THAT THE POWER THE PROPOSED
POLICY IS ANCHORED IN OUR
INSTITUTIONAL GOAL TO ELIMINATE
EQUITY GAPS. AND PROVIDE
AUTHENTIC ACCESS TO THE SEA
ISSUE TO ENSURE THAT EVERY
STUDENT ARRIVES WITH THE
ACADEMIC PREPARATION THAT BASS
POSITIONS THEM FOR SUCCESS. IT
IS GRADUATING WITH A HIGH
QUALITY DEGREE THAT TRANSFORMS
THE LIVES OF SEE ISSUE STUDENTS
NOT SIMPLY BE AND ADMIT IT. UNA
WHO ARRIVES UNDERPREPARED HAS
JUST ONE IN TEN CHANCE OF
GRADUATING IN FOUR YEARS. THE
PROPOSAL WAS NEVER CONCEIVED
ASSEMBLY MEMBER AS AN APPARATUS
FOR ADJUSTING A ROMAN. SECOND
THE PROPOSAL WAS GROUNDED IN A
RECOMMENDATION FROM AN
INCLUSIVE REPORT BY SEE ISSUE
STATEWIDE ACADEMIC SENATE
PUBLISHED IN TWO THOUSAND AND
SIXTEEN. OVER THE LAST. THREE
YEARS THE PROPOSAL HAS BEEN
SHAPED BY NATIONAL AND
INTERNETWORK FORMAL SEE ISSUE
BOARD OF TRUSTEE MEETINGS
INCLUDING A SPECIAL FOR OUR
HEARING. ARE ON THE TOPIC ON
AUGUST TWENTY NINTH WHICH
INCLUDED PANELS ARE
REPRESENTING VARYING VIEWPOINTS
MUCH LIKE TODAY'S HEARING.
THIRD THE POLICY HAS BEEN
ADAPTED TO PROVIDE STUDENTS
WITH FLEXIBILITY. STUDENTS WILL
BE ABLE TO TAKE THE
QUANTITATIVE REASONING COURSE
WHENEVER IT BEST FITS INTO
THEIR HIGH SCHOOL SCHEDULE
THERE ARE NUMEROUS TYPES OF
CLASSES THAT WILL FOR FEEL THIS
REQUIREMENT AND SCHOOLS ARE
ALREADY OFFERING A BROAD RANGE
OF THOSE COURSES. AND THIS
PROPOSAL ENSURES THAT NO
STUDENT IS DENIED ACCESS TO THE
SEA ISSUE BECAUSE THEIR HIGH
SCHOOL LACKS THE RESOURCES TO
OFFER QUALIFYING COURSES THE
PROPOSAL WILL NOT HARM STUDENTS
FROM HISTORICALLY UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES. LET ME JUST PAUSE
TO ADDRESS THE R. T. I. STUDY
THAT WAS FUNDED BY ADVOCACY
ORGANIZATIONS AND RESPONSE TO
THIS PROPOSAL. I TRULY BELIEVE
THAT THESE GROUPS SHARE ARE
INTERESTING COMMITMENT TO
EDUCATIONAL EQUITY ALTHOUGH WE
MAY NOT AGREE ON THE STEPS
NECESSARY TO ACHIEVE THIS. WE
LEARNED DURING THE
SUPERINTENDENT OF PUBLIC
INSTRUCTION IS HERE AND
QUANTITATIVE REASONING LAST
MONTH AT THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION
CONSIDERED R. T. EYES USE OF
THE STUDENT DATA FROM THE LAST
ELIGIBILITY STUDY TO BE A
BREACH OF CONTRACT WITH CD. AND
A BREACH OF STUDENT DATA. THAT
SAID THE RTI STEADY USED A VERY
LIMITED DEFINITION OF COURSES
WHICH WAS SATISFY SEE ISSUES
REQUIREMENTS ONLY ADVANCED MATH
CLASSES OR PHYSICAL SCIENCES.
PHYSICAL SCIENCE COURSES IN
CONTRAST WITH THE BROAD RANGE
FOR DEFINITION OF QUANTITATIVE
REASONING ADVANCED AND SEE
ISSUES PROPOSAL. AS A RESULT IT
IS NOT SURPRISING THAT ALL HIGH
SCHOOL GRADUATES IN TWENTY
FIFTEEN FOUR YEARS AGO WOULD
NOT OF SATISFIED A REQUIREMENT
THAT WOULD TAKE THAT WOULD TAKE
AFFECT SEVEN YEARS FROM NOW
WHEN ALL STUDENTS ARE TWENTY
NINE YEARS OLD. THE ISSUE DATED
DEMONSTRATE THAT TODAY 91% OF
NEW FIRST YEAR STUDENTS ALREADY
COMPLETE A QUANTITATIVE
REASONING REQUIREMENTS THEY'RE
ALREADY MEETING THE REQUIREMENT
AT LARGE MAJORITY OF STUDENTS.
IN THE INTERVENING YEARS TO SEE
ISSUE IS COMMITTED TO
PARTNERING WITH SCHOOL
DISTRICTS TO ADDRESSED
ADDITIONAL CAPACITY NEEDS.
ADDITIONALLY AS A FIRM BAR
CHANCELLOR STAFF WILL CONTINUE
TO MONITOR MONITORED DISTRICT
PREPARATION HIGH SCHOOL
GRADUATION OUTCOMES IN NEW
STUDENT TRANS. THE C. ISSUE IS
ALREADY EMBEDDED IN EXEMPTION
PROCESS AS PREVIOUSLY DESCRIBED
BY MARQUITA. AND THE CSU
TRUSTEES AND LEADERSHIP WERE
ALSO RETAIN DISCRETION TO
ADJUST THE IMPLEMENTATION DATE
IF NECESSARY AS WE APPROACH
TWENTY TWENTY SIX. FINALLY THE
PROPOSED POLICY AND
IMPLEMENTATION PLAN PROVIDES P.
K. THROUGH TWELVE DISTRICTS
SUPPORT FROM THE C. ISSUE AND
TIME TO PREPARE OVER THE NEXT
SEVEN YEARS. THIS PROPOSAL
ALIGNS WITH THE DIRECTION OF
EDUCATION IN CALIFORNIA FOR
EXAMPLE. SCHOOL DISTRICTS THAT
ARE A LINE IN THERE
REQUIREMENTS WITH CALIFORNIA
NEXT GENERATION SCIENCE
STANDARDS WILL THEREFORE. BE
ALIGNED WITH THE C. ISSUE
PROPOSAL. AND CALIFORNIA'S NEW
ACCOUNTABILITY AND CONTINUOUS
IMPROVEMENT SYSTEMS PROVIDE
INFORMATION ABOUT HOW LOCAL
EDUCATION AGENCIES AND SCHOOLS
ARE MEETING THE NEEDS OF
CALIFORNIA'S DIVERSE STUDENT
POPULATION BASED ON A CONCISE
SET OF MEASURES SIX OF WHICH
WOULD BE DIRECTLY SUPPORTED BY
THE ADOPTION OF A QUANTITATIVE
REASONING REQUIREMENTS. WITHOUT
QUESTION ADDITIONAL
QUANTITATIVE REASONING
PREPARATION A HIGH SCHOOL
INCREASES THE LIKELIHOOD THAT A
STUDENT WILL STAY IN ROLE TO.
BE SUCCESSFUL IN THEIR COLLEGE
LEVEL COURSES AND MOST
IMPORTANTLY GRADUATE IT
PREPARES THEM WITH THE SKILLS
THEY NEED TO BE COMPETITIVE AND
SUCCESSFUL IN THE CURRENT AND
FUTURE WORK FORCE NO MATTER
THEIR CAREER PATH AND NO MATTER
WHERE THEIR INTERESTS PASSIONS
AND LIFE EXPERIENCES TAKE THEM.
THE C. ISSUE WAS CONFIDENT THAT
THIS PROPOSAL IS IN THE BEST
INTERESTS OF STUDENTS IT IS
CONSISTENT WITH THE C. ISSUES
COMMITMENT TO AUTHENTIC ACCESS
OPPORTUNITY AND SOCIAL
MOBILITY. CHAIR MEDINA WE
APPRECIATE THE TIME THIS
AFTERNOON BUT YOU HAVE PROVIDED
TO US AND WE WILL WELCOME ANY
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
THANK YOU AND BEFORE WE BEGIN
SOME QUESTIONS FROM THE PANEL I
JUST WANT TO WELCOME ASSEMBLY
MEMBER JAMES RAMOS FROM SAMBAR
MEDINA THE MY IS JOINING. A
DISTRICT SO WELCOME THANK YOU
MISTER RAMOS. AND BEFORE I
BEGIN MY QUESTIONS I WANT TO
REITERATE SOMETHING AND THAT IS.
WE WERE OVER HERE TOGETHER
AWHILE BACK ETHNIC THE JOINT
COMMITTEE ON THE AUDIT WAS CSU
ON FINANCES. AND ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT CAME OUT OF THE
AUDIT WAS LACK OF TRANSPARENCY.
AS IT CAME TO THE BUDGET. AND
I'VE HEARD THAT YOU MENTION YOU
KNOW THE LONG TIME THAT THAT
CSU IS BENT AS SPENT ON THIS
ISSUE. BUT I WOULD REITERATE
AGAIN THAT IT WAS VERY MUCH
NEWS TO ME. AND A VERY
DISAPPOINTED THAT THERE WAS A
LACK OF COMMUNICATION TO THE
LEGISLATURE. AND THIS COMMITTEE
OF HIGHER EDUCATION AND I THINK
THAT'S ALSO REFLECTED FROM
OTHER SEGMENTS AS WELL. WITH
THAT HAVE A SERIES OF QUESTIONS
THAT I'D LIKE TO HAVE YOU
ANSWER FIRST QUESTION. WHAT IS
THE PROBLEM THAT THE PROPOSED
CHANGE IS TRYING TO ADDRESS.
SALT SO LET ME JUST BEGAN AND
I'LL INVITE MY COLLEAGUES THE
PROBLEM THAT THIS PROPOSAL ARE
SEEKS TO ADDRESS IS THE
INCONGRUENCE AS YOUR HER
MARQUITA MENTIONED BETWEEN WHAT
IS REQUIRED TO BE ADMITTED TO
THE C. ISSUE WHAT WE TODAY DEEM
COLLEGE READY. JUST A YEAR AGO
OR TWO YEARS AGO OF THE SIXTY
FIVE THOUSAND INCOMING SEE
ISSUE STUDENTS ABOUT TWENTY SIX
THOUSAND OF THEM ARRIVED UNDER
PREPARE FOR THEIR FIRST COLLEGE
LEVEL COURSE IN MATHEMATICS OR
QUANTITATIVE REASONING THAT IS
A PROBLEM IT DRAMATICALLY OUR-
INFLUENCES THEIR CHURCH
LIKELIHOOD. SO THE IDEA IS THAT
NOT ONLY DO WE REFORM
DEVELOPMENT OR REMEDIAL
EDUCATION ON OUR END TO TRY OUR
BEST TO MEET STUDENTS WHERE
THEY ARE THE PROPOSAL WAS ALSO
INTENDED TO IT INVITE STUDENTS
TO TAKE THE NEXT STEP UP TO
ENSURE THAT THEY'RE BETTER
PREPARE FOR COLLEGE. SUCCESS
UPON ARRIVAL. SEE IS YOU
EXECUTIVE ORDER. ELEVEN TEN
ELIMINATED MATH PLACEMENT TEST
AND TRADITIONAL REMEDIATION. IN
FAVOR PLACE IN ALL STUDENTS AND
COLLEGE LEVEL MATH. WHICH WORK
WITH SUPPORT AS NEEDED. GIVEN
THE POSITIVE RESULTS SO FAR
WHAT EVIDENCE IS THERE THAT AN
ADDITIONAL HIGH SCHOOL COURSE
WILL MAKE A DIFFERENCE. SOLD SO
LET ME JUST AGAIN OFFERIT WERE
VERY PROUD OF THE WORK THAT OUR
OUR FACULTY AND CAMPUS LEADERS
HAVE COMPLETED OVER THE LAST
TWO YEARS WITH EXECUTIVE ORDER
ELEVEN TEN. AND IT HAS MADE A
TREMENDOUS DIFFERENCE IN TERMS
OF HOW STUDENTS ARE PROGRESSING
TOWARD THEIR DEGREE. HOWEVER IT
WAS NEVER CONCEIVED TO BE A
LONG TERM COUNTER BALANCE FOR
THOUSANDS OF STUDENTS ARRIVE
INTO COLLEGE AND PREPARE. RIGHT
SOUL THE IDEA IS THAT. SO
THAT'S NUMBER ONE NUMBER TWO I
WOULD SAY EVEN WHEN YOU LOOK AT
STUDENTS WHO ARRIVE FULLY
PREPARED AND THOSE WHO ARE NOW
GOING TO CALL REQUISITE
COURSES. THERE ARE STILL PRETTY
SIGNIFICANT DIFFERENCES BETWEEN
THOSE STUDENTS THE IMPACTS ARE
NOT AS HARSH FOR STUDENTS WHO
ARRIVE UNDER PREPARED TODAY AS
THEY WERE JUST A YEAR AGO BUT
THERE ARE STILL DIFFERENCES
BETWEEN THOSE STUDENTS WE WITH
SOME OF US HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY
OF GOING TO COMMENCEMENT
CEREMONIES AND- AND WHEN YOU'RE
THERE AND THE SCIENCE. SCHOOL
OF SCIENCE AND ENGINEERING
STANDS UP. THERE PRETTY CLEAR
DESPAIR ISN'T AS OF WHO'S
GRADUATING WITH STEM DEGREES
AND THE IMPACT THAT THAT HAS ON
OUR OUR FUTURE WORK FORCE AND
THE SOCIAL AND ECONOMIC
MOBILITY OF MANY STUDENTS. SO
WE'RE VERY PROUD OF THAT BUT
BUT THAT'S ONLY ONE HALF OF THE
EQUATION THE SECOND HALF IS
THAT WE HAVE TO FIGURE OUT A
WAY TO ENCOURAGE AND TO INVITE
OUR STUDENTS TO BE BETTER
PREPARED UPON ARRIVAL. AND WHEN
YOU LOOK AT THE DATA THAT WE
HAVE PROVIDED FOR YOU STUDENTS
WHO ARRIVE WITH THREE YEARS OF
MATH OR QUANTITATIVE REASONING
COMPARE TO FOR IT'S PRETTY
CLEAR. NOT ONLY STE WHY
STUDENTS ASIAN STUDENTS AFRICAN
AMERICAN LATIN NEXT STUDENTS
ACROSS THE BOARD. THE LEVEL OF
PREPARATION MATTERS. IF NEARLY
EVERY STUDENT IS ALREADY MEDIAN
THE REQUIREMENT AS STATED IN
THE DOCUMENTS FOR C. ISSUES
AUGUST HEARING HOW WOULD THE
PROPOSED POLICY CHANGE AND
IMPROVE STUDENT SUCCESS. I
THINK FIRST AND FOREMOST WE
BELIEVE THAT EVERY STUDENT
MATTERS AND FOR THE REASONS YOU
JUST HEARD DR MINOR DESCRIBING
THE IMPACT NOT ON JUST ACADEMIC
PREPARATION WHAT HAPPENS IN THE
FIRST YEAR AND THE OUTCOMES OF
THOSE CHANGES THE FIRST YEAR
COURSES. BUT THOSE
OPPORTUNITIES TO STEM
DISCIPLINES TO BUSINESS THE
OTHER QUANTITATIVELY BASED
COURSES NURSING ARE OFTEN CUT
OFF BEFORE STUDENTS ARRIVE AND
SO AS I YOUR SHARE WE BELIEVE
THAT YES WALL WE'RE VERY PROUD
THAT 91% OF OUR STUDENTS. ARE
ACHIEVING THAT LEVEL THIS IS
INTENDED TO MAKE SYSTEMIC
CHANGE SO THAT ALL STUDENTS
HAVE THAT OPPORTUNITY IN CHOICE
OF MAJOR AND CHOICE TO PURSUE A
FIELD OF STUDY THAT BEST
POSITION THEM FOR THE FUTURE
AND WE BELIEVE THAT TO THE
POINT THAT JAMES MADE. ACADEMIC
PREPARATION MATTERS IN THIS
WOULD BE THE NEXT STEP IN
ADDRESSING. IF THE GOAL IS TO
INCREASE STEM OUTCOMES. WHY
DOES THE REQUIREMENT INCLUDE
NON STEM QUANTITATIVE REASONING
COURSES IS THERE CONCERN THAT
INCLUDING THESE COURSES COULD
ACTUALLY DECREASE THE
PROPORTION OF STUDENTS TAKING
I THINK THE SHORT ANSWER TO
THAT IS NOW I THINK ONE OF THE
REASONS YOU SEE THE INCLUSIVE
RANGE OF QUANTITATIVE REASONING
COURSES AS A DOES A COMEDY
STUDENTS WHO MAY NOT CHOOSE TO
PURSUE A STEM MAJOR BUT WAS
STILL BENEFIT FROM QUANTITATIVE
REASONING. PREPARATION AS I
MENTIONED JUST PREVIOUSLY THE
DIFFERENCES BETWEEN STUDENTS
WHO ARRIVE WITH THREE YEARS
COMPARED TO FOR ARE NOT ONLY
THE PRESENT ACROSS EVERY ETHNIC
GROUP OR ETHNICITY IT'S ALSO
PRESENT ACROSS EVERY MAJOR SO
EVEN WHEN YOU LOOK AT NON STEM
MAJORS AND YOU TAKE THOSE WHO
COME WITH THREE YEARS A
QUANTITATIVE PREPARATION.
COMPARED TO FOR THOSE WHO ARE
TAKEN FOUR YEARS PERFORM BETTER
WHEN THEY ARE IN COLLEGE SO WE
WANT TO ACCOMMODATE THE BROAD
RANGE OF STUDENTS WHO ARE GOING
TO ARRIVE TO THE C. ISSUE THIS
PROPOSAL STUDENTS WHO COMMON
THEY'RE VERY CLEAR ABOUT THE
FACT THAT THEY WANT TO BE ESTá
MAJOR MANY OF THOSE STUDENTS
ARE RIDE IN WITH THAT LEVEL OF
PREPARATION. BUT A STUDENT WHO
WE HAVE NOT ASKED TO DO THAT
WHO MAY WANT TO BE ESTA MAJOR
BUT CURRENTLY THE REQUIREMENTS
ONLY REQUIRE THAT STUDENTS TAKE
THREE YEARS OF MATH A
QUANTITATIVE REASONING THAT
STUDENTS. ARE ALMOST BY DEFAULT
IS ELIMINATED FROM BEING A STAY
MAJOR BEFORE THEY ARE ROLE IN
THEIR FIRST COLLEGE COURSE SO
THE IDEAL IS NATHAN IS MENTION
IS TO SYSTEMATICALLY RAISE THE
LEVEL OF PREPARATION FOR ALL
STUDENTS SO THAT THEY HAVE
REASONABLE CHOICES ABOUT THE
MAJOR CHOICE THAT THEY WANT TO
PURSUE STEM OR NOT STEM.
THERE'S BEEN PROGRESS IN RECENT
YEARS AN INCREASING I WOULD.
ELIGIBILITY RATES ESPECIALLY
AMONG LATINO STUDENTS. WHAT
RESEARCH HAS CSU DONE TO EXCESS
THE IMPACT THAT THIS CHANGE
WOULD HAVE AN ELIGIBILITY. SO
AS YOU LOOK AT THE INFORMATION
THAT YOU HAVE ON YOUR YOUR
SHEET HERE WE SHOWED SORT OF
THE IMPACT OF OUTCOMES FOR
INCOMING STUDENTS WE'VE ALSO
APPLIED THAT TO OUR ANNUAL IN
ROLLED NEW STUDENTS AND
ADMITTED STUDENTS AND LOOKED AT
SORT OF TRENDS IN CALIFORNIA
BASED ON CD E. DATA. FOR THE
FUTURE STUDENT POPULATIONS AND
AS WAS MENTIONED DURING THE
PRESENTATION WITH WE DO NOT
EXPECT ANY CHANGE IN
COMPOSITION ETHNICALLY RACIALLY
OF STUDENT POPULATIONS BASED ON
THIS CHANGE GIVEN WHAT WE SEE
OCCURRING TODAY IS STUDENTS
ARRIVING AND TO THE
INTERVENTIONS THAT WE'VE
OUTLINED THAT WERE DESCRIBED IN
THE TESTIMONY IN TERMS OF
BUILDING THAT ACT. ADDITIONAL
CAPACITY WHERE IT'S NEEDED. SO
WHAT IS CSU STRATEGY FOR
ENSURING. THAT THIS PROPOSAL IF
IMPLEMENTED DOES NOT REVERSE
THE TREND. LEADING AND LEADS TO
DECLINE OF ELIGIBILITY AMONG
LATINO AFRICAN MERICAN AND
OTHER REPRESENTED STUDENTS. WHO
CAN WE HOLD RESPONSIBLE IF THAT
HAPPENS. AND HOW DO YOU SUGGEST
THAT WE HOLD CSU RESPONSIBLE
SHOULD WE PROPOSED TO WITHHOLD
FUNDS FROM CSU JUST LIKE YOU'RE
PROPOSING TO WITHHOLD ADMISSION
FROM A STUDENT WHO DOES NOT
MEET THIS NEW HIGHER STANDARD.
SO LET ME JUST SAY NO TO THE
POLLS PROPOSAL OF WITHHOLDING
FUNDS FROM THE C. ISSUE I. I
WANT TO TAKE THAT QUESTION
SERIOUSLY I A THERE'S NOTHING
IN THE DATA ANALYSIS THAT WE
HAVE CONDUCTED HISTORICALLY OR
IN REAL TIME THAT WOULD SUGGEST
THAT THERE WOULD BE SIGNIFICANT
DECLINES OF STUDENTS OF COLOR.
OR ELIGIBILITY FROM UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES IF THIS PROPOSAL
WERE ADOPTED EVERY MARCH THE
OFFICE OF THE CHANCELLOR GOALS
TO THE BOARD OF TRUSTEES AND
MAKES A PART OUR PRESENTATION.
ON ACADEMIC PREPARATION WHICH
PROFILES INCOMING STUDENTS AND
THEIR TRANS AND HOW THE
COMPOSITION OF INCOMING COURTS
LOOK COMPARED TO PREVIOUS YEARS
AND I THINK WE WOULD HAVE AN
ANNUAL WINDOW. IN TERMS OF HOW
THE COMPOSITION BOTH IN TERMS
OF GENDER ETHNICITY INCOME
LEVELS AND LEVELS OF
PREPARATION ARE CHANGING YEAR
OVER YEAR AND SO THERE'S AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR THE BOARD
THERE'S AN OPPORTUNITY FOR THE
OFFICE OF THE CHANCELLOR WITH
OUTBOARD ACTION IN SOME CASES.
ON TO TAKE CORRECTIVE ACTION IF
FOR WHATEVER REASON WE SEE THAT
THERE ARE CHANGES IN THE TRANS
OF OUR INCOMING STUDENTS AGAIN
THE C. ISSUE IS NEVER BANK MORE
COMMITTED TO NOT ONLY ACCESS
BUT ALSO EQUITY. AND
MAINTAINING ITS RICH AND
DIVERSE POPULATION OF STUDENTS
AND SO THE PROPOSAL IS NOT
INTENDED NOR THE WE THINK THAT
THE CONSEQUENCE OF THE PROPOSAL
WILL HAVE NEGATIVE. EFFECTS ON
THE COMPOSITION OF OUR INCOMING
CLASS. IT'S BEEN MORE THAN
TWENTY FIVE YEARS SINCE THE
LAST CHANGE DECEIT USE SEE
ISSUES ADMISSIONS. WE KNOW THAT
MANY HIGH SCHOOLS DO NOT
REQUIRE THE EXISTING AG EIGHT
THROUGH G. REQUIREMENTS FOR
MISSION. WHY IS THAT THE CASE
AND HOW WOULD YOU HOW WOULD
THIS PROPOSAL AFFECT THAT
SITUATION. SALT LET ME JUST SAY
WELL OVER THE LAST SEVERAL
MONTHS THAT WE'VE HAD LOTS A
CONVERSATION ABOUT THIS
PROPOSAL I HAVE MADE THE CASE
THAT THE PROPOSAL. PERHAPS
UNFAIRLY BEARS THE BURDEN OF
MANY CHALLENGES IN PUBLIC
EDUCATION THE SCOPE OF THIS
PROPOSAL IS NOT INTENDED TO
SOLVE. EVERY PROBLEM IN PUBLIC
EDUCATION WHO ARE ALL LET ME
JUST BE VERY CLEAR THE PROPOSAL
ASK SIMPLY AMONG C. ISSUE BOUND
STUDENTS IS IT REASONABLE TO
ASK THEM TO TAKE ONE ADDITIONAL
COURSE IN QUANTITATIVE REASON
AND TO STRENGTHEN THEIR
PREPARATION FOR COLIC SUCCESS.
STUDENTS TODAY WHO ARE NOT MEET
IN THE EIGHT A. G. REQUIREMENTS
FOR WHATEVER REASONS MANY OF
THEM ARE HORRIFIC I'M HORRIFIED
BY THE FACT THAT MANY STUDENTS
CURRENTLY ARE NOT MEETING THE A
TO G. REQUIREMENTS THERE IS
STILL A PATH FOR THOSE STUDENTS
TO THE CSU. HALF OF C. ISSUE
STUDENTS TODAY ARRIVE FROM
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES
SOLD THE PROPOSAL ASSEMBLY
MEMBER IS NOT NECESSARILY
INTENDED TO SOLVE THE
DISPARITIES WE SEE ACROSS THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA IS TO
ENSURE THAT THE STUDENTS WHO
ARE GOING TO ARRIVE TO THE C.
ISSUE HAVE THE VERY BEST CHANCE
OF BEING A SUCCESSFUL. ONCE
THEY ARRIVE. I GOT A COUPLE
MORE. SHE IS USE INDICATED THE
TEN MILLION WILL BE USED THIS
YEAR FOR THE NEXT THREE YEARS
TO PREPARE MATH AND SCIENCE
TEACHERS HOW MANY ADDITIONAL
STEM TEACHERS HAS CSU COMMITTED
TO PRODUCING PER YEAR AND HOW
WILL THAT ADDRESS THE OVERALL
AVAILABILITY OF TEACHERS. GIVEN
THE EXISTING ATTRITION RATE
AMONG MATH AND SCIENCE TEACHERS.
THANK YOU FOR THAT QUESTION AS
WAS MENTIONED IN THE TESTIMONY
IN ADDITION TO THE ANNUAL
INVESTMENT OF TWO POINT SEVEN
MILLION DOLLARS IN OUR MATH AND
SCIENCE TEACHER INITIATIVE.
ARCHCHANCELLOR IS COMMITTED AN
ADDITIONAL TEN MILLION OVER THE
NEXT FOUR YEARS. TWO MORE
DIRECTLY ADDRESS THE TEACHER
SHORTAGES A MATH AND SCIENCE.
JUST LAST WEEK I WAS WITH THE
CSU EDUCATION DEANS AND
DIRECTORS OF EDUCATION AND WE
SAT DOWN AROUND A TABLE AND
TALKED ABOUT. HOW WE ARE
COMMITTING TO THAT HOW WE'RE
COMMITTING TO DOUBLING THE
NUMBER OF MATH AND SCIENCE IN
COMPUTER SCIENCE TEACHERS THAT
WE PREPARE WITH THIS ADDITIONAL
FUNDING. AND WE'RE. DEVELOPING
AN IMPLEMENT IMPLEMENT TO
IMPLEMENT WE'RE GOING TO FIGURE
OUT HOW TO DO IT. OVER THE OVER
THE NEXT COUPLE OF MONTHS WE
HAVE BEEN WORKING ON THE MATH
AND SCIENCE TEACHER INITIATIVE
SINCE THE EARLY TWO THOUSAND SO
WE KNOW THE STRATEGIES WE ALSO
KNOW WE NEED TO. INCREASE
PRODUCTION TO BETTER MEET THE
NEEDS AND AS I WAS IT MENTIONED
EARLIER WE'VE IDENTIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICTS WERE GOING TO START
SO THAT THOSE SCHOOL DISTRICTS
THAT APPEAR TO HAVE
INSUFFICIENT CAPACITY OR
SCHOOLS WHERE THE COURTS TAKING
PATTERNS OF STUDENTS ARE NOT
ALLOWING THEM OR ENCOURAGING
THEM TO TAKE ADDITIONAL MATH
SCIENCE OR QUANTITATIVE
REASONING COURSES THAT'S WHAT
WE'RE GOING TO START OUR
EFFORTS. LUCIUS WHO HAS A LONG
HISTORY OF PARTNERING WITH OUR
DEPARTMENTS A COUNTY OFFICES OF
EDUCATION TO THE TO DO THIS
WORK SO THAT'S WHAT WE INTEND
TO DO. YOU MENTIONED THE TEN
MILLION DOLLAR FUNDING. SO MY
QUESTION IS WHERE IS THAT TEN
MILLION DOLLAR FUNDING COMING
FROM AND FROM WHAT OTHER
PURPOSES ARE THE FUNDS BEING
SHIFTED TO SUPPORT THIS
INITIATIVE SO THAT TEN MILLION
IS WAS PART OF A YOU MAY RECALL
IN THE- SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN OUR
STATE BUDGET. ON THE STATE
ALLOCATED A HUNDRED AND TWENTY
MILLION IN ONE TIME FUNDS FOR
ENROLLMENT GROWTH TO THE C.
ISSUE THAT WAS TO BE SPREAD
OVER A NUMBER OF YEARS OVER A
FOUR YEAR PERIOD IN THE- CSU.
PROVIDED A PLAN BACK TO THE
STATE OVER AND WHAT WOULD BE
pDONE WITH THAT THESE DOLLARS
ARE TAKEN FROM THE ENROLLMENT
GROWTH THAT ONE TIME ENROLLMENT
GROWTH FUNDING. AT CHALLENGE
WITH ENROLLMENT GROWTH IS THAT
IT IS A WELL THAT THAT'S A ONE
TIME. ALLOCATION OF RESOURCES
TO AN ONGOING COMMITMENT BUT
OUR PROGRAM PROGRAMS LIKE
TEACHER EDUCATION THAT ARE
OFTEN COMPLETED WITHIN ONE YEAR
OF POST SECONDARY WORK OR THAT
CAN INCREASE CAPACITY. IN OUR
INTEGRATED TEACHER EDUCATION
PROGRAMS ARE A PERFECT USE OF
AND ONE TIME IN ROMAN DOLLARS
SO THEY COME FROM. THAT
SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN BUDGET
ALLOCATION ONE ONE TIME DOLLARS
FOR ENROLLMENT GROWTH THIS THE
ISSUE. SO WHAT IS THE ISSUE
DOING NOW TO ENSURE THAT IS
GRADUATES. GOING TO TEACH IN
ALL AREAS OF THE STATE.
INCLUDING AREAS LIKE MY OWN
INLAND EMPIRE. AND THE CENTRAL
VALLEY WHERE STUDENTS TYPICALLY
HAVE LESS ACCESS TO QUALIFIED
STEM TEACHERS AND STEM COURSES.
AGAIN THIS WORK BUILDS UPON THE
MATH AND SCIENCE TEACHER
INITIALLY BORK THAT WE'VE BEEN
ENGAGED IN OVER THE LAST
SEVERAL DECADES. AND WE ARE
REDOUBLING OUR EFFORTS TO WORK
IN PARTNERSHIP WITH OUR SCHOOL
DISTRICT PARTNERS AND COUNTY
OFFICES OF EDUCATION TO ENSURE
THAT WE HAVE AN ADDITIONAL
SUPPLY OF MATH SCIENCE AND
COMPUTER SCIENCE TEACHERS. TO
MEET THIS THESE AREAS OF
SHORTAGE. SO I SEE THE ROLE
THAT SHE IS YOU AND THE PRINT
THIS PROPOSAL ENSURING MARK
STEM TEACHERS A GRADUATING EACH
YEAR AS A WIN WIN. KATE TWELVE
WILL HAVE MORE QUALIFIED
TEACHERS CS YOU WILL REAP THE
BENEFITS WHEN THE STUDENTS
TAUGHT BY THE GRADUATES COME TO
THEIR CAMPUSES AS FRESHMEN. AND
THE STATE WILL BENEFIT FROM
STUDENTS AND GRADUATES HAVE A
STRONGER STEM FOUNDATION. BUT
WHY NOT JUST PURSUE CAPACITY
BUILDING ON THE PART OF THE CSU
PROPOSAL WITHOUT THE PUNITIVE
ACCESS RESTRICTIONS THAT COME
WITH INCREASING ADMISSION
REQUIREMENTS. IN OTHER WORDS
WHY NOT JUST IT CONTINUED TO
INCREASE THE NUMBER OF STEM
TEACHERS. WITHOUT. IT'S TWO IN
STATING VISA RESTRICTIONS THAT
WILL. MAKE A DIFFERENCE MORE
DIFFICULT FOR STUDENTS TO IT
GAIN ADMISSION INTO CS YES ALSO
I WOULD JUST SAY QUICKLY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RIGHT I THINK
RATHER THAN EVEN EITHER OR WE
PREFER BOTH AND A FEW WEEKS AGO
THE C. ISSUE HOSTS A COUNSELOR
CONFERENCE HIGH SCHOOL
COUNSELORS ALL ACROSS THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA. AND MANY OF THEM
HAVE BEEN MADE AWARE OF THE
PROPOSAL. AND MANY OF THEM
AGREE WITH THE PROPOSAL BUT
HERE'S WHAT STRUCK ME IN SOME
OF THOSE CONVERSATIONS.
ALTHOUGH THERE COULD BE A
COMMITMENT IN IS A COMMITMENT
TO INCREASE THE NUMBER OF
TEACHERS WHAT WE REQUIRE AND
OUR EXPECTATIONS OF STUDENTS
MATTERS THE NUMBER OF HIGH
SCHOOL COUNSELORS WHO SAID TO
ME JAMES YOU WOULD NOT BELIEVE
THE NUMBER STUDENTS WERE
LEAVING HIGH SCHOOL AT NOON.%
BECAUSE THEY FOR FEEL THE HIGH
SCHOOL GRADUATION REQUIREMENTS
AND THEY'VE ALREADY MET THE CSU
ELIGIBILITY STANDARDS AND
BECAUSE WE DON'T ASK THEM TO DO
ANYTHING MORE THEY DON'T. THEY
DON'T. AND SO I THINK IT IT IS
A POSSIBLE YES WE NEED TO
INCREASED A TEACHER
PRODUCTIVITY. ARE IN TEACHER
CANDIDATES WHO WERE GOING INTO
A HIGH NEED AREAS BUT I THINK
IT'S ALSO IMPORTANT THAT WE
REQUIRE WHAT WE BELIEVE
STUDENTS NEED TO BE SUCCESSFUL
UPON ARRIVAL. AS I THINK YOU
CAN DO BOTH AT THE SAME TIME.
THANK YOU. THIS MCCARTY THANK
YOU I THINK YOU NEEDED A BREAK
MR MEDINA BUT THE GOOD NEWS IS
YOU CAN YOU CAN GO BACK BECAUSE
WE DON'T HAVE. ANYBODY ELSE
APPEARED TO ASK QUESTIONS. OKAY
TAKE OVER YOUR PATIENT.
IMPORTANT QUESTIONS YEAH YEAH I
KNOW AND I THAT HELP FRAME SOME
OF MY QUESTIONS AND I DON'T
WANT TO BE REPETITIVE I JUST
WANTED TO JUST TALK BIG PICTURE
SAID IT WAS TWO YEARS YOU PUT
THIS PROPOSAL OUT THEN I THINK
I FIRST HEARD ABOUT IT THIS
SUMMER IT CERTAINLY WASN'T
ANYTHING THAT. THAT THAT THE
LEGISLATURE AT NEW ABOUT WE
TALKED ABOUT MAYBE OUR SPEAKER
BEING THAT HE'S A MEMBER OF THE
CSU TRUSTEES BUT THERE WASN'T A
LOT OF BACK AND FORTH HERE I
WANT YOU TALK ABOUT THE
ENGAGEMENT I DIDN'T SEE AND I
SEE A SHEET WITH FOLKS WHO HAVE
CONCERNS I DON'T SEE SHEET OF
THE PEOPLE WHO ARE SUPPORTING.
BUT SHE DID THE FACULTY FOR THE
CSU WHETHER IT'S THAT YOUR
ACADEMIC SENATE'S OR THE THEY
DID OR BY COLLECTIVE BARGAINING
ORGANIZATION THE CFA HAVE. THEY
ENGAGED IN THIS HAVE THEY TAKEN
A POSITION. SO THE PROPOSAL IS
A RESULT. OF A TASK FORCE
REPORT THAT FOR MORE STATEWIDE
ACADEMIC SENATE IN TWENTY THIRD
THE TASK FORCE BEGIN IN TWENTY
FOURTEEN THE REPORT CAME OUT IN
TWENTY SIXTEEN. WITH A MADE FOR
RECOMMENDATIONS ONE OF WHICH
WAS. THIS ADDITIONAL OF
REQUIREMENT RELATED TO QUANTITY
I AGREE THAT MEANS AND IT DID
YEAH YES OKAY AND NOW YOU'RE AT
THE UNION AND THEY ARE NOT
BASHFUL THEY THEY SHARE THEIR
OPINIONS READILY. APPEAR AT THE
STATE CAPITOL. WHERE ARE THEY
WITH THIS PROPOSAL. THE
CALIFORNIA FACULTY IS SO YEAH
CFA HAVE YES THAT A LETTER OF
OPPOSITION OKAY I DIDN'T SEE
THEM ON THIS LIST HERE. THIS
LIST ARE THE ON HERE. THEY ARE
OKAY AND THIS THAT. ANYWAY OKAY
THEN YOU YOU'RE YOU'RE
DISTRICTS I SEE THERE'S A FEW
DISTRICTS TO HAVE IT EXPRESSED
CONCERN ONE THE DUPLICATES THAT
SUPER TEN AND THE DISTRICT BUT
YOU MENTIONED THAT THERE'S FIVE
DISTRICTS THAT CURRENTLY HAVE
ALL OTHER STUDENTS DO THIS
ALREADY ARE THOSE DISTRICTS HE
I THINK HE SAID LONG BEACH
STOCKED IN SAN DIEGO ARE THEY
IN SUPPORT OF THIS PROPOSAL SEC
SO THEY'RE ACTUALLY FAR MORE
THAN THAT FOR THE FIVE LARGEST
ALREADY HAVE GRADUATION
REQUIREMENTS DIED SATISFIED
THERE THESE REQUIREMENTS YEAH
BOTH LONG BEACH UNIFIED IN SAN
DIEGO UNIFIED HAVE WRITTEN
FORMAL LETTERS OF SUPPORT PART
WE HAVE NOT ASKED ALL THE
LARGEST AGAIN EVEN THOUGH WE'VE
HAD. AGAIN ND GET BEEN
ENGAGING THEM WE HAVE NOT MADE
THAT ASK OF THEM YEAH SO THERE
ARE MANY DISTRICTS SCHOOL
DISTRICTS THAT ALREADY DO THIS
AND SUPPORT THIS POLICY YES
YEAH HOW MANY OF THE THOUSANDS
WHO SO SCHOOL DISTRICT IN
CALIFORNIA THEIR HIGH SCHOOL
DISTRICTS DO YOU THINK
CURRENTLY HAVE THIS REQUIREMENT
OF THE FOUR YEARS MAP SLASH Q.
R. I DO NOT HAVE THE SPECIFIC
ANSWER THAT SAID WE SORT OF
STARTED WITH THE LARGEST AND
THEN AS AS WAS REFERENCE
CONDUCTOR CORNER SHIRES
TESTIMONY AS WELL WE LOOKED AT
THE SMALLEST THE SMALLEST AS
WELL TO SORT OF LOOK AT BOTH
ENDS BUT I DON'T HAVE A TOTAL
COUNT. AT THIS MOMENT AND WE I
WILL SAY THAT WE HAVE BEEN
ENGAGE WITH THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT EDUCATION ON THIS
CONVERSATION FOR SOME TIME THEY
ALSO DID NOT HAVE AN EXACT
ARTICULATION OF THAT EITHER SO
IT'S REALLY BEEN THROUGH THE
EVALUATION THAT WE'VE
IDENTIFIED. THE DISTRICTS WE
HAVE THUS FAR. OKAY. AND THEN.
THE WITH WHAT DO YOU SAY TO
THE- I KNOW THERE'S IT WILL GET
TO THE SECONDS FAR AS THE-
INDIVIDUAL STUDENTS. BUT WHAT
DO YOU SAY TO THE SCHOOL
DISTRICTS LIKE. SIGN SACRAMENTO
SAN BERNADINO SANTANA. ANAHEIM
WHO HAVE CONCERNS WITH THIS
POLICY YOU KNOW THEY MAY NOT
HAVE THE WHEREWITHAL TO. SHOOT
TO HIRE FACULTY TO TEACH THESE
COURSES ASSEMBLY MEMBER IT IF I
MAY. YOU KNOW I TOLD A GROUP
LAST WEEK EVERYBODY LIKES
CHANGE EXCEPT FOR THE CHANGE
PART. A YEAR AGO OR TWO YEARS
AGO WHEN WE WERE ADVANCE AN
EXECUTIVE ORDER ELEVEN TEN.
SIMILAR OPPOSITIONAL FORCES
AROSE. THIS IS HARMFUL FOR
STUDENTS STUDENTS OF COLOR
GONNA BE HARMED YOUR HE EVEN
STUDENTS WHO ARE UNDER PREPARED
INTO COLLEGE CLASSROOMS THEY'RE
ALL GOING TO FAIL. EXETER
ECCENTRIC CENTER RESOLUTIONS
LETTERS OF OPPOSITION. A YEAR
LATER ASSEMBLY MEMBER WE TOOK
THE FINDINGS ARE THE RESULTS
FROM THAT POLICY CHANGE. AND
DEMONSTRATED A STUDENTS WHO
OTHERWISE WOULD HAVE BEEN
ASSIGNED TO A DEVELOPMENTAL
EDUCATION COULD NOT GET THE
UNDERSTANDABLE THE BUDGET
QUESTION BECAUSE WE HAD SO WE
DEAL WITH WHAT I'M WHAT I WOULD
LIKE TO RESPOND TO AS YOU'RE
ASKING QUESTIONS ABOUT THE
OPPOSITION. YEAH AND ABOUT WHO
SORT OF POLITICALLY HAS ALIGNED
WITH WHO NO NOT UPS AND SAYING
WHAT WOULD YOU SAY TO A SCHOOL
DISTRICT IS POLICY COMES INTO
EFFECT THE AB I GET EIGHT YEARS
TO. TO ROLLED IN WHICH IS A
LONG TIME TO GET THAT LOSS THAT
SAME QUESTION THE NEXT PANEL.
THAT THERE IS A DESERT SO YOU
KNOW WE LIKE THIS WE WANT TO DO
IT BUT WE WERE WE KNOW WHERE.
OUR CASTERS AND PURRS WERE
BARELY UNDER BARELY AFLOAT
ALMOST UNDER WATER AND ARE ARE
DISTRICTS YOU OTHER STRAP WE
HAVE ONE HERE IT'S NOT TO RUN
OUT OF CASH AND LA IN OAKLAND
AND THEY HAVE REAL CHALLENGES
IN A BOOMING ECONOMY. WHAT'S
THE NEXT RECESSION HITS AND
THEY HAVE TO MAKE THESE TOUGH
DECISIONS WHAT DO YOU DO THAT
AND SO HOW DO YOU WILL WHAT DO
YOU SAY TO THESE DISTRICTS THAT
NEED TO HIRE. ADDITIONAL STATS
OR TRIGONOMETRYWHAT. WHAT HAVE
YOU. GOT HOLD SOLD PROFESSING
SO LET ME JUST. ANSWER MORE
DIRECTLY I THINK YOU HEARD IN
THE FIRST TESTIMONY THAT WHEN
THESE CHANGES OCCUR. SCHOOLS
DISTRICTS. AND SCHOOLS AND
STUDENTS AND FAMILIES A JEST.
THE SECOND THING I WOULD I
WOULD JUST SAY IS THAT. YOU
KNOW I DON'T WANT US TO OVER
ESTIMATE WHAT MIGHT BE REQUIRED
FOR STUDENTS TO MEET THIS
REQUIREMENT. AGAIN VIRTUALLY
EVERY COMPREHENSIVE HIGH SCHOOL
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA HAS
COURSES IN PLACE TO DAY. THAT
WOULD MEET THIS REQUIREMENT. A
NUMBER OF SCHOOL DISTRICTS THAT
YOU HEARD NAY TH AND SAID AS A-
BY PRODUCT OF GRADUATING THE
STUDENTS WOULD HAVE MET THIS
REQUIREMENT. AND SO I JUST WANT
TO BE REALISTIC ABOUT WHAT THE
LEFTY AS FOR SCHOOL DISTRICTS.
TO GO FROM FIFTEEN COURSES TO
SIXTEEN COURSES OVER SIX OR
SEVEN YEAR PERIOD YOU'RE SAYING
IT'S NOT THAT BIG OF LIFE. I
JUST DON'T THINK IT'S
INSURMOUNTABLE WHAT ARE SCHOOL
DISTRICTS GOING TO HAVE TO MAKE
SOME CHANGES. ARE TOUGH CHOICES
AND BETTER PREPARE STUDENTS FOR
COLLEGE YES ADAM ALREADY HAVE
THOSE COURSES AND THEY'RE NOT
BEING. UTILIZED BY STUDENTS
GOING WHAT I'M SUGGESTING IS
THAT WE HAVE NOT REQUIRE
STUDENTS TO TAKE. THE LEVEL OF
PREPARATION REQUIRE FOR THEM TO
BE SUCCESSFUL UPON ENTRY OKAY.
AND THEN AS FAR AS THE BUT MAY
I MAY I MORE DIRECTLY OR IN A
IN A PERHAPS. A DIFFERENT WAY
ADDRESS THAT QUESTION. ASSEMBLY
MANNER ASSEMBLYMEMBER CART. WE
COMMIT TO CONTINUING OUR
COLLABORATIVE WORK WITH OUR
SCHOOL DISTRICT PARTNERS AND SO
THE BEST EXAMPLE OF THAT IS OUR
E. R. W. C. COURSE. AND SO
RIGHT NOW WE ARE AND WE HAVE AN
MRI WC COURSE OF THIS IS A
FOCUS ON MATHEMATICAL
REASONING. THAT WE WILL USE THE
SUCCESSFUL MODEL OF THE R. WC.
WHICH IS BEING DISTRIBUTED
THROUGH COUNTY OFFICES OF
EDUCATION AND OFFER THIS COURSE
IN PARTNERSHIP WITH THOSE HIGH
SCHOOLS. IN ADDITION TO WORKING
WITH THEM TO DEVELOP AND
IDENTIFY EXISTING Q. R. COURSES
THAT ARE IN THEIR COURSE
SCHEDULE RIGHT NOW SO. SO
THAT'S THE COMMITMENT THAT WE
WILL CONTINUE TO MAKE IS TO
PARTNER WITH OUR SCHOOL
DISTRICTS TO BUILD THIS
CAPACITY OVERTIME GOTCHA. AND
AS FAR AS THE EXEMPTIONS FOR
THE STUDENTS THAT THAT WAS ONE
OF MY- CONCERNS I DIDN'T QUITE
UNDERSTAND THE POLICY YOU'RE
SAYING THAT. IF YOU'RE A
STUDENT. WHO AND YOUR AT A
SCHOOL WHO DOESN'T HAVE AN
OPTION FOR YOUR FOURTH YEAR.
YOUR EXEMPTED BUT IT'S AN
AUTOMATIC EXEMPTION OFF TO DO A
SUPPLEMENTAL APPLICATIONS
CORRECT SO IT DOESN'T GET ALL
ON THE STOOD ON THE STUDENT OF
THE FAMILY MEMBER THAT'S A KEY
QUESTION NEXT PANEL AND WHAT'S
THE BIG DEAL IF YOU ALREADY
HAVE THIS. AUTOMATIC EXEMPTION
IN THERE AND THEN AS FAR AS
IT'S A LITTLE CONFUSING THE
NORMALLY YOU WOULD THINK THAT
THAT YOU SEE WHAT HAVE THE
HIGHER STANDARD SO WITH. CSU
COMING BEFORE YOU SEE. AS
SOMEWHAT ODD TO ME AND SO MEYER
SETTING IS THE LAST TIME WE DID
THE A THREE G. CHANGES THEY
KIND OF CAME. AS A PACKAGE AND
THIS ONE'S KIND OF A ONE OFF.
AND YOU WOULD THINK. THAT THE
UC ONE WOULD COME FIRST NOT THE
CSU NOT KNOCKING THIS IS YOU OF
COURSE I'M CSU GRADUATE THANK
YOU. BUT MAYBE YOU COULD TOUCH
ON THAT. SO LET ME JUST SAY
QUICKLY WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO
ADDRESS AND I DON'T WORK FOR
THE UC SO I CAN'T SPEAK FOR THE
UC. BUT WHAT I NOW AND THEN. WE
DO IT ALL THE TIME I'M NOT WELL
WELL MAYBE I'LL TAKE THE
LIBERTY HERE. BUT WHAT WE KNOW
ABOUT THE COMPOSITION AND THE
PROFILE OF THEIR INCOME IS
STUDENTS IS PROBABLY 99% OF
THEM. ARRIVE WITH FOUR OR MORE
YEARS OF MATH OF QUANTITATIVE
NINE SIX YARDS A NOMINATION FOR
THAT SECTOR. OKAY AND THAT
LEADS ME TO MY NEXT QUESTION SO
YOU TALKED ABOUT WHICH I WAS
INTERESTED THAT 91% OF YOUR
STUDENTS A ROLE THAT CSU HAVE
TAKEN FOR MORE COURSES RIGHT.
NOT 91% OF INCOMING STUDENTS
WOULD HAVE MET THIS REQUIRE YET
ONCE YOU ADD AREA SEE AREA DE
AN AREA SHE COURSES THAT'S KIND
OF WHEN I MET BUT YES MUCH
BETTER. SO OUT OF THIS OTHER
STUDENTS. THAT THAT. IT DIDN'T
ENTER CSU RIGHT NOW NEEDING
REMEDIATION GRANTED I KNOW
YOU'RE CHANGING NOW THERE'S NO
LONGER GOING TO BE YOU'RE GOING
TO INCORPORATE INTO ONE. WOULD
YOU SAY THAT THAT THEY'RE
DISPROPORTIONATELY FROM
STUDENTS WHO DIDN'T HAVE THESE
COURSES ABSOLUTELY YEAH.
ABSOLUTELY IT'S A STUDENTS WHO
ARE BEHIND THE REASON THERE BE
ASK IF THE MISTER ENOS QUESTION
THE WRITTEN THAT'S WHY YOU'RE
DOING THIS YOU SAY
UNEQUIVOCALLY. LET'S LET'S
START START RIGHT HERE THIS IS
THIS IS WHY WE'RE HERE TODAY SO
YOU'RE SAYING THAT THE STUDENTS
WHO ARE BEHIND WHEN THEY ENTER
CSU NEED REMARK REMEDIATION.
THEIR DISPROPORTIONATELY
STUDENTS WHO HAD THREE OR FEWER
OF THESE COURSES AND SO THEY
JUST THERE. THEY START BEHIND
THE STAY BEHIND ABSOLUTELY AND
HOW HOW HOW CAN YOU. BE SO
CONFIDENT CAN YOU WALK THROUGHS
NUMBER WELL WHAT WE DO WE CAN
LOOK AT THE PROFILE OF INCOMING
STUDENTS AND WE CAN LOOK AT THE
PROFILE OF STUDENTS AND
PREVIOUS CALL COURTS WHO WERE
REQUIRED. TO TAKE DEVELOPMENTAL
EDUCATION COURSES OR WOULD
DEEMED UNDERPREPARED YEAH AND
DISPROPORTIONATELY. THOSE
STUDENTS ARE STUDENTS OF COLOR.
THOSE STUDENTS ARE FIRST
GENERATION STUDENTS AND ALL
STUDENTS HAVE LIMITED
PREPARATION AND QUANTITATIVE
REASONING A MATHEMATICS TO VERY
CLEAR. AND ONE THING THAT'S
INTERESTING IF YOU LOOK AT AT
CSU YOU'RE MUCH MORE DIVERSE
THAN THE THAN THE UC SO IF THIS
WAS A CHANGE THAT YOU SEE
ADDING A. B. GREATER CONCERN
BECAUSE- UNDERREPRESENTED
STUDENTS THAT YOU SEE IN CS AT
UC ART ARE ALREADY HAVING A
TOUGH TIME. MEETING THE NUMBERS
ARE AT BUT THE PIPELINE OF HIGH
SCHOOL GRADUATES. IS VERY
DIVERSE IN THE FIRST PLACE SO
THE NUMBERS FOR CSU. THE
MAJORITY OF CS USE OUR HISPANIC
SERVING INSTITUTIONS YEAH
BECAUSE 50% OF HIGH SCHOOL
KIDS. REAP REFLECT THAT
POPULATION. AFTER AMERICAN
POPULATION I THINK IS PRETTY ON
PAR WITH HIGH SCHOOL GRAD RATES
AT CSU IF I'M NOT MISTAKEN. SO
IF THIS POLICY WENT INTO A
FACT. WOULD YOU HAVE ANY
CONCERN THAT THE DIVERSITY
NUMBERS WOULD CHANGE OR THEY
WOULD REMAIN THE SAME AS FAR AS
YOUR INCOMING. CLASS I OR
PRESIDENT TRANSFER STUDENTS I
DON'T I THINK WE HAVE TO
REMEMBER WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
TWENTY TWENTY SIX. AND I THINK
FOR CURRENT MIDDLE SCHOOLERS
TODAY IF IT BECAME KNOWN IN THE
BORE WAS TO ADOPT THIS POLICY
THAT THE REQUIREMENT FOR ONE
ADDITIONAL QUANTITATIVE
REASONING COURSE. WAS REQUIRED
FOR MINIMUM ELIGIBILITY FOR THE
C. ISSUE THIS IS A REASONABLE
ASKED TO STRENGTHEN THE
PREPARATION OF INCOMING
STUDENTS. THEN WE ASK ABOUT
CAPACITY AND CAPACITY BUILDING
OVER THE SEVEN YEAR PERIOD
THERE'S NOTHING IN OUR ANALYSIS
THIS SUGGESTS THAT THIS WOULD
ALTER CURTAIL ACCESS FOR
HISTORICALLY UNDER REPRESENTED
POPULATIONS THERE JUST ISN'T.
THE WORST THING THAT CAN HAPPEN
IS THAT MANY MORE OF THEM
BECOME ELIGIBLE FOR THE UC. BY
WAY OF STRENGTHENED IN THEIR
PREPARATION SO I'D I DON'T WANT
US TO BE. I DON'T WANT US TO A
TO EXAGGERATE THE PROPOSITION
THAT SOMEHOW THIS BE A STUDENTS
ARE NOT GOING TO RESPOND TO
THIS AND THEREFORE WE'RE GOING
TO HAVE DRAMATIC DIFFERENCES.
AND AN ELIGIBILITY OR THE
RACIAL COMPOSITION OF OUR
INCOMING CLASS YEAH. OKAY AND
THEN LASTLY BEFORE IT'S THE
NEXT. LOOKS LIKE. YEAH I
UNDERSTAND THAT THAT THEIR
EXPECTATIONS OF STUDENTS ARE
CHANGING THE THAT NEED FOR MORE
STEM THE ECONOMIC CHANGES FOR
WHAT BUT GRADUATES ARE SO YOU
KNOW YOU YOU CAN LOOK AT THIS
AS TWO WAYS YOU CAN BE LIKE. AS
AS THEY ARE. SIR CONSULTANT
OUTLINED EARLIER. IN THAT
RATIONING OF ACCESS SO HE SAID
THIS KIND OF THE WE TALKED
ABOUT THERE IS THAT. FOR
WHATEVER REASONS THEY ONLY HAVE
TWENTY THREE CAMPUS AREAS WERE
IMPACTED WE HAVE MORE MORE HIGH
SCHOOL GRADUATING STUDENTS THE
STATE'S BY GIVING IT UP ENOUGH
MONEY TO FIND ON ROMAN SO YOU
NEED TO HAVE SOME. THING AND
THERE TO LIKE THROW A WET
BLANKET ON THE EXPECTATIONS OF
STUDENTS TRYING TO GO TO
COLLEGE. BUT OF THE FLIP SIDE
OF COURSE IS YEARS YOU'RE
SAYING. THAT YOU KNOW THIS IS
THE REALITY FOR WHAT STUDENTS
NEED TO SUCCEED AT CSU AND NOT
BEING REMEDIATION. AND MEET THE
REQUIREMENTS FOR BUT A COLLEGE
GRADUATE NEEDS IN THIS IN THIS
ECONOMY. SO. WHAT WOULD YOU SAY
ONE MORE TIME TO. INDIVIDUALS
WHO HAVE GREAT CONCERNS AT THIS
WOULD. LIMIT ACCESS FOR
STUDENTS BECAUSE YOU'RE NOT IN
THIS BUSINESS I WOULD THINK TO
AND THE CSU. TO LIMIT ACCESS TO
CALIFORNIA THAT'S WHY YOU EXIST
IN SO. HOW WOULD YOU RESPOND TO
THAT. THE GOOD THAT HELD THE
LESSONS OF THE INDIVIDUALS AND
GROUPS AT ARKANSAS ALL BEGAN
AND ALL ALL TURN MY COLLEAGUES
TO ROUND OUT A RESPONSE. YOU
WON'T WHEN WE EVEN THOUGH AS
HAS BEEN CHAIRED THIS
CONVERSATION HAS BEEN ONGOING
SENSE OF OUR ACADEMIC SENATE
CREATED THEIR TASK FORCE ON
THIS TOPIC IN TWENTY FOURTEEN
WITH A REPORT IN TWENTY
SIXTEEN. ALONG THAT SAME TIME
AS YOU HEARD FROM THE PRIOR
SPEAKER THE STATE CONDUCTED AN
ELIGIBILITY STUDY WHICH
ULTIMATELY FOUND THE BASED ON
THE GRADUATING CLASS OF TWENTY
FIFTEEN OF HIGH SCHOOL
STUDENTS. BUT THE C. ISSUES.
CURRENT CRITERIA CAPTURING
ABOUT 41% OF THE STUDENTS. AT
THAT POINT OUR TRUSTEES OUR
SYSTEM EXAMINE THAT DATA AND
MADE A DECISION TO MAKE NO
CHANGES IN ELIGIBILITY IT THE
CSU REINFORCED ITS COMMITMENT
TO ACCESS THIS CONVERSATION WAS
BORN OUT OF A DISCUSSION ABOUT
ACADEMIC PREPARATION AND WHAT
REALLY IS IMPORTANT FOR
STUDENTS TO BE SUCCESSFUL IN
OUR INSTITUTION AND ALSO TO BE
SUCCESSFUL IN CALIFORNIA IN THE
FUTURE IN THE FACE OF SORT OF
CHANGING WORKFORCE AND SOCIETAL
NEEDS WHETHER THAT BE IN STEM
DISCIPLINES WHETHER BEING JUST
UNDERSTANDING BASIC INFORMATION
SCIENCE BEING ABLE TO.
UNDERSTAND POLITICAL POLLING
AND DATA COMING OUT THEM ON A
DAY TO DAY BASIS I'M IT REALLY
BEGAN IN A CONVERSATION ABOUT
WHAT WAS NECESSARY AND THE
NECESSARY ACADEMIC PREPARATION
SO THERE WAS AN EASIER CHANGE
TO MAKE IF IT REALLY WAS ABOUT
CURTAILING ACCESS BASED ON THAT
ELIGIBILITY STUDY FROM TWENTY
FIFTEEN THAT'S NOT WHAT THIS
CONVERSATION WAS ABOUT IT
REALLY WAS ABOUT WHAT IS THE
BEST PREPARATION NECESSARY TO
ADDRESS EQUITY AND MAKE SURE
ALL OF OUR STUDENTS ARE
COMPETITIVE. FOR CSU STUDENTS
AND IN THE FUTURE. AND THEN.
LASTLY WE. WHAT'S WHEN IS THE
PROPOSED HEARING. AND THE VOTE
FOR THIS AT THE CSU BOARD
JUSTICE THIS WILL BE ON THE-
BOARD AGENDA FOR THEIR NOVEMBER
BOARD OF TRUSTEES MEETING WHICH
I BELIEVE IS NOVEMBER
NINETEENTH AND TWENTY OKAY
COMING UP. ANYTHING ELSE TO ADD
MICHAEL. THANK YOU MISTER MEDIA
THANK YOU. PERHAPS COMMENTS
RATHER THAN QUESTIONS SINCE WE
HAD THE DISCUSSION HERE IN THIS
COMMITTEE AND WE SAW THE
LEGISLATION BOTH FOR COMMUNITY
COLLEGE AND CSU TO GET RID OF
REMEDIAL CLASSES I VERY MUCH
GET THE THRUST OF THAT HAVING
BEEN COMMUNITY COLLEGE
INSTRUCTOR HAVING BEEN
COMMUNITY COLLEGE CHRISTY. YOU
KNOW I KNOW VERY WELL THAT BOTH
AT THE CSU AND AT THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE WHEN STUDENTS WERE
STOCK AND HAVING TO TAKE
REMEDIATION IN A MATH AND
ENGLISH AND I HAD MORE
EXPERIENCE WITH THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE THEY WOULD NEVER GET TO
COLLEGE LEVEL MATH OR ENGLISH
AND SO IT WOULD BE PRETTY HARD
TO. GET AN A DEGREE OR A FOUR
YEAR DEGREE IF YOU'RE ALWAYS
STUCK AND REMEDIATION I THINK
THAT WAS THE THRUST OF BOTH THE
LEGISLATION FOR A COMMUNITY
COLLEGE AND THE CSU AND THEN I
SAW IMPLEMENTATION OF THAT AT
STANFORD AND DINO. A CSU CAL
STATE SALMON A DINO WITH THE
BRIDGE PROGRAM I'D BRING IN AND
SOME STUDENTS OVER THE SUMMER
TO DO VERY FAST BRINGING THEM
UP TO SPEED BUT DURING THE
SUMMER AND CONTINUING DURING
THE ACADEMIC YEAR. BUT THIS
PROPOSAL SEEMS TO ME TO BE
SOMEWHAT OF A REVERSE OF COURSE
THE LA TIMES EDITORIAL SAYS YOU
KNOW ITS- TAKING STUDENTS. LA
TIMES EDITORIAL ON JULY TWENTY
NINTH THEY SAY EIGHT REQUIRING
ALL APPLICANTS AT CAL STATE TO
TAKE A FOUR YEAR. SUBSTANTIALLY
RAISE CAL STATE GRADUATION
RATES OR PRINT PERHAPS NOT BUT
IT THE FRIEND IN. WOULD ALSO
MAKE IT HARDER FOR STUDENTS TO
APPLY TO CAL STATE ESPECIALLY
BLACK AND LATINO STUDENTS SO
THIS SEEMS TO ME A REVERSAL OF
STAKING STUDENTS WHERE THEY ARE
AND TRYING TO DO THE WORK. IT
WHILE THEY ARE STUDENTS THERE.
YOU MENTIONED A COUPLE OF
DISTRICTS YOU MENTIONED MARTIN
LUTHER KING HIGH SCHOOL IN MY
DISTRICT OF RIVERSIDE UNIFIED.
AND AGAIN I'VE SPOKEN TO THE AS
SUPERINTENDENT. OF RIVERSIDE
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT HE IS
VERY STRONGLY A PROSE OPPOSED
TO THIS PROPOSAL. I STILL HAVE
A MANY CONCERNS AND I HOPE THAT
WE CAN CLARIFY SOME OF THOSE AS
WE MOVE ALONG IN THIS HEARING
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU.
AND THEN WE WILL BRING UP.
MICHELLE SEEK YELLOWS PRESIDENT
OF THE CAMPAIGN FOR COLLEGE
OPPORTUNITY AND CHRISTOPHER AT
LEAGUE CO FOUNDER AND PRESIDENT
EMERITUS THE OPPORTUNITY
INSTITUTE AND LAW PROFESSOR AT
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
BERKELEY SCHOOL OF LAW. WELCOME.
YEAH GOOD. BEGIN WHENEVER
YOU'RE READY. THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MEDINA THANK
YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER MCCARTY FOR
HOSTING THIS HEARING TODAY AND
FOR INVITING ME TO SPEAK AYE
MICHELLE SEE KATO'S PRESIDENT
OF THE CAMPAIGN FOR COLLEGE
OPPORTUNITY BUT I ALWAYS LIKE
TO SAY I'M ALSO THE FIRST IN MY
FAMILY TO GO TO COLLEGE AND WAY
BACK IN THAT DAY THEY WERE A
THROUGHOUT FOR CHOIR MEN'S
WHICH I ACTUALLY HAD NO IDEA
THAT I WAS EVEN IN ROLLED AND
SO I WAS ONE OF THE LUCKY
STUDENTS THAT GOT TRAPPED SO
THAT I COULD HAVE THE CHANCE TO
GO TO. A COLLEGE AND EARNED A
BACHELOR'S DEGREE AND THEN I GO
TO UCLA AND GET MY MASTER'S
DEGREE I THE CAMPAIGN WAS
FOUNDED FIFTEEN YEARS AGO BY
MAULED AFTER THE MEXICAN
AMERICAN LEGAL DEFENSE AND
EDUCATIONAL FUND THE CALIFORNIA
BUSINESS ROUNDTABLE IN THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE LEAGUE WITH
THE SOLE PURPOSE AND FOCUS ON
ENSURING THAT MORE CALIFORNIA
STUDENTS WOULD HAVE ACCESS AND
AN OPPORTUNITY TO ATTEND
COLLEGE IN OUR STATE. THE
CAMPAIGN AS MANY OF YOU KNOW
HAS USHERED SOME OF THE MOST
TRANSFORMATIVE HIGHER AT POLICY
IN CALIFORNIA IN TWENTY TEN WE
WORKED CLOSELY WITH THEN
SENATOR ALEX PADILLA AND
SPONSORED SENATE BILL. FOURTEEN
FORTY WHICH CREATED THE
ASSOCIATE DEGREE FOR TRANSFER.
VERY MUCH STREAMLINING THE
PROCESS FOR STUDENTS TO GET
BETWEEN A COMMUNITY COLLEGE
WITH GUARANTEED ADMISSION AS
JUNIORS INTO THE CSU. I AM
PLEASED TO SHARE WITH ALL OF
YOU TODAY THAT OVER TWO HUNDRED
THOUSAND CALIFORNIA STUDENTS
HAVE EARNED AN ASSOCIATE DEGREE
FOR TRANSFER. IN TWENTY
SEVENTEEN WE ALSO WORK CLOSELY
WITH THIS CHAMBER AND SPONSORED
ASSEMBLY BILL SEVEN OH FIVE
AUTHORED BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
JACQUI IRWIN THAT REQUIRES
COMMUNITY COLLEGES TO USE HIGH
SCHOOL PLACEMENT TEST. THAT
REQUIRES A COMMUNITY COLLEGES
TO USE HIGH SCHOOL PERFORMANCE
AND GPA NOT PLACEMENT TEST. IN
ORDER TO REALLY EFFECTIVELY
ENSURE THAT ALL TALENTED
STUDENTS ARE PUT IN COLLEGE
LEVEL CLASS COURSES THAT THEY
WERE READY FOR EVEN THOUGH IT
TASK MAY NOT HAVE PREDICTED
THAT. BETWEEN OF THE FALL OF
TWENTY SEVENTEEN AND THIS FALL
THE NUMBER OF TRANSFER LOVER
LEVEL COURSES IN MATH AND
ENGLISH BEING OFFERED. BY
COMMUNITY COLLEGES HAS MORE
THAN DOUBLED. WE'VE WORKED WITH
YOU VERY CLOSELY TO AN WITH
CALIFORNIA GOVERNORS. TO SECURE
OVER THREE BILLION IN THE STATE
FUNDING FOR SIXTY THOUSAND
ADDITIONAL SPOTS FOR CALIFORNIA
STUDENTS IN THE UC AND CSU. AND
WE'VE PUBLISHED OVER SEVENTY
GROUND BREAKING RESEARCH
REPORTS INCLUDING LEFT OUT
ACCESS DENIED THE STATE OF
HIGHER EDUCATION FOR LOT NEXEN
BLACK STUDENTS IN CALIFORNIA.
THE TRANSFER MAYES AND DIVIDED
WE FAIL ALL THESE REPORTS
FOCUSED ON PUTTING A SPOTLIGHT
ON THE WORK WE NEED TO DO TO
IMPROVE COLLEGE ACCESS.
COMPLETION AND MOST IMPORTANTLY
TO CLOSE THE STUBBORN RACIAL
EQUITY GAPS THAT PERSIST IN OUR
STATE. WE ARE RELENTLESSLY
FOCUSED ON RACIAL EQUITY IN
COLLEGE ACCESS AND COMPLETION
AND HAVE BEEN NECESSARILY
IMPATIENT WITH THE PACE OF
CHANGE REQUIRED TO IMPROVE
ACCESS AND COMPLETION IN
CALIFORNIA. FOR TODAY'S
STUDENTS. I HAVE I HOPE YOU
HAVE IN FRONT OF YOU SOME
HANDOUTS THAT I WANTED TO
QUICKLY GO THROUGH. ON PAGE TWO
OF THE HAND OUTS YOU CAN SEE
WHY WE CARE ABOUT RACIAL EQUITY
AS CALIFORNIA'S POPULATION HAS
BECOME MORE AND MORE DIVERSE.
UNFORTUNATELY WHEN YOU LOOK AT
ADULTS IN OUR STATE ONLY 12% OF
LAST NEXT ADULTS HAVE A
BACHELOR'S DEGREE. THAT
COMPARES 232% OF ALL
CALIFORNIANS BUT IN THAT GRAPH
YOU CAN SEE THAT EVERYBODY
TRAILS WHITE AND ASIAN AMERICAN
STUDENTS IN OUR STATE AND THAT
SHOULD BE UNACCEPTABLE TO ALL
OF US. OF COURSE THE CSU PLAYS
A CRITICAL ROLE IN ENSURING
CALIFORNIA HAS THE EDUCATED
POPULACE THAT WE NEED AND THAT
WE MEET WORKFORCE DEMAND. BY
TWENTY THIRTY ALL OF YOU KNOW
THAT 60% OF ADULTS WILL NEED TO
HAVE SOME POST SECONDARY
EDUCATION. THAT MEANS THAT WE
NEED TO EXPAND ACCESS NOT
CONSTRAIN IT AND ESPECIALLY
NEED TO INCREASE THAT FOR BLACK
IN LATIN NEXT STUDENTS WE HAVE
FOUGHT ALONGSIDE THE CSU EVERY
YEAR WITH THEM. DURING THE
STATE BUDGET SEASON TO INCREASE
THE NUMBER OF SPOTS AVAILABLE
FOR CALIFORNIA STUDENTS AND FOR
ADDITIONAL FUNDING IN EFFORTS
LIKE THE GRADUATION INITIATIVE.
AT THE LOCAL LEVEL WE'VE WORKED
AND SUPPORTED CAMPUSES IN ORDER
TO STAVE OFF DECLARING
IMPACTION. BUT THIS PROPOSED
CHANGE TO ELIGIBILITY
REQUIREMENTS THREATENS COLLEGE
OPPORTUNITY BY MAKING CSU MORE
SELECTIVE THAN EVER BEFORE. AND
THAT UNFOUNDED SELECTIVITY
THREATENS OUR STATE. INSIDE
THREE YOU CAN SEE SOME OF THE
NEGATIVE IMPLICATIONS THAT
WE'VE OUTLINED AND WILL SPEAK
TO TODAY OF THIS PROPOSAL. IN
PARTICULAR THERE ARE FOUR MAJOR
RED FLAGS THAT WE HAVE CONCERNS.
FIRST THE CSU CONTINUES TO
RAISE THE BAR FOR ADMISSIONS
HIGHER AND HIGHER SUCH THAT IT
IS BECOMING OUT OF REACH FOR
FAR TOO MANY STUDENTS
PARTICULARLY BLACK LIGHT NEXT A
NATIVE AMERICAN ONES. EVERY
TIME OUR STUDENTS REACH THE NEW
ADMISSION BAR THE CSU SETS. THE
MOVE IT OUT FURTHER THAT IS
WHAT THIS PROPOSAL WOULD DO.
THE MOVING OF THE BAR IS
DIRECTLY TIED TO MANAGING
ENROLLMENT AND IMPROVING
GRADUATION RATES. INCREASING
CAPACITY AND IMPROVING WHAT
HAPPENS WHEN STUDENTS ARE AT
THE CSU IS WHAT WE SHOULD BE
TALKING ABOUT NOT RAISING THE
BAR ON THE STUDENTS THAT GET IN.
SECOND THE CSU PROPOSAL IS
ESSENTIALLY AN UNFUNDED MANDATE
ON K. TWELVE. K. TWELVE DOES
NOT HAVE THE CAPACITY TO OFFER
THE CURRENT A THROUGH G.
CURRICULUM EQUITABLY. LET ALONE
A THROUGH G. PLUS ANOTHER
QUANTITATIVE REASONING COURSE.
IF THE CSU IS SERIOUS ABOUT
THIS PROPOSAL THEY SHOULD BE
WORKING TO FIRST ENSURE ALL
STUDENTS CAN COMPLETE THE
CURRENT A THROUGH G.
REQUIREMENTS. BEFORE EXPANDING
THEM AND EXACERBATING ACCESS
CHALLENGES. THIRD THIS PROPOSAL
BY CSU HAS BEEN DONE. IN A SILO
IT HAS BEEN CLOSED OFF PROCESS
FROM PUBLIC STAKEHOLDERS K.
TWELVE PARTNERS AND THE
LEGISLATURE. IT THREATENS TO
MISALIGNED COLLEGE READINESS
REQUIREMENTS FROM THE UC AS
ASSEMBLY MAN MCCARTY APTLY
POINTED OUT EARLIER. FOURTH IF
THIS PROPOSAL MOVES FORWARD
DATA SHOWS ELIGIBILITY WILL GO
DOWN FOR LET NEXT AND BLACK
STUDENTS AS WELL AS STUDENTS IN
KEY REGIONS OF THE STATE. WE
CANNOT PUT A POLICY IN PLACE
NOTING THAT IT WILL HAVE A
DISPARITY IMPACT IT IS
IRRESPONSIBLE AND UNACCEPTABLE.
IN THE NEXT SLIDE. I JUST WANT
TO SHOW YOU THAT OUR STUDENTS
ARE ALREADY MEETING HIGH
STANDARDS CHRISTOPHER COBALT
ACTUALLY POINTED THIS OUT. BY
TELLING YOU THAT THE
REQUIREMENTS WE HAD IN THE
NINETEEN SIXTIES OR NINETEEN
SEVENTIES. ARE FAR LOWER THAN
ANY REQUIREMENTS THAT WE HAVE
OF TODAY STUDENTS IN FACT
STUDENTS ENROLLING IN THE CSU
TODAY ARE MORE PREPARED THAN
EVER BEFORE. THEY DON'T JUST
MEET THE MINIMUM CRITERIA FOR
ELIGIBILITY AT TWO POINT OH IN
A THREE G. THEY FAR EXCEED IT.
THE RESULT OF IMPACTION. HAS
MEANT STUDENTS MUST MEET A MUCH
HIGHER BAR FOR ADMISSION HERE
YOU CAN SEE THE AVERAGE HIGH
SCHOOL GPA ENROLLED STUDENTS AT
FULLY IMPACTED CAMPUSES HAVE TO
MEET. BUT LOOKING ACROSS ALL
TWENTY THREE CAMPUSES THE
AVERAGE HIGH SCHOOL GPA OF
ENROLLING FRESHMAN IS NEAR A
THREE POINT FIVE. FOR A STUDENT
TODAY WHO EARNS THE MINIMUM TWO
POINT OH IN A THROUGH G. THEY
WOULD NEED AT THIRTEEN FIFTY S.
A. T. TO MEET MINIMUM
ELIGIBILITY AT THE CSU. AT
THIRTEEN FIFTY FOR THOSE OF YOU
WHO MIGHT NOT HAVE STUDENTS
THAT ARE IN HIGH SCHOOL TODAY
CAN GET YOU INTO ALMOST ANY IVY
LEAGUE IN THE COUNTRY. THE BAR
HAS ALREADY BEEN RAISED AND
STUDENTS ARE PROVING TIME AND
TIME AGAIN THAT THEY'RE
QUALIFIED. IN THE NEXT SLIDE. I
WANT TO JUST POINT OUT A FEW
MORE THINGS. 40% OF CALIFORNIA
HIGH SCHOOL STUDENTS AND
GRADUATES ARE CURRENTLY
ELIGIBLE FOR THE CSU. AND THE
STUDENTS HAVE ALREADY COMPLETED
FIVE AND A HALF YEARS OF
QUANTITATIVE REASONING COURSES
THAT'S THREE YEARS OF MATH TWO
YEARS OF A LAB SCIENCE AND HALF
A SEMESTER OF ECONOMICS. AND
LET ME BE CLEAR FIVE AND A HALF
YEARS IS JUST THE MINIMUM CSU
ESTIMATES THAT INCOME INCOMING
STUDENTS AVERAGE APPROXIMATELY
TWENTY ONE A THREE G. COURSES
WHEN SIXTEEN. ARE REQUIRED. SO
STUDENTS ARE LIKELY STUDENTS
ARE VERY LIKELY TAKING MUCH
MORE QUANTITATIVE REASONING
PRIOR TO CSU THAN JUST THE FIVE
AND A HALF YEARS. THAT MEANS
THAT DESPITE YEARS OF
PREPARATION AND QUANTITATIVE
REASONING CSU IS STILL DOING AN
INSUFFICIENT JOB AT GRADUATING
THE STUDENTS IF THEY'RE SAYING
THE REASON FOR THIS IS TO
IMPROVE THEIR GRADUATION RATES.
CS USE OWN DATA SHOWS THAT ONLY
TWENTY FOR WORK 24% OF STUDENTS
WITH AN ADDITIONAL YEAR OF
QUANTITATIVE REASONING.
GRADUATE IN FOUR YEARS. AND
ONLY SEVENTEEN AND 18% OF BLACK
AND WHITE NEXT STUDENTS. WHO'VE
TAKEN THE ADDITIONAL YEAR OF Q.
R. GRADUATE IN FOUR YEARS. THE
Q. R. PROPOSAL IS HARDLY THE
SILVER BULLET FOR IMPROVED
GRADUATION AT THE CSU. INSTEAD
IT WILL BE ANOTHER EXAMPLE OF
USING MATH AS A FILTER TO KEEP
STUDENTS OUT. ON THE NEXT SLIDE
I WANT TO TALK ABOUT. TEACHERS
AND QUALITY AND THE NUMBER OF
QUALIFIED TEACHERS BECAUSE I
KNOW THAT'S A CONCERN. THAT
MANY OF US SHARE. SO INSIDE SIX
YOU CAN SEE THAT IN ADDED
INEQUITIES IN A THREE G. ACCESS
ALREADY EXIST AT OUR SCHOOLS.
ESPECIALLY SCHOOLS THAT ARE
UNDER RESOURCE RACIALLY
STRATIFIED AND OVERWHELMINGLY
LOW INCOME. ARGUMENTS ABOUT A
LACK OF CAPACITY QUALIFIED
TEACHERS AND GREATER INVESTMENT
TO ADD AN ADDITIONAL YEAR OF Q.
R. EQUITABLY HAS FALLEN ON DEAF
EARS AT THE CSU. STUDENTS
HAILING FROM LOW INCOME AREAS
ARE MORE LIKELY TO HAVE
UNQUALIFIED TEACHERS IN MATH
AND SCIENCE THAN STUDENTS IN
HIGHER INCOME AREAS. THERE'S
PLENTY OF DATA ANDRESEARCH ON
THAT COURSE AVAILABILITY AT A
CAMPUS WHICH IS YOU KNOW AN
ASSESSMENT THAT CSU HAS DONE
ARGUING THAT THESE COURSES ARE
ALREADY AVAILABLE AT MOST
CAMPUSES. DOESN'T MEAN EVERY
KID GETS A SEAT. IN FACT I'LL
SHOW YOU A SLIDE ON A THREE G.
COMPLETION BY RACE IN THE NEXT.
HAND OUT YOU CAN SEE THAT MORE
THAN 60% OF BLACK AND WHITE
NEXT HIGH SCHOOL GRADUATES ARE
ALREADY IN ELIGIBLE FOR THE COW
STATE UNIVERSITY SYSTEM. THAT
IS TODAY'S ENVIRONMENT. THE
NEXT SLIDE YOU CAN SEE A
THROUGH G. COMPLETION BY REGION
AND THAT VARIES TO WITH SAN
FRANCISCO BAY AREA HAVING THE
HIGHEST BEST A THREE G.
COMPLETION RATE FOR THEIR
STUDENTS AND THE CENTRAL VALLEY
IN INLAND EMPIRE AND THE NORTH
COAST HAVING SOME OF THE WORST.
THIS IS WHY SEVERAL PROMINENT
SCHOOL DISTRICTS HAVE EXPRESSED
THEIR OPPOSITION TO THIS EFFORT.
YOU HAVE A LIST OF FOLKS
OPPOSED INCLUDING LA UNIFIED
ANAHEIM SAN FRANCISCO UNIFIED
SACRAMENTO UNIFIED SANTA ANA
UNIFIED. THEY REPRESENT ALMOST
14% OR SIX POINT ONE MILLION OF
ALL K. TWELVE STUDENTS IN
CALIFORNIA AND THEY'RE OPPOSED
TO THIS POLICY TO. IN THE NEXT
SLIDE I WANT TO SHOW YOU A
THROUGH G. COMPLETION BY INCOME.
SO THAT WE CAN JUST BE CLEAR IN
ON THE SAME PAGE THAT
ESSENTIALLY. IF YOU'RE HIGHER
INCOME STUDENT YOU'RE MUCH MORE
LIKELY TO COMPLETE THE A THREE
G. WE HAVE YET TO SEE EVIDENCE
FROM THE C. S. USED TO
SUBSTANTIATE THEIR CLAIM THAT
THIS PROPOSED CHANGE WOULD NOT
HAVE DESPAIRED IMPACT ON
STUDENTS SEEKING ACCESS TO THE
CSU. NO ELIGIBILITY STUDY HAS
BEEN DONE SO TOGETHER WITH OUR
COLLEAGUES AT JUST EQUATIONS
AND AT TRUSTS WEST WE
COMMISSIONED RTI INTERNATIONAL
THE FIRM THAT COMPLETED THE
STATE'S LAST ELIGIBILITY STUDY
TO EXAMINE HOW INCREASING
REQUIREMENTS WITH AN ADDITIONAL
YEAR OF MATHEMATICS OR SCIENCE
WOULD IMPACT ELIGIBILITY RATES.
USING DATA FROM THE HIGH SCHOOL
GRADUATING CLASS OF TWENTY
FIFTEEN THESE REQUIREMENTS
WOULD HAVE REDUCED ELIGIBILITY
FROM FORTY ONE TO THIRTY FOUR
PERCENT. THIS CHANGE WOULD
RENDER NEARLY 80% OF BLACK HIGH
SCHOOL GRADS INELIGIBLE FOR THE
CSU. IN THE NEXT SLIDE ON SLIDE
ELEVEN. WE WANT TO SHOW YOU THE
EFFECT THAT ARE TI MODELED BY
REGION AND YOU CAN SEE THAT IN
GROWING REGIONS LIKE THE
CENTRAL VALLEY ELIGIBILITY
RATES WOULD GO FROM 34% 227% TO
BE CLEAR WE WOULD LOSE AS MANY
AS ONE FIFTH OF OUR PREVIOUSLY
ELIGIBLE STUDENTS FROM THE
CENTRAL VALLEY. INSIDE TWELVE
YOU CAN SEE THE IMPACT ON BLACK
STUDENTS NEARLY A QUARTER OF
BLACK STUDENTS PREVIOUSLY
ELIGIBLE WOULD NO LONGER BE
ELIGIBLE UNDER THE NEW CRITERIA.
AN IN FLIGHT THIRTEEN YOU CAN
SEE THE IMPACT FOR LIGHT NEXT
STUDENTS. THE NUMBER OF LACKEY
LET NEXT STUDENTS WHO ARE CSU
ELIGIBLE WOULD DROP BY ABOUT
20% THAT'S OVER FIVE THOUSAND
LET NEXT STUDENTS EVERY YEAR.
PP I SEE RECENTLY PUBLISHED A
PIECE ABOUT THE POTENTIAL
CHANGING QUANTITATIVE REASONING
REQUIREMENTS EMPHASIZING THAT
IT WOULD ONLY CAUSE MORE
CONFUSION FOR STUDENTS AND SOME
STUDENTS. WHO QUALIFY FOR THE
UC MAY NOT QUALIFY FOR THE CSU.
THE CSU CLAIMS THAT IF WE USE
IF THE UC ADDS AN ADDITIONAL
YEAR SCIENCE TO ITS ADMISSIONS
REQUIREMENTS THERE WOULD BE
OVERLAP FOR STUDENTS WHO WOULD
WANT TO APPLY TO THE TWO
SYSTEMS. BUT YOU SEE IS STILL
CONDUCTING A RIGOROUS
INDEPENDENT STUDY ON THE
IMPACTS OF SUCH A CHANGE AND
THE CHANGE HAS NOT BEEN
APPROVED AND MAY NOT EVEN OCCUR.
SO HOW CAN WE MOVE FORWARD. YOU
HAVE IN FRONT OF YOU A LIST OF
OVER SEVENTY CIVIL RIGHTS
COMMUNITY LABOR AND STUDENT
ORGANIZATIONS OPPOSED TO THIS
PROPOSAL. THAT INCLUDES THE
CALIFORNIA TEACHERS ASSOCIATION
THE CALIFORNIA FACULTIES
ASSOCIATION. MALL DEATH THE LA
URBAN LEAGUE LA U. S. D. SAN
FRANCISCO UST. THE STUDENT BODY
PRESIDENTS OF CAL STATE LA.
CALLE POMONA. CHANNEL ISLANDS
AND DOMINGUEZ HILLS THE
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL BOARDS
ASSOCIATION. THE ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
ADMINISTRATORS THE EQUAL
JUSTICE SOCIETY. THE ACLU OF
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA THE END
DOUBLE DOUBLE ACP OF POMONA
VALLEY ASIAN AMERICANS
ADVANCING JUSTICE WE NEED THOSE
U. S. MOSHE AND THE LOTUS WORK
THAT FOUNDATION. AND JUST
YESTERDAY. THE CALIFORNIA STATE
STUDENT ASSOCIATION. THIS
COALITION IS GRAVELY CONCERNED
ABOUT THE ISSUES I'VE JUST
RAISED AND WE'RE LOOKING AT YOU
TO EXERCISE YOUR LEADERSHIP AND
OVERSIGHT. HERE'S WHAT WE ASK.
URGE YOU. TO URGE THE CSU
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE AND THE CSU
TRUSTEES TO PAUSE THERE'S TOO
MUCH UNCERTAINTY UNCERTAINTY
AND LACK OF AUTHENTIC
COLLABORATION FOR THIS TO MOVE
FORWARD. SECOND THIS.
SIGNIFICANT BACKLASH THIS
PROPOSAL IS RECEIVING A
SYMPTOMATIC OF A LARGER ISSUE
FACING CALIFORNIA AND THAT IS
THE LACK OF A COORDINATING
ENTITY FOR HIGHER EDUCATION WE
PROUDLY SUPPORTED THE
LEGISLATURE'S EFFORT TO
ESTABLISH A COORDINATING AND TO
TV AB ONE THIRTY WHICH WAS
RECENTLY VETOED BY THE GOVERNOR
HOWEVER IT IS THIS TYPE OF
ENTITY THAT IS BOTH INDEPENDENT
OF THE SYSTEMS BUT HAS THE
AUTHORITY TO REQUIRE THE
SYSTEMS TO ALIGN WITH EACH
OTHER TO WORK TOGETHER WITH K.
TWELVE FOR THE BENEFIT OF OUR
STATE THAT WE NEED TO REVIEW
WHAT IS COLLEGE READINESS. IN
RELATION TO OUR DEMANDS WHAT
MAKES SENSE IN TERMS OF FUNDING
FOR THE STATE. WE URGE YOU TO
APPOINT A TASK FORCE THAT CAN
ASSESS COLLEGE READINESS ACROSS
THE STATE AND CONDUCT AN IMPACT
STUDY TO ASSESS THESE
ELIGIBILITY. CHANGES ONE THAT
IS INDEPENDENT AND TRANSPARENT
FROM EACH OF THE SEGMENTS. WE.
THE CSU MUST FOSTER GREATER K.
TWELVE COLLABORATION. K. TWELVE
COLLABORATION HAS BEEN AN
AFTERTHOUGHT WITH K. TWELVE
ONLY BEING BROUGHT IN WITHIN
THE LAST SEVERAL MONTHS FOR
PROPOSAL THAT HAS HUGE
IMPLICATIONS FOR THE SYSTEM
THAT IS UNACCEPTABLE AND ONCE
AGAIN IT RESPONSIBLE. THE CSU
SHOULDN'T KICK THE CAN TO K.
TWELVE TO IMPROVE THEIR
GRADUATE GRADUATION RATES.
THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT THIS
PROPOSAL WILL DO. FINALLY ANY
CHANGES THAT EVENTUALLY OCCUR
WITHIN ADMISSIONS MUST BE
RIGOROUSLY MONITORED BY THE
LEGISLATURE WE URGE THE
LEGISLATURE TO SET THE STANDARD
BY WHICH CSU REPORTS ON ITS
PROGRESS OF ANY ADMISSION
CHANGES SUCH THAT THE OUTCOMES
ARE TRANSPARENT AND REGULAR AND
SUCH THAT WE INSURE THAT THERE
ISN'T TO SPIRIT IMPACT. WE
CONTINUE TO STAND WITH THE CSU
THERE'S NO QUESTION ABOUT
WHETHER OR NOT THE CSU NEEDS
MORE ADEQUATE FUNDING TO EXPAND
CAPACITY THEY DO AND WE URGE
YOU TO PROVIDE IT. WE ARE
TURNING AWAY TOO MANY ELIGIBLE
STUDENTS AT A TIME WHEN OUR
ECONOMY IS DEMANDING A MORE
EDUCATED POPULACE. WE STAND
WITH THE CSU AND ENSURING
FUNDING FOR THE GRADUATION
INITIATIVE AND EFFORTS LIKE
REMOVING THE REMEDIAL EDUCATION
BARRIER POLICIES THAT LOOK AT
HOW CS USE OWN INTERNAL
POLICIES AND PRACTICES ARE
HINDERING STUDENT SUCCESS. BUT
I WANT TO BE VERY CLEAR WE
STAND FOR STUDENTS FIRST AND
THIS PROPOSAL DOES NOT PUT THEM
FIRST. I WANT TO JUST CLOSE BY
SHARING A FEW THINGS IN
RESPONSE TO PREVIOUS PANELIST
AND REMARKS THIS IS ABOUT
MANAGING ENROLLMENT. IT IS
ABSOLUTELY GOING TO BE AN
OUTCOME OF A NEW ADMISSIONS
REQUIREMENTS IT IS RATIONING
AND SORTING THAT'S WHAT IT DOES.
IT IS AS CSU DECLARES ABOUT
STUDENT SUCCESS. BUT IT FOCUSES
ON THE K. TWELVE SYSTEM AND
WHAT THEY SHOULD BE DOING AND
WHAT STUDENTS THE CS. I OFTEN
SAY THAT IT WOULD BE A MUCH
MORE HELPFUL CONVERSATION FOR
COLLEGES TO STOP TALKING ABOUT
STUDENTS BEING COLLEGE READY
AND FOR THEM TO LOOK IN THE
MIRROR AND ASK THEMSELVES ARE
THEY STUDENT READY. I URGE YOU
TO JOIN CIVIL RIGHTS AND
EDUCATION LEADERS ACROSS THE
STATE TO EXPRESS YOUR STRONG
CONCERN TO THIS PROPOSAL. I
ALSO WANT TO ADD IT'S ONLY BEEN
TWO YEARS SINCE EXECUTIVE ORDER
ELEVEN HUNDRED AND ELEVEN TEN
WERE BROUGHT FORWARD BY THE
CSU. BUT APPARENTLY MEMORIES
ARE SHORT. THE CAMPAIGN FOR
COLLEGE OPPORTUNITY CIVIL
RIGHTS LEADERS EDUCATION
LEADERS ACROSS THE STATE. MUCH
SUPPORTED THAT PROPOSAL IN FACT
WE WERE CHAMPIONING IT WITH THE
MEDIA AND THE PUBLIC BECAUSE IT
WAS THE RIGHT THING TO DO BY
STUDENTS. IT WAS A GOOD POLICY
FOR STUDENTS OF COLOR. SO I
TAKE A LITTLE BIT OF ON BRIDGE
AT SAYING THAT FOLKS ARE AFRAID
OF CHANGE. WE'RE NOT AFRAID OF
CHANGE. NEITHER ARE OUR
STUDENTS IN FACT THEY KEEP
MEETING THE BAR EVERY TIME YOU
RAISE IT. WE HAVE FOUGHT FOR
CHANGE. EVERY YEAR FOR OUR
STUDENTS. SO THAT GRADUATION
AND ACCESS TO COLLEGE WOULD BE
POSSIBLE SO THAT GETTING THAT
DEGREE AND WALKING ACROSS THE
STAGE WOULDN'T JUST BE AN
ILLUSION. BUT THIS POLICY
PROPOSAL THIS PROPOSED CHANGE
DOES NOT MEET THE ONLY BAR THAT
MATTERS IT IS NOT GOOD FOR
STUDENTS AND IT IS NOT GOOD FOR
EQUITY IN CALIFORNIA SO I HOPE
YOU EXPRESS YOUR STRONG
CONCERNS TO THE CAL STATE
UNIVERSITY SYSTEM. THANK YOU. I
MISTER CHAIRMAN MISTER CHAIRMAN
OF THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY. TO BE HERE BOB I
HAVE ABOUT I THINK I HAVE FIVE
POINTS TO MAKE AND I TRY TO DO
IT QUICKLY SINCE I. YIELDED
SOME OF MY TIME TO MICHELLE. I.
I BUT I WANT TO START BY SAYING
GIVING YOU A LITTLE BIT OF MY
BIOGRAPHY SO. SIR YOU MAY FEEL
THAT I'M WORTH LISTENING TO.
I'M. I'VE ONLY BEEN IN
CALIFORNIA FIFTEEN YEARS. I AM
A PROFESSOR AND FORMER DEAN AT
UC BERKELEY LAW SCHOOL BUT
BEFORE THAT I TAUGHT AS A LAW
PROFESSOR AT HARVARD FOR TWENTY
THREE YEARS. UP BOTH AT HARVARD
AND IN MY NON DEAN YEARS AT
BERKELEY UP MY PRINCIPAL AREAS
OF RESEARCH AND TEACHING HAVE
BEEN ADMINISTRATIVE LAW AND
EDUCATION POLICY. I'VE ALSO
WORKED ON EDUCATION POLICY IN
THE I HAD JOBS TOUCHING OR
INVOLVED IN EDUCATION POLICY.
IN THE CARTER WHITE HOUSE WHEN
I WAS TWELVE. I IN THE CLINTON
WHITE HOUSE. IN FIVE
PRESIDENTIAL CAMPAIGNS AND TO
PRESIDENTIAL TRANSITIONS. I. MY
PERSPECTIVE IS LARGELY NATIONAL
BUT I'VE LEARNED QUITE A BIT
ABOUT CALIFORNIA IN THE LAST.
THE LAST COUPLE OF YEARS. UP
AND FINALLY UP MY FAVORITE
HOBBY IS CHAIRING WERE
PARTICIPATING IN COMMITTEES OF
THE NATIONAL OF THE NATIONAL
ACADEMIES OF SCIENCE. AND THREE
RELEVANT COMMITTEES THAT I
CHAIRED IN RECENT YEARS OP
WHICH ARE COMPOSED OF LEADING.
THREE THAT I HANDLED THAT ARE
RELEVANT HERE AB. IS FIRST A
PANEL ON SETTING ADULT LITERACY
STANDARDS. WHAT'S. PROFICIENT
WHAT'S ADEQUATE BUT CENTER
SECOND A COMMITTEE ON SETTING
PERFORMANCE STANDARDS FOR NATE
THE NATIONAL ASSESSMENT OF
EDUCATION PROGRESS HOW SHOULD
ONE DECIDE WHAT IS BASIC WHAT
IS PROFICIENT. ARE AT CENTER.
AND FINALLY I JUST FINISHED
SHARING. A COMMITTEE THAT WAS
CHARGED WITH DESIGNING A
NATIONAL SYSTEM OF INDICATORS
FOR EDUCATION EQUITY IN K.
TWELVE. ALL RIGHT THAT'S ME. I.
I WAS GOING TO TALK ABOUT THE
POLITICAL WITH THE POLITICAL
FORCES LINED UP BUT I THINK
MICHELLE READ YOU A VERY
IMPRESSIVE LIST OF WHO HAS
WEIGHED IN ON IT I'D VENTURE TO
SAY THAT ALMOST ALL OF THE
ORGANIZATIONS ON HER LIST KNOW
MORE ABOUT HIGH SCHOOLS. AND K.
TWELVE CURRICULUM. THEN THE
ACADEMIC SENATE OF CSU. SECOND.
WHATEVER CSU DECIDES TO DO. IT
IS A BUILDING ON THE EXISTING
SYSTEM AND THE INEQUITIES THAT
ARE ALREADY BAKED INTO THE
EXISTING SYSTEM. MOST
IMPORTANTLY FOR OUR PURPOSES
THE CAPACITY ISSUES AND MOST
IMPORTANT ABOUT CAPACITY
TEACHERS. EFFECTIVE QUALIFIED
TEACHERS. WE KNOW. THAT SCHOOLS
THAT HAVE HIGHER MINORITY
ENROLLMENTS HIGHER ENROLLMENTS
OF POOR CHILDREN. ARE MORE
LIKELY TO HAVE HAVE TEACHER
SHORTAGES IN STEM AND MATH. 80%
OF SCHOOL DISTRICTS 80% OF
SCHOOL DISTRICT CURRENTLY
REPORTS THAT THEY HAVE TEACHER
SHORTAGES. STEM AND SPECIAL ED
ARE THE MAJOR CHALLENGES. THE
EXISTENCE OF A COURSE IN A HIGH
SCHOOL. DOES NOT MEAN THAT.
EVERYBODY WHO WANTS TO TAKE IT
WILL BE ABLETO TAKE. AND THAT
IS A CRITICAL POINT. I YOU
CAN'T JUST LOOK AT THE COURSE
CATALOG AND ASSUME THAT. IT
MEANS GENUINE ACCESS ODD TO.
FOUR YEARS OF MATH AND
QUANTITATIVE REASONING. BOB
NUMBER THREE. THE CORE
CONCEPTUAL ISSUE HERE IS TO ME
I WHO SHOULD BE MAKING THE
POLICY ABOUT WHAT. THE ACADEMIC
RESPONSIBILITY IS FOR
CALIFORNIA'S PUBLIC HIGH
SCHOOLS. THIS IS NOT THE
NINETEEN TWENTIES WHEN A
THROUGH F. WAS ADOPTED BY STE
BY CSU AND IT'S CERTAINLY NOT
THE LATE NINETEENTH CENTURY. IN
FACT IT'S NOT EVEN NINETEEN
SIXTIES SINCE THE MASTER PLAN.
THE STATE HAS ESTABLISHED NOT
ONLY A DIFFERENT SET OF
GOVERNANCE MECHANISMS FOR K.
TWELVE BUT A COMPLETELY
DIFFERENT FINANCING STRUCTURE
MORE STATE MONEY THAN THERE WAS
BEFORE THE MASTER PLAN OPS MORE
STATE ACCOUNTABILITY FOR K.
TWELVE THAN THERE USED TO BE. I
AND MUCH MORE. SO I THINK THAT
THE TRADITION OF HAVING THE
FACULTIES OF CSU AND YOU SEE.
STEER THE HIGH SCHOOL
CURRICULUM BOAT. IS OUTDATED.
THIS SHOULD BE ABOUT X.
EXPERTISE. AND IT SHOULD BE
ABOUT LEGITIMACY. BUT THE
DEEPER PROBLEM EVEN TO THAT. IS
WHETHER YOU BELIEVE AS POLICY
MAKERS THAT PUBLIC HIGH SCHOOLS
SHOULD BE ALIGNED WITH PUBLIC.
COLLEGES AND UNIVERSITIES. I IT
TOO TWO OF THE PREVIOUS
SPEAKERS HAVE SAID THAT CSU
TAKES IT BELIEVES ITS
RESPONSIBILITY IS TO MEET
STUDENTS WHERE THEY ARE. WELL
WHERE THEY ARE. IS NOT FOUR
YEARS OF MATH A QUANTITATIVE
REASONING. THE BATTLE NOW IS
OVER WHETHER IT'S THE
RESPONSIBILITY OF UNDER FUNDED
HIGH SCHOOLS. BY THAT EXTRA
PREPARATION. FOUR TWO FOUR TO
REQUIRE THAT ARE COLLEGES ARE
UNDER FUNDED COLLEGES. PROVIDE
FOR THAT EXTRA PREPARATION. I
ALSO WANT TO REMIND YOU THAT
WHAT AN ACADEMIC SET ACADEMIC.
SENATE SAYS ABOUT. REQUIREMENTS
AND GRADUATION REQUIREMENTS. IS
RARELY IF EVER BASED ON
EVIDENCE IT'S MOSTLY BASED AND
I SAY THIS AS A LONG TIME
ACADEMIC IT'S MOSTLY BASED ON
FACULTY POLITICS. AND IT'S
BASED ON. SOCIAL CONSTRUCTS.
FOR WHICH THERE ARE NO EXTERNAL
VALIDITY CHECKS. GREEK AND
LATIN. WORK IN PART. A SENSE OF
COLLEGE PROFESSORS OF WHAT IT
MEANS TO BE EDUCATED. THERE'S
NO EVIDENCE ABOUT THEIR UTILITY
THERE'S NO EVIDENCE ABOUT HOW
IT WOULD PREDICT SUCCESS IN
COLLEGE. SIMILARLY I THINK WHAT
WE'RE SAYING HERE IS THAT TO
PROMOTE COLLEGE SUCCESS. MORE
MAPS. MORE MATH WHY NOT MORE
WRITING. I. MORE WRITING WOULD
BE MORE USEFUL IN THE REAL
WORLD. THERE IS NO EXTERNAL
VALIDITY STUDY BE OFFERED BY CS
YOU AS TO WHY ADDITIONAL MATH
AND QUANTITATIVE REASONING OUR
REPORT. TO SAY THAT THEY ARE
CORRELATED WITH HIGHER
COMPLETION RATES AND HIGHER
PERSISTENCE IN HIGHER
EDUCATION. IS TO ME RATHER FAIR
NONSENSICAL. IT'S THERE IS NO
THEORY THAT MAKES IT A CAUSAL
CONNECTION IT'S ONLY A
CORRELATION MOREOVER. IT MAY
NOT BE THE BEST CORRELATION IT
MAY NOT BE THE BEST PREDICTOR
OF IMPROVED. POST SECONDARY
OUTCOMES. I AS COMPARED WITH
FOR EXAMPLE GPA OR SCORES ON
THE SMARTER BALANCED ASSESSMENT.
FOR IF I CAN BE IRONIC FAMILY
INCOME. THAT'S THE PROBLEM WITH
LOOKING AT EXPOSURE TO MATH WE
KNOW THAT THE AVAILABILITY OF
QUALITY MATH IS CORRELATED WITH
SOCIAL WITH WITH POVERTY AND
WITH THE RACE. IF YOU PUT MORE
EMPHASIS ON THE ROLE OF MATH
PREPARATION. THEN YOU'RE
PUTTING MORE EMPHASIS ON
WHITENESS. AND HI INCOME. I
THINK THAT'S AN EQUITY ISSUE.
AND I DON'T THINK THE CSU
FACULTY. IS THE SOURCE OF.
DECISION MAKING ON. HOW MUCH
INEQUITY IS TOO MUCH I THINK
PEOPLE LIKE YOU ARE. A WORD
ABOUT THE LEGAL FRAMEWORK FOR
THIS. BOB. THE END OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE CONSTITUTION'S
EQUAL PROTECTION CLAUSE. A
DISPARATE IMPACT OF A POLICY
MAKES IT A CRIME OFFICIALLY
CASE FOR VIOLATION OF EQUAL
PROTECTION. I BELIEVE THE
EVIDENCE IS PRETTY CLEAR THAT
THERE WILL BE A DISPARATE
RACIAL IMPACT FROM ADOPTING
THIS AS THINGS CURRENTLY STAY
AT GIVEN WHAT WE KNOW RIGHT NOW
ABOUT WHO'S TAKING THESE
COURSES WHO HAS ACCESS TO THIS
COURSE. IF THAT IS TRUE THEN WE
HAVE TO ASK WHETHER THERE IS
WHAT STATE YOU HAVE TO
ESTABLISH. WE'LL HAVE TO
ESTABLISH BECAUSE I BELIEVE IF
THEY ADOPT THIS POLICY IT WILL
VERY QUICKLY UP BE LITIGATED.
BY CIVIL RIGHTS ATTORNEYS. CS
YOU WILL HAVE THE BURDEN OF
SHOWING THAT THEY HAVE A
COMPELLING INTEREST. AT THAT
THERE IS NO ALTERNATIVE POLICY
THAT THEY COULD ADOPT. THAT.
WOULD SERVE THAT INTEREST WITH
LESS. DISPARATE IMPACT. BUT WE
KNOW THE GPA AT THE RESEARCH
SHOWS US THAT BOTH GPA AND THE
SMARTER BALANCED ASSESSMENT ARE
VERY GOOD PREDICTORS OF
POSTSECONDARY SUCCESS I SO
FOCUSING ON. YEARS OF MATH. IS
PROBLEMATIC FROM THE
PERSPECTIVE OF CIVIL RIGHTS LAW.
POLITICS IT HAS BEEN SUGGESTED
THAT POLITICS SHOULD NOT PLAY A
PART IN DECISIONS OF THIS SORT.
OP FRANKLY AS SOMEONE WHO
TEACHES AT THE INTERSECTION OF
RULE OF LAW AND POLITICS. I
FIND THAT A LITTLE NONSENSICAL.
IF. POLITICS MEANS THAT ELECTED
OFFICIALS HAVE A VOICE. THEN
YOU'RE SAYING. DEMOCRACY ISN'T
SUCH A GOOD IDEA. FOR MAKING
DECISIONS ABOUT THE POWER
DYNAMICS IN EDUCATION POLICY.
OR DECISIONS ABOUT EQUITY.
THERE MUST BE POLITICS. BUT I
DON'T THINK IT SHOULD BE THE
POLITICS OF AN ACADEMIC SENATE
THAT'S DRIVING CHOICES OF SENSE
OF THIS SORT I THINK THE
LEGISLATURE SHOULD WEIGH IN AT
A MINIMUM BUT YOU SHOULD WEIGH
IN INFORMALLY. BUT YOU SHOULD
ALSO CONSIDER. THAT THE CIVIL
RIGHTS PERSPECTIVE THE EQUITY
PERSPECTIVE. IS ABSOLUTELY YOUR
RESPONSIBILITY ABSOLUTELY YOUR
RESPONSIBILITY BECAUSE THE
STATE CONSTITUTION. MAKES THAT
AN OBLIGATION OF THE STATE
GOVERNMENT. DIRECTLY. FINALLY
LET ME JUST SAY THAT I LOVE
MATH. I THINK THAT MATH IS. THE
BEST EVIDENCE FOR THE EXISTENCE
OF GOD OR SOMETHING. I WAS THE
UNDERGRADUATE MAJOR IN
MATHEMATICS AND BRIEFLY
CONSIDERED BEING A
MATHEMATICIAN. IF I COULD MAKE
THE CHOICE PEOPLE WOULD HAVE.
TEN OR ELEVEN MATH COURSES IN
HIGH SCHOOL. JUST BECAUSE IT'S
SO BEAUTIFUL. BUT IT'S NOT MY
CHOICE I. BUT YOU SHOULD BE
INVOLVED IN THE CHOICE. THE
IDEA OF A WAIVER FOR AN
EXEMPTION. FOR SCHOOLS AND
STUDENTS THAT DON'T. MAKE THE
Q. R. COURSE READILY AVAILABLE.
I. IS OKAY IF YOU FIRST
DEMONSTRATED THAT THIS FOURTH
YEAR IS THE BEST WAY TO ACHIEVE
CS USE. OBJECTIVES OF IMPROVING
IMPROVING ACADEMIC OUTCOMES.
BUT EVEN IF IT IS THE BEST WAY.
EVEN IF IT IS THE BEST WAY. THE
EXEMPTION THAT CSU IS
CONSIDERING. FIRST OF ALL HAS
NOT BEEN DEFINED SO WE KNOW
WHAT IT REALLY IS WHAT THE
STANDARD WOULD BE. SECONDLY
IT'S NOT IN THE FORMAL
PROPOSAL. FOR WHAT WILL BE THE
CHANGE IN THE REGULATIONS. IT'S
MENTIONED IN STAFF MEMOS. AND
THIRD IF THERE'S GOING TO BE AN
EXEMPTION. IT SHOULD BE C. D.
E. THAT DECIDES THAT MAKES THE
JUDGMENT AS TO WHETHER OR NOT
COURSE AVAILABILITY IN HIGH
SCHOOLS. IS SATISFACTORY. LET
ME STOP THERE I HAVE SOME IDEAS
ABOUT WHAT THE COMMITTEE MIGHT
DO I AND PERHAPS THE BE A
CHANCE FOR ME TO. TALK ABOUT
THOSE IN THE QUEUE IN A. THIS
MCCARTY QUESTIONS COMMENTS
THANK YOU. WELL FIRST THE SOUL
MATH CHOICE I'M I'M JUST BLOWN
AWAY BY THAT AND I WANT TO GET
SIDETRACKED HERE BUT I'M
LOOKING AT THE CSU SHEET HERE
AND BELIEVE IT OR NOT. MY
PERSONAL EXPERIENCE. I ONLY
WENT UP TO PRE ALGEBRA IN HIGH
SCHOOL. AND YOU GOT NO WHERE
AND I'M- WE'RE OBVIOUSLY BUT
DON'T TELL ANYBODY BUT I RIGHT
SHARE HALF OF THE BUDGET FOR
THE CALIFORNIA THAT EXPLAINS A
LOT ABOUT THE BUDGET BUT I'M
REALLY GOOD AT DOING ON THE FLY
MATHEMATICS WITH MY BASEBALL
BATTING AVERAGE AND STUFF LIKE
THAT. BUT IT DOES WORK OUT FOR
SOME PEOPLE YOU KNOW THAT I WAS
GETTING THAT THAT THIS IS A BIG
ISSUE AND- YOU KNOW. THAT THAT
WAS AN ALLY OF COURSE AND THE
REALITY OF STUDENTS TODAY'S IS
MUCH MUCH DIFFERENT BUT- THEY
WOULD JUST ASK YOU JUST BIG
QUESTION. BIG PICTURE QUESTION
WHY DO YOU THINK. CSU IS
PROPOSING THIS INTERVIEW. I
ASSUME THAT YOU DON'T THINK
THEY'RE BAD PEOPLE. AND THAT
THERE HAVE ILL INTENTIONS OF
HARMING. THE NEXT GENERATION OF
COLLEGE STUDENTS SO WHY DO YOU
THINK THEY- AND THEIR ACADEMIC
SENATE. IN THIS POLICY. WELL
IT'S OBVIOUSLY A COMBINATION OF
REASONS AND A COMBINATION OF
MOTIVES AT AT WORK. I'M UP
SOMETHING THAT'S KIND OF A
SENTIMENT THAT'S VERY FAMILIAR
FOR ACADEMICS FOR FACULTY IS. I
CAN I CAN HAVE MUCH BETTER
STUDENT OUTCOMES IF YOU JUST
GIVE ME BETTER STUDENTS CLEAR.
SO. THAT'S PART OF WHAT'S
DRIVING THEIR THEIR JUDGMENT.
OUR AND IT'S NOT MY
RESPONSIBILITY AS YOUR UNIVERSE
TIRED OF DOING REMEDIATION AND
DEVELOPMENT THAT'S RIGHT OR
CREATING OTHER COURSES. NOT TO
MENTION JUST THE QUESTION OF.
WHO ACTUALLY SHOULD CARRY THE
BURDEN OF DOING THESE THINGS
WHICH EACH THINGS IN HIGH
SCHOOL NOW THAT USED TO BE
TAUGHT THE COLLEGE. BECAUSE WE
MADE A JUDGMENT THAT WAS OKAY.
FOR COLLEGES TO SHED THAT
RESPONSIBILITY IF GIVEN THE
HIGH SCHOOLS. THAT'S ALSO PART
OF WHAT THEY'RE DOING THEY'RE
MAKING CLEAR THAT THAT
ADDITIONAL EXPOSURE TO
QUANTITATIVE REASONING OR MATH.
HAVE TO COME FROM HIGH SCHOOLS
RATHER THAN FROM THE COLLEGES
AND UNIVERSITIES. I KNOW WHERE
IS IT WRITTEN IN STONE. WHAT
THE ENTRY LEVEL CREDIT COURSE
NEEDS TO BE. I'M. THE THIRD BIG
THING ABOUT THEIR WHAT THEY'RE
DOING I THINK IS THAT THEY'RE
TAKING A SIMPLE CORRELATION.
NGUYEN EXPOSURE TO MATH. AND
STUDENT OUTCOMES. REALLY FOR
PEOPLE MAJOR IN ENGLISH. FOR
PEOPLE WHO MAJOR IN HISTORY. IF
THERE IS A CORRELATION FACT
SIMPLY PROVES. THAT MATH TAKING
IS RELATED TO OTHER KINDS OF
ACADEMIC PREPARATION AND
ACADEMIC ACHIEVEMENT AND THOSE
OF THE REAL THINGS THAT ARE
DRIVING. THE SUCCESS RATES
ASSOCIATED WITH MATH
PREPARATION. YOU WITH ME AS I
SAID BEFORE. MAP CORPORATION
FIGHT BUT INCOME AND RACE AND
GEOGRAPHY OUR FOR MORE FAR MORE
POWERFUL DRIVERS. I'M. FULL
STOP OKAY DID YOU EVER AS FOR
THE CLASS OF FOLLOW UPS BUT
YEAH I A YEAR I MEAN I AGREE I
WOULD JUST ADD THAT I THINK IF
THE LEGISLATURE FUNDED ANOTHER
FIFTY THOUSAND SPOTS IN THE CAL
STATE UNIVERSITY SYSTEM I DOUBT
WE WOULD BE HERE TESTIFYING IN
FRONT OF YOU AROUND AN
ADMISSIONS PROPOSAL THAT'S
CLEARLY GOING TO LEAVE STUDENTS
OUT. BUT THAT ANSWER LEADS ME
TO MY NEXT QUESTION FOR BOTH OF
YOU IS THAT. BUT THAT WAS THE
CASE YOU WOULD YOU COULD SAY
THAT MAYBE THE STUDENTS WOULD
ALSO HAVE CHALLENGES WITH
REMEDIATION. AND STEPPING UP
NOT BEING ILL PREPARED TO. TAKE
THE COURSES ARE THERE IN
FRESHMAN WHICH LEADS TO THREE
OR FOUR. INCOMES THAT THREE OR
FOUR FOR SIX YEARS AS FAR AS
THE FOUR YEAR GRADUATION RATE
AND- YOU KNOW STUDENTS THERE'S
THIS THERE'S A SEVERE
CONSEQUENCE NOT TALK TO PRESENT
ALSO ALSO TIME HE TELLS HIS
INCOMING FRESHMEN THEIR
FAMILIES. WHO WANTS A CHECK FOR
TWENTY THOUSAND DOLLARS. ALMOST
FAMILIES RAISE THEIR HAND OKAY
WELL TO CHOICE IS EASY. YOU
TAKE FIFTEEN UNITS A SEMESTER
AND NOT TWELVE LIKE YOUR-
FINANCIAL AID CAL GRANT ADVISER
TELLS YOU DO. YOU WILL GETA
CHECK FOR TWENTY EIGHT THOUSAND
DOLLARS ARE CONVERSING OFF TO
PAY THAT CHECK IN YOUR FAMILY
YEAR WITH. TUITION HOUSING
COSTS AND THAT'S A REALITY
ITSELF STUDENTS WHO. AREN'T
THERE MORE THAN LIKELY. GO ON
NAFTA SPEND MORE TIME IN THE
CSU SYSTEM. SO THE ISSUE THAT I
ASK THE CSU EARLIER ABOUT THEY
SAID THAT 91% OF THEIR
STUDENTS. RT TAKE THE FOR THE
FOUR YEARS. AND THAT IT'S THE
IT'S THE- NOT NINE. NINE THE
STUDENTS ARE ON CAMPUS. WITH
THAT THE STUDENTS WHO ARE ON
CAMPUS STUDENTS WHO WERE
ADMITTED TODAY RIGHT CORRECT
BUT THAT SAYS NOTHING ABOUT THE
POOL YEAH AND IT SAYS NOTHING
ABOUT WHO'S IN HIGH SCHOOL I
GUESS TO GO BECAUSE YOU'RE
ARGUING TWO THINGS YOU'RE
YOU'RE I MEAN YOUR ARGUMENT IS
NOT JUST WHO IS THERE BUT WE
WANT TO GET MORE STUDENTS
THERE. WHICH IS YOUR WHOLE
CAMPAIGN WHICH I GET THAT BUT
LET'S JUST FOCUS STUDENTS TO
SHOW UP ON DAY ONE SO THEY'RE
SAYING THAT THAT THERE'S NINE
PERCENT. THAT HADN'T TAKEN
THOSE FOUR YEARS OF MATH OR
ADDITIONAL Q. R. COURSES THERE
DISPROPORTIONATELY IN ENROLLED
IN REMEDIAL OR NEED REMEDIATION
GRANTED THE REMEDIATION THINGS
CHANGED. DO YOU DISAGREE WITH
THAT BECAUSE YOU'RE SAYING THAT
THERE'S NO CORRELATION THERE
SAYING THAT THERE IS. WHAT I'M
SAYING IS THERE'S NO EVIDENCE
BEING PRESENTED AT THAT THE
CORRELATION BETWEEN TAKING MATH.
AND BEING SUCCESSFUL IN COLLEGE.
IS CALL VOTE. THE THEORY WOULD
SUGGEST THAT WHAT CAUSES THE
IMPACT OF MATH TAKING IS THAT
IN HIGH SCHOOLS WHERE THERE'S
BOTH THE AVAILABILITY AND THE
CULTURE I SUPPORTING MATH
TAKING. I HAVE LOTS OF OTHER
BENEFITS I'S GOING TO BE WELL
OVER SOURCED IT'S GOING TO HAVE
EFFECTIVE TEACHERS I IT'S GOING
TO HAVE LESS. LESS POVERTY IT'S
GOING TO HAVE LESS RACIAL
ISOLATION. I JUST DON'T THINK
IT'S THE QUADRATIC EQUATION. I
THAT IS. LINKED IT CAUSATION
TERMS. OR THEORETICALLY. I TO
POST SECONDARY OUTCOMES. OKAY
TO SEND YOU TO AN OBJECT RIGHT
NOW YEAH I SEE WHAT YOU'RE
SAYING THAT CAUSATION VERSUS
CORRELATION AND BY GIVEN AT
FAMILY. WHO'S HAS LIMITED
RESOURCES A HUNDRED BUCKS LIKE
TO MAKE THAT ALL OF A SUDDEN
THAT FAMILY THAT KID LITERATE
BECAUSE COULD HAVE HUNDRED
BUCKS IS THE- PARENT IS GOING
TO READ THE BOOKS AND ALL THESE
OTHER. THINGS ARE IN FACT SO I
GET YOUR- ARGUMENT THERE. IN
YOUR ANALYSIS. MAYBE MY DID
MAKE SENSE BUT- I THINK YOU
DON'T I'M TRYING TO SAY. I DID
OKAY. SO THE WHOLE OPTING OUT
THING. WHY ONE THAT WORK IF
THERE IF SEIZE YOU SAYING WE
GET THE S. THE MAYBE SOME.
DISTRICTS DONNA PICK ONE
ANYWHERE IN CALIFORNIA JUST FOR
WHATEVER REASON DOESN'T HAVE.
THE COURSE OFFERINGS WE DON'T
WANNA HARM THAT STUDENT THEY
CAN OPT OUT AND THEY'RE SAYING
THE ONLY AFTER ASKED OPT OUT AS
AN AUTOMATIC OPT OUT. I WANT
THAT SUFFICE THE OPPOSITION IN
YOUR ARGUMENTS OF THIS WILL.
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACT. A
CERTAIN STUDENTS AND
COMMUNITIES UP BECAUSE THE CSU
HAS FAILED TO BE EXPLICIT ABOUT
WHAT THIS WAIVER WOULD LOOK
LIKE IT'S NOT. ANYTHING THAT
WE'VE SEEN IN DETAILED STATUE
AS THE PROPOSAL IS BEING
FORWARD WERE SUPPOSED TO TRUST
THAT THE WAIVER IS GOING TO
WORK WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
SCHOOLS THAT ALREADY. DON'T DO
A GREAT JOB AT PROVIDING
SUFFICIENT ACCESS COUNSELING
PREPARATION SUPPORT FOR
STUDENTS TO COMPLETE A THROUGH
G. COURSES AS IS.
CLARITY WOULD BE ALL VERY YOU
KNOW VERY HELPFUL BUT I ALSO
FEEL LIKE WE'RE HAVING A
CONVERSATION ABOUT A WAIVER.
WERE HAVING A CONVERSATION
ABOUT WHETHER IT THIS IS
CAUSATION OR CORRELATION SO
ESSENTIALLY WE'RE PUTTING THE
CART BEFORE THE HORSE I GET
THAT BUT THERE'S A WILL THERE
WAS AN OPT OUT WHICH YOU THINK
WAS. A FACT DEVON WHICH WOULD
BE FAIR WOULD THAT MEAN YOU
WOULDN'T HAVE CONCERNS OF THIS
POLICY. I HAVE CONCERNS WITH
THE POLICY FOR A LOT OF REASONS
FIRST BECAUSE THERE ISN'T PROOF
AS CHRIS AT LEE HAS ACTUALLY
UPDATED. THE OPT OUT WITH THE
OPT OUT IS NOT DEFINED I DON'T
KNOW LESS AND LESS THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS HAVE RECEIVED MORE
INFORMATION ABOUT THE WAIVER.
AND IT BEING AUTOMATIC SO THAT
THEY HAD A CS ON BY NOW SHARED
A LIKE IF THERE IF YOU COULD
CRAFT THE PERFECT OPT OUT
POLICY. WITH THAT MITIGATE THE
MAJORITY OF THE- YOUR PROBABLY
PROBABLY NOT BECAUSE I DO
BELIEVE THAT THIS IS A
RATIONING AND SORTING TOOL. AND
SO EVEN IF YOU HAVE AN OPT OUT
SO IN IT IMAGINE HOW DO YOU
GUARANTEE THAT. THAT STUDENTS
TO GET THE WAIVER AN OPT OUT
AREN'T ACTUALLY IMPACTED BY THE
POLICY WHEN THERE CONTINUES TO
BE THERE WILL CONTINUE TO BE
GROWING ELIGIBILITY. RIGHT
BECAUSE OUR YOUNG PEOPLE KNOW
THAT THEY HAVE TO GET A FOUR
YEAR DEGREE. AND THEY CONTINUE
TO MEET THE RAISE THE BAR OF A
THREE G. ACCESSING COMPLETION
SO. SO NO I WOULD NOT BE
SATISFIED. OKAY AND THEN WHAT.
DO YOU THINK ABOUT THE REFER
THEM TO PROVIDE YEAH. I
APOLOGIZE FOR I'M- I DON'T KNOW
HOW TO DESIGN. A WAIVER OR AN
OPT OUT I'M. GOOD AT FINDING
PEOPLE WHO ARE MORE EXPERT THAN
I AM. AND I WOULDN'T LOOK TO
SEE AS YOU FOR THAT I'D LIKE TO
SEE D. E. AND I'D LOOK TO
INDEPENDENT RESEARCHERS. SO NOT
ONLY DO WE HAVE NO REAL
CONTENT. TO WHAT THE CRITERION
WILL BE FOR DECIDING THAT A
SCHOOL DISTRICT DOESN'T. HAVE
CAPACITY HAVE THE MEASURE THAT
OUT BUT. THE WRONG BODY THE
WRONG PEOPLE ARE DEFINING THAT
AND IMPLEMENTING IT. I SO AT A
MINIMUM AT THE SHOULD BE
SOMETHING IN WHICH I C. D. BABY
THERE NEED TO BE. WARD
STANDARDS SHOULD BE MAKING THE
JUDGMENT ABOUT WHETHER THEY'RE
SUFFICIENT CAPACITY OKAY AND
THEN THE NEXT QUESTION IS ABOUT
THE DISTRICTS ARE DOING THIS
AND STAND WE'RE GONNA HAVE A
PANEL IN A FEW MOMENTS FROM MY
LOCAL DISTRICT IN MY ASSEMBLY
DISTRICT SUPER EXCITED TO SEE
HER COME UP HERE. AND I'M NOT
SURE WHERE SHE'S GONNA COME IN
ON THIS BUT THERE ARE SOME
DISTRICTS THAT ARE DOING THIS
AND SOME THAT ARE NOT SO THE
CSU REPRESENTATIVE SAID
ESSENTIALLY IT'S NOT THAT BIG
OF A DEAL WITH WHAT THEY
CURRENTLY HAVE IN THEIR
RESOURCES KNOWING YOU HAVE.
EIGHT YEARS. TO ROLL THIS OUT
THAT THERE ARE STUDENTS TO. AND
I'VE HEARD ABOUT THIS LOCALLY
STUDENTS WHO ARE IN TWELFTH
GRADE. AND THEY'VE KEPT
COULDN'T COMPLETED THEIR-
COMPLETED THEIR OB. GRADUATION
REQUIREMENTS THEY YOU KNOW THEY
HAVE HALF DAYS. HOW DO YOU. HOW
DO YOU RECONCILE THAT THAT SOME
OF THE LARGER DISTRICTS IN
CALIFORNIA LARGE POPULATIONS
ARE ARE DOING IT AND IT HASN'T.
UPSET THE APPLE CART TOO MUCH
AT ALL OR DO YOU THINK THAT
THERE ARE HARMS IN THOSE
DISTRICTS FIRST FOR CERTAIN
STUDENTS YEAH THANK YOU THAT'S
AN EXCELLENT QUESTION YOU KNOW
I'M CERTAINLY NOT A K. TWELVE
EXPERT BUT I TRUST WHEN I
TALKED TO SUPERINTENDENT C<c.cyan></c>
CáC A LOT OF SACRAMENTO. I
TRUST WHEN I TALKED TO SCHOOL
BOARD MEMBER AND SCHOOL BOARD
FORMER SCHOOL BOARD PRESIDENT
MONICA GARCIA AND LA AND THEY
TELL ME ABOUT THEIR CONCERNS
AROUND THE AVAILABILITY OF MATH
AND SCIENCE TEACHERS. THAT THEY
ALREADY HAVE TOO MANY POSITIONS
THAT THEY CAN'T FILL I'M
CONCERNED WHEN THE FIRST TIME
THEY'VE HEARD OF THIS PROPOSAL
IS BECAUSE I'VE TALKED TO THEM
ABOUT IT OR BECAUSE WE HAVE AS
A COALITION OF CIVIL RIGHTS
ADVOCATES HAVE GONE OUT AND
TALK TO THEM ABOUT IT. I DON'T
THINK THAT THAT'S REALLY GOOD
COLLABORATION POLICY THAT LOOK
AT RIGHT NOW IS TO NEXT BUT BUT
RESPECTFULLY EARLIER THEY THEY
MENTION THAT LEVEL. I THOUGHT
THESE PAPERS WE MENTIONED NOT
AS STRICT SAN DIEGO AND. LONG
BEACH STOP IN THE MENTION A FEW
OTHERS SO. IT'S WORKING THERE
THOSE ARE LARGE DISTRICTS. AND
YOU THINK WELL LONG BEACH
UNIFIED INVESTED MORE THAN TEN
MILLION DOLLARS. IN AND OF
ITSELF AND ITS IN RECRUITING
PREPARING FOR A THREE G. AS A
DEFAULT CURRICULUM. I WOULD
LOVE IT IF EVERY SCHOOL
DISTRICT HAD THE RESOURCES AND
CAPACITY AND PHILANTHROPIC
SUPPORT. THAT LONG BEACH WAS
ABLE TO GET IN ORDER TO ELEVATE
THIS REQUIREMENT FOR AND
PROVIDE REAL ACCESS TO ALL
STUDENTS. IF EVERY SCHOOL
DISTRICT DID NOT GETTING GO
STOCKED IN ELK GROVE. SO HOW
ANOTHER LARGE URBAN DISTRICTS.
LOW AND I AND I CAN SHOW YOU A
THREE G. COMPLETION RATES AND
TERMS OF PREPARATION FOR ALL
THOSE DISTRICTS I DIDN'T PULL
THE OWES FIRST ON THE STANDING
OUT HOW THEY'RE DOING IT. AND
WHAT WOULD WORK WHEN. THE
CONCERNS THAT YOU'RE
ARTICULATING HAVEN'T BEEN HAVE
MEANT VALENTYN THOSE. EXAMPLE
WELL I THINK THEY'VE BEEN FOUND%
IN IN SEVERAL DISTRICTS THAT
I'VE THAT WE'VE GOTTEN TO
OPPOSE THIS THAT ARE PRETTY
SIGNIFICANT SO SACRAMENTO. LOS
ANGELES SANTA ANA ANAHEIM YEAH
WELL LET LA UST HAS DEFAULT A
THROUGH G. CURRICULUM. AND
THEY'VE BEEN IMPLEMENTING THAT
FOR OVER TEN YEARS AND A 100%
OF THEIR GRADUATES ARE STILL
NOT ELIGIBLE SO I THINK
ASSEMBLY MINUTES SPEAKS TO THE
VERY REALITY THAT SCHOOL
DISTRICTS FACE IN TERMS OF
PROVIDING TRUE EQUITABLE ACCESS
EVEN WHEN THEY'RE COMMITTED TO
IN A THROUGH G. DEFAULT POLICY.
YEAH BUT I GET THAT BUT YOU
KNOW YOUR JOB RESPECTFULLY IS
TO GO AROUND IN. A CAMPAIGN TO
RID ELEVATE THIS ISSUE TO
ARTICULATED THIS IS NOT GOOD
FOR CERTAIN POPULATION AND
THERE ARE. A TO BRING BACK UP
HERE WITH A LISTED QUITE A FEW
DISTRICTS IF YOU LOOK AT THE
POPULATION I WOULD THINK IT'S
A- GREAT NUMBER OF THAT.
OVERALL PUBLISHED IN CALIFORNIA
THEY FIGURED IT AND WE MISSING
SOMETHING. OR OR IS THIS FEAR
LIKE YOU SAID THE CHANGE I MEAN
HE SAID PEOPLE ARE AFRAID I
LOOK ABOUT CHANGED THIS TO
PEOPLE PEOPLE ARE AGAINST IT.
ARE A 100% CERTAIN THE DOWNFALL
PEOPLE ARE FOR CHANGE ARE
CAUTIOUSLY OPTIMISTIC THE
UPSIDE SO WHY WHAT IS CHANGE
ALWAYS LISTEN WELL FIRST IT
STATE THAT THAT. THAT'S NOT MY
POSITION. MY POSITION IS NO
MORE BEFORE YOU MAKE A DECISION
OKAY. SO THAT'S MY LAST
QUESTION ACTUALLY RIGHT HERE NO
MORE BE SO THERE'S- I COULD
GIVE YOU FIFTEEN. EMPIRICAL
QUESTIONS THAT SHOULD BE
ANSWERED BEFORE POLICY WITH
THESE HIGH STAKES RISKS. IS SET
IN AND OUT THAT'S ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT I WOULD HOPE THE
COMMITTEE. LET ME AS A MATTER
OF I HAVE THAT I DON'T
QUESTIONS BECAUSE I KNOW MISTER
MEDINA HAS SOME QUESTIONS WE
HAVE ONE MORE PANEL THEN PUBLIC
COMMENT. AND IT'S ALREADY
GETTING LATE. AND SO MY
QUESTION IS DO YOU THINK THAT
THIS IS. A CAB. DO YOU THINK
THIS POLICY. HAS HAS MERIT IT'S
ABOUT TIMING. COULD YOU TALK
ABOUT THE ROLLOUT LACK OF
INFORMATION THE LACK OF K.
TWELVE. ENGAGE MEN BUILT IN A
SILO THAT'S ALL GOBBLEDYGOOK
FOR YOU NOW JUST DO IT NEXT
YEAR GIVE US TIME AND WE HEAR
THAT ALL THE TIME UP HERE OR DO
YOU THINK THIS IS SUCH A
FATALLY FLAWED PROPOSAL ON THE
IDEA. THAT WE SHOULD NEVER
HAPPEN AND THAT IT'S HARD FOR
ME TO GET THAT BECAUSE KNOWING
THAT. THERE'S OTHER DISTRICTS
THAT HAVE DONE THIS AND THAT
THE STUDENTS WHO ARE. HAVING
CHALLENGES WITH REMEDIAL
EDUCATION AND THE NEED IF THE
SAYS AT. AT ELEMENT DECADE
RECTIFY THAT I WISH WE WERE
HAVING A CONVERSATION IN
HEARING FROM THE CSU TO TALK
ABOUT WHAT THEY'RE DOING
INTERNALLY TO IMPROVE
GRADUATION RATES AND SUPPORT
THEIR STUDENTS AND THERE'S A
LOT OF GREAT WORK THAT'S
HAPPENING AT CAMPUSES TO DO
THAT. AND I THINK THAT'S WHERE
WE SHOULD BE SPENDING MUCH MORE
OF OUR TIME AND ENERGY INSTEAD
OF KICKING THE CAN TO K. TWELVE
AND SAYING THEY SHOULD DELIVER
BETTER STUDENTS BETTER STUDENTS
BEING VERY SUBJECTIVE TO GET TO
ANSWERING YOUR QUESTION I DON'T
BELIEVE THAT THIS POLICY. IS
THE RIGHT POLICY BECAUSE THEY
HAVEN'T PROVIDED SUFFICIENT
EVIDENCE IN A PUBLICLY
TRANSPARENT WAY THAT IT
ACTUALLY WILL CAUSE THE RESULT
THAT THEY WANT THAT'S ASSUMING
THAT THE RESULT THAT THEY WANT
WHICH IS IMPROVED GRADUATION
RATES. WILL IT THE ONLY WAY OR
THE BEST WAY TO GET THERE IS
THROUGH THIS POLICY AND WITHOUT
ANY PROOF THAT IT ISN'T GONNA
HAVE DESPAIRED IMPACT FOR
STUDENTS OF COLOR AND FOR LOW
INCOME STUDENTS AND FOR
STUDENTS IN REGIONS THAT ARE
ALREADY HAVING A VERY HARD
TIME. MEETING COLLEGE
PREPARATION EIGHT THREE G.
ACCESS FOR OUR STUDENTS. I
THINK WE KNOW ENOUGH ABOUT.
CAPACITY PROBLEMS UP AND THEIR
RELATIONSHIP TO POVERTY AND
REYES I TO STATE THAT THERE IS
EVIDENCE THAT THIS KIND OF
POLICY THAT WOULD CREATE A
DISPARATE IMPACT BUT WE DON'T
WON'T KNOW FOR SURE UNTIL IT'S
BEEN IN PLACE FOR SEVERAL YEARS
BUT THERE BUT THERE IS RESEARCH
RIGHT NOW THAT SUGGESTS THAT
IT'S LIKELY. HAVE A DISPARATE
IMPACT IT IT. I SO THAT REALLY
DOES MEAN THAT THE BURDEN
SHOULD BE ON CSU. EITHER
DEMONSTRATE NOT WITH
SPECULATION THAT IT WON'T. BUT
ALSO TO DEMONSTRATE THAT THERE
ARE ALTERNATIVE. WAYS TO.
INCREASED PREPARATION THAT
DON'T HAVE THE KIND OF. RACIAL
AND CLASS. ACT THAT MATHEMATICS
DIES BECAUSE OF THE INEQUITIES
THAT CURRENTLY EXISTING K.
TWELVE. SO I KNOW THAT'S THOSE
MY LAST QUESTION BUT YOU YOU'RE
WATCHING THEM TO YOUR
CONVEYANCE THAT THERE'S GOING
TO BE THIS DESPERATE DISPARATE
IMPACT. AND THAT'S A LEGAL TERM
AN OBVIOUS YEAR AT BUT YOU KNOW
WHAT I'M NOT I YEAH I
DISPROPORTIONATE IMPACT ON
CERTAIN COMMUNITIES RIGHT RIGHT
SO IF THE 91% WE SHOP THE CSU
WITH FOR YEARS ALREADY ARE THE
SAME ETHNIC BREAK GROUND AS A
9% BUT HOW DID ABBOTT NEGATIVE
IMPACT. TO LOOK AT THE CSU
INCOMING CLASS IT'S VERY VERY
DIVERSE IN THE FIRST PLACE AND
ASSUMING THAT THOSE ARE
DIFFERENT THOSE TWO POPULATIONS.
HOW IT NEGATIVELY IMPACT IF
THERE ARE THE PEOPLE WHO ARE
GETTING IN ARE JUST AS BROWN
AND BLACK AS THE 9% TO GET IN
AND WHO. HAVE DIFFICULT TIME
WITH THE REMEDIATION AT THE
GATE AND THEY NOW HAVE TO IN
THE YOUNGER THE LITTLE BROTHERS
AND SISTERS AFTER TAKE THESE
FOURTH FOURTH. HERE OF COURSE
IS NOT. BOB I THINK THAT IS
EVIDENCE THAT. IT'S SOME
EVIDENCE THAT THERE IS NOT A
DISPARATE IMPACT BUT I THINK
YOU'RE LOOKING AT THE WRONG.
ISSUE WITH THIS IS FOCUSED ON
ELIGIBILITY. I THEY COULD USING
WHOLE FILE REVIEW OF MAKE UP
FOR US Q. IN THE ELIGIBLE
ELIGIBILITY POOL OF. BASED ON
THE SUBTLER SUCH MORE SUBTLE HI.
SCREENING AND. NOT TECHNIQUES
THAT THEY USED TO BE MORE STOOD
TO BE TO BE SELECT THAT'S
THAT'S A HYPOTHESIS WE DON'T
REALLY KNOW NO NUMBERS THAT'S
RIGHT AND THAT'S WHAT THAT IS
WHAT IS PROBLEMATIC WE DON'T
KNOW THE NUMBERS. AND BEFORE
THAT FOR MY PURPOSES A
DESPERATE DESPERATE IMPACT.
ABOUT WHAT THE OUTCOME WELL WE
KNOW THAT THERE IS A DISPARITY
ALREADY IN CAPACITY. THAT'S
RELATED TO POVERTY AND RACE WE
KNOW THAT ALREADY THAT'S
EVIDENT THAT'S RESEARCH THAT'S
BEEN DONE. SO THE MOST LOGICAL
THING TO BELIEVE AND WE ALSO
KNOW THAT UNDER RESOURCE
DISTRICTS. I HAVE MORE TROUBLE
WITH IMPLEMENTATION. AS A
GENERAL IMPLEMENTING DOING THE
RIGHT THING WITHOUT CFF
IMPLEMENTING EL CAP I MEAN YOU
NAME IT. UNDER RESOURCE
DISTRICTS OBVIOUSLY HAVE MORE
TROUBLE WITH IMPLEMENTATION SO.
SO WE KNOW THAT IF THE
ELIGIBILITY POOL. PIGGY BACKS
OFF OF A SET OF. IT SORT OF
INEQUITABLE CIRCUMSTANCES. ARE
I THINK IT IS A VERY REASONABLE
INFERENCE NOT SPECULATION I
THAT. IT'LL BE TAINTED IN THE
SAME WAY. AGAIN IF WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT ELIGIBILITY YOU
CAN CLEAN IT UP. TO A DEGREE
WITH WHOLE FILE REVIEW. OKAY
THANK YOU THANK YOU. A COUPLE
OF COMMENTS AND THEN A COUPLE
OF QUESTIONS I THINK I HEARD
MISTER MCCARTY SAY THAT HE HAD
THREE YEARS OF MATH. IN HIGH
SCHOOL. SOUNDED LIKE ONE POINT
ONE. THINK ABOUT WHAT ONE OF MY
LEAST I'VE WON AT LEAST ONE AT
LEAST ONE. MAYBE YOU MAY WANT
TO MAYBE TWO MAYBE TWO MAYBE TO
SOME OF THE FIVE PERCENTER.
ONLY 5% PEOPLE HAD THAT.
BACKGROUND SO I WAS THE CALL
RIGHT THERE WITH YOU OKAY GOOD
RIGHT TWO OF US. ALGEBRA ONE
GEOMETRY. THAT WAS IT AS OUR
FANCY CLASSES FOR ESTIMATES
THAT WAS IT THAT WAS IT AND
STILL I WAS ACCEPTED INORDER
DAME UNIVERSITY PURDUE
UNIVERSITY AND I'M A GRADUATE
OF UC RIVERSIDE AND HAVE A
MASTERS IN HISTORY FROM UC
RIVERSIDE. WITH ONLY THOSE TWO
YEARS OF MATH. SO I THINK IT IS
A POINT WELL TAKEN THAT THAT
FOR STUDENTS WHO ARE NOT GOING
INTO. ENGINEERING SCIENCE YOU
KNOW. AB THREE YEARS OF MATH
MAY BE ENOUGH AND CERTAINLY MR
MCCARTY AND I DID OKAY WITH
ONLY. TWO YEARS OF MATH SO I'M
JUST POINTING THAT OUT I ALSO
WANT TO SHARE YOUR COUPLE
LETTERS THAT I HAVE ONE IN
FRONT OF ME HERE FROM THE
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATIVE BLACK
CAUCUS THE IT SAYS HERE IT'S
SUBMIT THIS LETTER IN
OPPOSITION TO CSU PROPOSAL TO
INCREASE ADMISSION
REQUIREMENTS. SECOND LETTER
PATRICK O'DONNELL THE CHAIR OF
EDUCATION HE SAYS I AM
CONCERNED THAT OUR PUBLIC
SCHOOLS CURRENTLY LACK THE
FISCAL AND STAFF RESOURCES TO
IMPLEMENT THE PROPOSED
REQUIREMENT. I DO THINK THAT IT
IS A QUESTION OF INFORMATION
AND DATA AND CSU. TO MY WAY OF
LOOKING AT THINGS HAS NOT
DEMONSTRATED. THAT THIS
PROPOSAL. IS ONE NEEDED AND I
THINK TO DOCTOR LEE IS AS YOU
HAVE INDICATED. THAT THERE
REALLY IS A CONNECTION ONE BIT
BETWEEN THE OTHER AND THAT IT
REALLY IS THAT FORTY YEAR OF
MAP THAT'S GONNA MAKE THE
DIFFERENCE THAT IS NOT
SOMETHING ELSE. SO THANK YOU
FOR YOUR PRESENTATION A COUPLE
QUESTIONS IF YOU HAD ANY
MODIFICATIONS TO THIS PROPOSAL
WHAT WOULD THEY BE TO MAKE IT
MORE ACCEPTABLE. TO YOU IF ANY.
WHY I THINK OUR OUR BROAD
RECOMMENDATION IS THAT WE
SHOULD HAVE BE WE SHOULD BE
HAVING A BROADER CONVERSATION
AROUND COLLEGE AGILE
ELIGIBILITY I THINK DATA
TRANSPARENCY HAS BEEN RAISED
SEVERAL TIMES. INDEPENDENT DATA
TRANSPARENCY TO REALLY ANALYZE
A DESPAIRED IMPACT AND REAL
COORDINATION WITH K. TWELVE TO
INSURE THE POSSIBILITY THAT
EVEN SIX YEARS IS AN
APPROPRIATE TIME FRAME FOR
IMPLEMENTATION. THE NEXT
QUESTION AND I ONLY HAVE A
COUPLE MORE DO YOU THINK THE
pSTATE SHOULD BE SATISFIED WITH
THE LARGE NUMBER OF STUDENTS
WHO WERE ONLY TAKING TWO OR
THREE YEARS OF MATH. AND IF NOT
HOW WOULD YOU ADDRESS. THE
NUMBER OF STUDENTS WHO ARE
TAKING TWO OR THREE YEARS OF
MATH. OTHER THAN THE PROPOSAL
THAT THERE. PROPOSING. IF THIS
WERE GOING TO GO FORWARD. I
THINK IT SHOULD BE CSU
PERSUADING THE STATE BOARD OF
EDUCATION AND THE
SUPERINTENDENT. TO CHANGE HIGH
SCHOOL CURRICULUM AND
GRADUATION REQUIREMENTS. THAT'S
THE RIGHT WAY TO DO THIS IF
IT'S GOING TO BE DOT. IT STILL
DOESN'T ADDRESS THE QUESTION OF
WHETHER. QUANTITATIVE REASONING
IS THE BEST WAY TO IMPROVE
STUDENT OUTCOMES. THEY OUGHT TO
LOOK AT ALTERNATIVES. I AM NOT.
MR BUT JUST LET ME LET LET LET
ME LET ME STOP THERE. SO I
WOULD. SO THE MAIN CHANGE I
WOULD MAKE IN THE IN THE IN THE
PROPOSAL AS IT'S WRITTEN AND IT
MAY BE ON THE LEGISLATION COULD
ACCOMPLISH THIS IS REQUIRE THAT
THE- EXEMPTION. BE DEFINED AND
IMPLEMENTED BY CD. RATHER THAN
THE CSU ACADEMIC FACULTY.
ACADEMICS AND. AND MY LAST
QUESTION TO MICHELLE. IN NOT
SUPPORTING THIS PROPOSAL. WHAT
ADVICE WOULD YOU HAVE THE CSU
TO INCREASE GRADUATION RATES.
WELL I THINK OF YOU KNOW CS USE
GRADUATION INITIATIVE HAS BEEN
A REALLY EXCELLENT NORTHSTAR IT
HAS DEMONSTRATED A COMMITMENT
BY THE INSTITUTIONS AND THE AND
THEIR LEADERSHIP AT THE VALUE
OF IMPROVING GRADUATION RATES
AND I THINK MOST OF YOU SAW
THAT YOU KNOW WONDERFUL NEWS
THAT THE FOUR YEAR GRADUATION
RATE HAS INCREASED AS HAS THE
SIX YEAR GRADUATION RATE. I
THINK ASSEMBLY MEMBER MCCARTY
TALKED ABOUT YOU KNOW THE VERY
REAL REALITY AROUND COUNSELING
AND GUIDANCE RIGHT ENSURING
THAT STUDENTS KNOW THAT FULL
TIME ENROLLMENT TO GRADUATE IN
FOUR YEARS IS FIFTEEN AND NOT
TWELVE EVEN THOUGH YOU GET FULL
FINANCIAL AID PACKAGING AT
TWELVE UNITS. WE KNOW THAT
SUMMER BRIDGE PROGRAMS AT CAL
STATE SAN BERNARDINO ARE
INCREDIBLY EFFECTIVE WE KNOW
THAT THE ELIMINATION OF
REMEDIAL AT COURSES HAS HAD
HUGE SUCCESS WITH STUDENTS WHO
WOULD HAVE BEEN DEEMED REMEDIAL
WE ALSO KNOW THE CAL STATE
DOMINGUEZ HILLS HAS DONE A GOOD
JOB OF IMPROVING ACCESS TO STEM
ART COURSES FOR STUDENTS OF
COLOR AND GETTING THEM TO
SUCCEED IN THOSE PATHWAYS. I
THINK THE CSU PROBABLY IS A
BETTER EXPERT AT A LOT OF THE
DIFFERENT INITIATIVES THAT THEY
ARE ALREADY PUTTING INTO PLACE
I WOULD MY ADVICE TO THE CSU IS
TO FOCUS AND DOUBLE DOWN ON ALL
OF THOSE EFFORTS AND
INITIATIVES THE IDEA. THAT WE
SHOULD. THE IDEA THAT THE
BIGGEST SOLUTION SHOULD BE
AROUND THE INCOMING STUDENTS.
INSTEAD OF FOCUSING ON WHAT THE
INSTITUTION CAN CONTROL AND
SHOULD DO TO BETTER SERVE ITS
STUDENTS. YOU KNOW WE WANT TO
SEE GRADUATION NUMBERS GO UP
BUT NOT AT THE EXPENSE OF
CONTINUING TO LEAVE MORE
STUDENTS BEHIND AND LEAVE THEM
OUT. ESPECIALLY WHEN THOSE
STUDENTS TYPICALLY TEND TO BE
LOW INCOME STUDENTS OF COLOR.
I'D LIKE TO ADD UP I'D I'D LIKE
LIKE TO ADD MISTER CHAIRMAN
THAT. THERE'S A DIFFERENT WAY
TO FRAME THIS. THE AT THE DEEP
QUESTION IS UP WHAT CAN HIGH
SCHOOLS DUE TO HELP CSU PRODUCE
BETTER OUTCOMES. THIS PROPOSAL
OFFERS ONE IDEA. ONE IDEA OF
HIGH SCHOOLS MY COUNTRY MIGHT
IT'S SPECULATIVE IMPROVE
STUDENT OUTCOMES. BUT SUPPOSE
YOU HAD A POLICY IN PLACE OF
THIS Q. R. ONE THAT SAID. I
STUDENTS HAVE TO HAVE. THE
FOURTH YEAR OF MATH. FOR A
SECOND A SECOND COURSE IN AYE
EXPOSITORY WRITING. FOR A
COURSE IN PHILOSOPHY. RIGHT
MAKE MAKE A SET OF OPTIONS IF
YOU BACK EACH OF THEM WITH
EVIDENCE THAT THEY ARE
PREDICTORS OF COLLEGE SUCCESS I
WOULDN'T LIMITED TO MATH
BECAUSE OF ALL THE PROBLEMS
THAT ARE ASSOCIATED WITH MATH.
RIGHT SO I THINK I THINK
FRAMING IT THIS NARROWLY.
EXACERBATES THE DANGER OF
AMPLIFYING THAT K. TWELVE
INEQUITIES WE ALREADY HAVE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
PRESENTATION THANK YOU FOR
BEING HERE AND NEXT SIDE HOPE
TO HAVE A RESPONSE FROM THE K.
TWELVE AND WITH THAT I INVITE.
JACKIE ONE. SCHOOL BOARD
PRESIDENT WASHINGTON UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT. I THINK YOU
BURDEN. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR
MEDINA THE FUN. AND ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MCCARTY THANK YOU FOR
HAVING ME TODAY ADVOCATE TOLD
RESPONSE PORTION OF THE
OVERSIGHT HEARING HUGE
RESPONSIBILITIES SO I ACTUALLY
HAVE TECHNOLOGY THAT THERE MAY
BE SOME PERSPECTIVE FROM CABLE
THAT PERHAPS ARE MISSING FROM
THIS PANEL. SO WITH THAT SAID
MY NAME IS JACKIE TOO LONG LONG
AND I CURRENTLY SET AT THE
PRESIDENT OF THE WASHINGTON
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT IN WEST
SACRAMENTO SO WE ARE THE END
CAP TO THIS PANEL LOOKS LIKE. I
WANT TO NOTE THAT I'M ALSO
REPRESENTING NOT ONLY MY
EXPENSE OF THE TRUSTEE BUT ALSO
A DROP FROM MY EXPERIENCE
HAVING WORKED IN THE
LEGISLATURE WHICH INCLUDING
BEING PART OF THE DEVELOPMENT
OF THE CURRENT STATUTORY K.
TWELVE FRAMEWORK KNOWN AS THE
LOCAL CONTROL FUNDING FORMULA.
OR ELSE YOU. MY WORK AT AND
ALSO MY WORK AT THE CALIFORNIA
APARTMENT AS OF EDUCATION AS A
REGULATOR FOR A STATE WIDE
PROGRAM TALKING BELITTLE YOU.
AT THE CENTRAL OFFICE SCHOOL
DISTRICT ADMINISTRATOR IN A
LARGE URBAN SCHOOL DISTRICT
BEFORE AND DURING STATE
RECEIVERSHIP SO YOU CAN GUESS
WHERE THAT MIGHT BE. AS AN
EDUCATOR IN THE HIGHER ED
SYSTEM AND MOST IMPORTANTLY AT
THE DIRECT SERVICE PROVIDER FOR
STUDENTS AND FAMILIES. HELPING
THEM TO FILL THEIR COLLEGE AND
CAREER GOALS. I WANNA BEGIN BY
PROVIDING THE COMMITTEE WITH A
FEW DATA POINTS RELATED TO
CAREFUL DEMOGRAPHICS I THINK IT
WILL HELP PAINT A KIND OF. A
PICTURE OF WHAT WHERE WEREUP
AGAINST. WE HAVE APPROXIMATELY
SIX POINT FOUR MILLION STUDENTS
APPROXIMATE TWO MILLION IN HIGH
SCHOOL AND WITH A THIRTEEN
HUNDRED HIGH SCHOOL SEVEN OUR
SCHOOLS OF ALTERNATIVE
EDUCATION. AND A HUNDRED THIRTY
EIGHT SPECIAL EDUCATION
SCHOOLS. WHICH WILL BE IMPACTED
BY THIS PROPOSAL. ONE QUESTION
UNDER REVIEW AND CONSIDERATION.
FOR MY COLLEAGUES IS HOW DO WE
HAVE TO MAINTAIN. A HIGH
COLLEGE GOING CULTURES WHILE
SIMULTANEOUSLY ENSURING THAT
ENTRY INTO A FOUR YEAR COLLEGE
SHOULD BE ACCESSIBLE TO ALL
CALIFORNIANS STUDENTS. THIS IS
PARTICULARLY IMPORTANT IN TITLE
ONE ARE HIGH POVERTY SCHOOL
DISTRICTS. THE COLLEGE GOING
FRAMEWORK HAS BEEN MADE AYE
BUNDLING CLEAR WITH THE
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL DASHBOARD.
WHICH IS CALIFORNIANS NEW
DISTRICT ACCOUNTABILITY SYSTEM
AND I'M SURE YOU'RE WELL AWARE
OF THAT BUT AFTER HIGHLIGHTS
AND TRACKS PROGRESS MADE BY
DISTRICTS TOWARDS COLLEGE AND
CAREER READINESS. AND WE'VE
USED THE A TO G. REQUIREMENT AS
THAT TRACKING ADVICE AS WELL AS
ENTRY COMPLETION OF COLLAGEN
GRIP PATHWAYS. HEALTHY OF OUR
STATURE DRIVER REQUIRES THAT WE
CONTINUOUSLY WORK TOWARDS
CLOSING ACHIEVEMENT GAPS
BETWEEN SUB GROUPS. AND TO
ENSURE EQUITY FOR ALL THINGS
WITHIN OUR K. TWELVE SYSTEM.
NEW TO THIS ACCOUNT A FRAMEWORK
AS IDENTIFICATION SINCE IN
FOSTER CARE AT THE SUB GROUP A
GROUP THAT I BELIEVE WILL MAY
BE NEGATIVELY IMPACTED BY THE
CSU PROPOSAL. I ALSO AM
CONCERNED THAT STUDENTS WITH
SIMILAR DEMOGRAPHICS AS FOSTER
YOUTH WILL SUFFER THE SAME
CHALLENGES AS MENTIONED EARLIER.
IT CONCERNS ME THAT THIS NEW
PROPOSAL WILL FURTHER
EXACERBATE THE ACHIEVEMENT GAP.
AND POSSIBLY UNDERMINE CURRENT
EFFORTS TOWARDS TOWARDS
EDUCATIONAL EQUITY. WHICH AGAIN
AS A DRIVER OF OUR STATUTORY
OBLIGATIONS TO OUR SIX POINT
TWO SIX SIX SIX ONE FOUR
MILLION STUDENTS. THE OTHER
QUESTION THAT NEEDS TO BE
UNPACKED IS WHETHER SOLELY IT
ADDING A YEAR A QUANTITATIVE
REASONING IS REALLY GOING TO
ENSURE MATRICULATION A
GRADUATION AND HIRING AD WHICH
HAS BEEN DISCUSSED BEFORE. A
WHAT THAT LOOKS LIKE FOR
STUDENTS WHO COME FROM
DISADVANTAGED BACKGROUNDS
INCLUDING BUT NOT LIMITED FALL
STREET HOMELESS YOUTH SPECIAL
NEEDS STUDENTS AND OTHERS. IF
YOU DON'T MIND I'M GONNA TAKE A
LITTLE BIT DEEPER INTO THE
DATA. FROM AT THAT YOU CAN DATE
OF STUDENTS IMPOSSIBLE TO
OUTLINE THE WORK THE CABLE
SYSTEMS HAVE TO DO TO ACTUALLY.
MEET THE GOALS OF THE DASHBOARD
AND THE INTENTIONS OF THE LOCAL
CONTROL FUNDING FORMULA AGAIN
OUR STATUTORY DRIVERS. THE HELP
CLOSE EDUCATIONAL EQUITY. ARE
THE EDUCATIONAL EQUITY GAP. SO
DO THE VARIOUS CHALLENGES AND
FROM MY EXPERIENCE TO STUDENTS
IN FOSTER CARE OFTEN AT AND ON
AN ACADEMIC AND DISADVANTAGED.
WHICH IS OFTEN EXACERBATED BY
THE EXTREMELY HIGH SCHOOL
MOBILITY OR TRANSFER RATES.
THEY ARE FIVE TIMES MORE LIKELY
AFTER TO TRANSFER SCHOOLS OF AN
ACADEMIC YEAR COMPARED TO THEIR
PEERS. ACROSS THE AND ACROSS
THE BOARD THEY ARE STILL IN THE
RED CATEGORY AND ACADEMIC
ACHIEVEMENT. MEANING THAT THEY
ARE FAR FROM STANDARD IN
ENGLISH LANGUAGE ARTS AND MATH.
FOR MATH SPECIFICALLY THEY ARE
HUNDRED AND FOURTEEN POINTS
BELOW STANDARD. SO AGAIN IT
PAINS KIND OF THE WORK THAT WE
HAVE TO DO AN AN LVF POSSE THAT
IDENTIFIED SUBGROUP. AND WE
HAVE A STATUTORY OBLIGATION TO
THEM. THEY ARE THE THEY ARE THE
LOWEST BUT THEY HAVE THE LOWEST
PERFORMANCE IN MEETING COLLEGE
AND CAREER READY AS INDICATORS
AT ONLY TEN POINT FOUR PERCENT.
OF THEIR STUDENT POPULATION
THAT ACTUALLY MEET THAT
INDICATOR. ONLY BE TO BE BEAT
BY. SAYS STUDENTS WITH SPECIAL
NEEDS AT NINE POINT 2% SO ALL
ALL OTHER STUDENTS ARE AT FORTY
TWO POINT 2% PREPARED. THAT
MEANS THAT STUDENT FOSTER'S
FOUR TIMES LESS LIKELY THAN
THEIR NON FOSTER COMFORT TO
MEET THE CURRENT STANDARDS FOR
COLLEGE. WHAT WE ALSO KNOW IS
THAT THERE IS A STRONGER
LIKELIHOOD THAT FOSTER IT WAS
RECEIVED A DEGREE IF THEY'D A
DIRECTLY AND ROLL AND A FOUR
YEAR COLLEGE OR UNIVERSITY.
RIGHT. ADDING THIS ADDITIONAL
YEAR OF MATH AND QUANTITATIVE
REASONING DOES NOT ACKNOWLEDGE
THE CHALLENGES THAT STUDENTS IN
THESE SITUATIONS HAVE TO
OVERCOME TO JUST MEET THE
CURRENT REQUIREMENTS AND HOW IT
IMPACTS ACCESSIBILITY FOR
STUDENTS TO WHOM THE STATE HAS
THE UNIQUE OBLIGATION HAVING
REMOVE THEM FROM THEIR FAMILIES
AND FOR WHOM THE STATE HAS
TAKEN ON PARENTAL
RESPONSIBILITIES. THANKS AFFECT
THE SUCCESS IN HIGHER EDUCATION
GRADUATION IS OFTEN DUE TO THE
SUPPORTS PROVIDED VIA TARGETED
STAMP PROGRAMS LIKE ETHIOPIA.
E. O. APS GUARDIANS COLLARS AND
THE LIKE. THIS RESEARCH
INDICATES THAT THESE TYPES OF
TARGETED STUDENT SUPPORT
PROGRAMS HAVE ALLOWED HIM TO
PROSPER AND OTHER STUDENTS WITH
SOME EXPENSE TO THRIVE IN
HIGHER EDUCATION AND COMPLETE.
DEGREES NOW THAT ASIDE THEY'RE
ACTUALLY LARGER CONCERNS THAT
ARE BROUGHT TO LIGHT WITH
ADDITIONAL REQUIREMENT AND
ALTHOUGH DISTRICT LIKE OURS.
HAS TWENTY NINE COURSES WHO
COULD MEET THIS OTHERS DO NOT.
FROM. HOW DOES NOT HAVE
INFRASTRUCTURE IS OFTEN NOT
REQUIRED TACTIC SHIFT RESOURCES
EVEN OPEN THE LAID EMPLOYMENT
IMPLEMENTATION TIMELINE.
SPECIFICALLY WITH AN INEVITABLE
RECESSION ON THE HORIZON AS
INDICATED BY THE ECONOMIC
INDICATOR SHARED BY THE LA JOH
INVERTED YIELD SCORES LOW GDP.
THE BUSINESS CYCLE ABOUT TO END
RIGHT AND THAT'S GONNA HAPPEN
SORRY. AS SOMEONE MCCARTY
YOU'RE GONNA HAVE TO CHAIR THIS.
HOW IT'S HARD TO IMAGINE HOW
AND WHERE SCHOOL DISTRICTS
DISTRICTS WILL FIND THE
FINANCIAL RESOURCES TO ADD
ADDITIONAL COURSES. THIS IS
ESPECIALLY TRUE OF SMALL WORLD
OF STRENGTH WHO HAVE LIMITED
TEACHING FACULTY TO MEET THE
CURRENT CSU REQUIREMENTS.
ALTHOUGH WAIVER PROPOSAL HAS
BEEN PUT FORTH FOR
CONSIDERATION THIS WAIVER
PROCESS WILL CREATE ADDITIONAL
BUREAUCRATIC CHALLENGES BOTH
FOR K. TWELVE OUR ADVISORS AND
I MATCH IN THE CSU SYSTEM IF IT
ISN'T REALLY STREAMLINED AN%
AUTOMATIC. IT SEEMS THAT THE
WAIVER WOULD ALSO CREATE A
MULTI TIERED SYSTEM OF
ELIGIBILITY WHICH COULD. BE
PROBLEMATIC. ALTHOUGH CSU HAS
COMMITTED ONE TIME TEN MILLION
OVER THREE YEARS TO HELP
BOLSTER THE SHRINKING
POPULATION OF K. TWELVE. STEM
TEACHERS IT IS UNLIKE IT IS
LIKELY NOT SUFFICIENT ENOUGH TO
ADDRESS ADDRESS THE GAP THAT IS
REQUIRED TO MEET THE CURRENT
CURRICULUM NEEDS. MUCH LESS TO
BUY AN ADDITIONAL YEAR OF
QUANTITATIVE REASONING AND OVER
THIRTEEN HUNDRED HIGH SCHOOLS
AND SEVEN HUNDRED ALTERNATIVE
EDUCATION SCHOOLS. AS I
DISCUSSED THIS WITH SEVERAL
COLLEAGUES THROUGHOUT THE STATE
THEY ALSO DIDN'T KNOW THAT THIS
WAS HAPPENING SO THE SHOCK TO A
LOT OF MY COLLEAGUES BOARD
MEMBERS SUPERINTENDENTS. THEY
WERE. THE REASON FOR THE KEY
QUANTITY REASON PROPOSAL IS
UNCLEAR IF THERE IS A BELIEF
THAT Q. R. IS WHAT CAN INCREASE
MATRICULATION GRADUATION THEN
WHY COULD VENN COULD
QUANTITATIVE REASONING THE ONE
OF THE OPTIONAL MATH OR SCIENCE
REQUIREMENTS. ADOPTED IN WITHIN
THE CURRENT FRAMEWORK. AS I
UNDERSTAND IT FROM COLLEAGUES
WHO ARE IN THE MATH DEPARTMENT
HIGH SCHOOL MATH ACTUALLY NOT
SEQUENTIAL WRITE SO DOESN'T GO
FROM. ALGEBRA ALGEBRA TO
GEOMETRY TO TRICK YOU CAN
ACTUALLY FOLD IN A QUANTITATIVE
REASONING COURSE AND SO IT'S
NOT SEQUENTIAL AND THAT AND
THAT METHOD. THAT THAT OPTION
WOULD SEEM TO ME TO BE RESOLVED
IN ADDITION TO THE RESEARCH
SEEM TO BE A BIT LIMITED IN
SCOPE. ONLY FOCUSING ON MATH
AND QUANTITATIVE REASONING WELL
THEY COULD BE THERE COULD BE
OTHER SEEN BEHAVIORS THAT MAY
HAVE ALSO SHOWN HYBRID
MATRICULATION GRADUATION RATES.
I A PERHAPS COMPLETION OF
ETHNIC STUDIES COURSES OR
ANYTHING ELSE WITH THAT WAS
MENTIONED BY DOCTOR LEE. OR FOR
EXAMPLE OTHER RESEARCH THAT HAS
IDENTIFIED STRONG SEEN SUPPORT
SYSTEMS AND HIRED AT AS AS A-
AS A WAY FOR DISADVANTAGED
STUDENTS ACTUALLY COMPLETE AND
SUCCEED IN HIGHER EDUCATION. IN
CLOSING WHAT THIS PROPOSAL HAVE
HIGHLIGHTS THE ME AND A NUMBER
OF MY COLLEAGUES AS A THAT
THERE HAS BEEN A LACK OF STRONG
COORDINATION BETWEEN THE CABLE
SYSTEM AND SEE IF YOU TO INSURE
THAT THERE IS A CLEAR AND
CONSISTENT ARTICULATION. AND
EDUCATION PROGRAM WITH FAR
HIGHER AT. IT WOULD BENEFIT ALL
PARTIES A STRONGER AUTHENTIC
PARTNERSHIP. INCREASE
CURRICULUM DESIGN AND UPLAND
IMPLEMENTATION EXISTED BETWEEN
THE TWO. INDEED THERE ARE
POCKETS OF EXCELLENCE SUCH AS
LONG BEACH BUT WE ALSO MUST
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT LONG BEACH
UNIFIED HAS HAD MANY FACTORS
THAT HAVE CREATED LONGEVITY
LEADERSHIP. WHICH INCLUDES
STRONG PRIVATE FOUNDATION
FUNDING EITHER DIRECTLY OR
THROUGH TO TREAT STRATEGIC
PLANNING THAT WILL LIKELY NOT
BE AVAILABLE TO ALL ONE
THOUSAND PLUS HIGH SCHOOLS IN
THE STATE. SO WHAT DO WE KNOW
IN FISCAL RECEIVED RESOURCES
AND A LOOMING RECESSION ON THE
HORIZON. IS IT WISE TO IMPOSE
ADDITIONAL REQUIREMENTS ON THE
CABLE SYSTEM WHEN MANY
DISTRICTS ARE STILL TRYING TO
JUST MEET. THE CURRENT
REQUIREMENTS AND THE LOCAL
CONTENT COAT LOCAL CONTROL
FUNDING FORMULA MANDATES.
AVAILABLE RESOURCES WOULD BE
LIKELY BETTER SPENT ON HOW K.
TWELVE AND HIGHER ED AND WORK
TOGETHER TO CREATE LEARNING
ENVIRONMENTS THAT. UBER IS ONLY
ONE FACTOR THAT PREPARES K.
TWELVE STUDENTS AT FOR SUCCESS
IN THE CSU SYSTEM. THANK YOU
THANK YOU MISTER MCCARTY
QUESTIONS COMMENTS. THE BILL
ISN'T JUST WANT WHAT QUESTIONS
I KNOW YOU YEAH THANK TASK YEAR
ONE DISTRICT AS A THOUSAND HAVE
YOU SO THAT CSPA ASSOCIATION
ARE THEY ENGAGED IN THIS ONE OR
THE OTHER THERE OPPOSE THEY'VE
COMMITTED A LOT ARE LOOK AT
THIS AND I HAPPEN TO BE ALSO
ONE OF THE CSPA. DELEGATES IF
YOU ADD AOL AND. WHAT TO SOME
OF THE DISTRICTS THAT HAVE THIS
REQUIREMENT. WHAT ARE THEY HAVE
A TEST A DISSENTING VOICE IN IT
IN MATTER OF THE SUPPORT OF THE
CSU POLICY I THINK THEY
UNDERSTAND THE CHALLENGES OF
THE COLLEAGUES IN TERMS OF
FISCAL AND FISCAL
RESPONSIBILITY AND- I THINK
THAT THE LARGER ISSUE AT HAND
IS. WHETHER NOT WE WERE ENGAGED
FROM THE BEGINNING. RIGHT TO
MAKE SURE IS THAT SIX YEARS IS
THAT FOR YEARS AS A THREE YEARS
IN TERMS OF. IS THIS IT DOES
THIS MEET THEN TENTACLES OF CSU
AND HOW WHAT IS THE ROLE K.
TWELVE IN US. RIGHT SO THAT THE
BIGGER QUESTION AMONG CALL A
MONTH COLLEGE IS. HOW ARE WE
ACTUALLY ENGAGING SCHOOL
DISTRICT IN K. TWELVE. HELPFUL
THANK YOU. EXTENT THEM AND
THAT'S WHAT MY ONLY QUESTION
SOMEWHAT AND IN THE SAME. SAME
LINE ON THE TIME NEEDED FOR
IMPLEMENTATION THE CONCERN.
IT'S A IT NEEDS TO BE
DISCUSSION BETWEEN ALL ALL
ACTUALLY AND EDUCATION CALL IT
A CO AX CTA CSPA ETCETERA SO I
WOULD SAY I RIGHT NOW I
COULDN'T TELL YOU EXACTLY WHAT
ALL OF MY COLLEAGUES ACROSS A
THOUSAND PLUS DISTRICTS WOULD
SAY. AND WHAT THEY'RE NOT THERE
YOU KNOW THE SMALL WORLD NEED
TO BE EXEMPTED OR THERE'S
ACTUALLY DIFFERENT MACHINATIONS
I WOULD IMAGINE THAT SOME
DISTRICTS CAN GO ONLINE SOONER
LIKE WASHINGTON UNIFIED IN
RIVER CITY OTHERS MAY NOT RIGHT
AGAIN YOU KNOW HAVING SEEN THIS
PAST YEAR A LOT OF THE PRESS
AROUND CONTRACT NEGOTIATIONS.
RIGHT AND HOW TO ACTUALLY BUILD
THE BUDGET WITH IT ONE OF THE
STARS AND PURRS COSTS AND OTHER
THINGS AND HOW DO HOW WOULD.
ONE ACTUALLY ADD AN ADDITIONAL
YEAR OF QUANTITATIVE REASONING.
WHAT THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK
YOU FOR YOUR PRESENTATION I'M
GOING TO ACTUALLY ASK.
REPRESENTATIVES OF CSU IF THEY
COULD COME BACK IF THERE. ANY
AND SO WHAT ABOUT. AND IF THE
REPRESENTATIVES OF CS YOU COULD
COME BACK TO THE TABLE PLEASE.
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE. SO I
WANT TO THANK EVERYONE FOR
THEIR PRESENTATIONS AGAIN THANK
YOU EVERYONE FOR BEING HERE TO
ALL THE PANELISTS AND I HOPE
THIS HEARING HAS BEEN BOTH
INFORMATIVE AND I AM OPENING
PRECIADO EVERYONE'S CANDOR AND
TRANSPARENCY. IN THIS
CONVERSATION. I PERSONALLY AM
NOT CONVINCED OF THE SEA ISSUES
OUR PROPOSAL IS WARRANTED I
HIGHLY ENCOURAGE CSU TO WORK
WITH ALL AFFECTED STAKEHOLDERS
BEFORE THEY TAKE ACTION ON THIS
PROPOSAL. I AM CONCERNED THAT
THE STUDENTS OF SAID THAT THE
STUDENTS THAT CSU BELIEVES THIS
PROPOSAL WILL ASSIST ARE THE
SAME STUDENTS WHO. VERY WELL
MAY BE ADVERSELY IMPACTED BY
THIS PROPOSAL. WHO MAY NEVER
MARCH MATRICULATED TO A CSU.
WHAT WILL THAT A FAX AB ON THE
STATE OUR COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
AND THE INFLUX OF STUDENTS WHO
MAY CHOOSE COMMUNITY COLLEGES
OVERSEE AS YOU. IN LIGHT OF
EVERYTHING THAT I HAVE LEARNED
TODAY I HAVE A SERIES OF
QUESTIONS FOR CSU. AND LET IT
MAYBE I CAN GO THROUGH THESE
QUESTIONS AND THEN ASK FOR A
RESPONSE. IF THIS PROPOSAL
PASSES I TRULY BELIEVE THAT THE
PROPOSAL SHOULD INCLUDE AS WAS
RECOMMENDED HERE. THE CREATION
OF A QUANTITATIVE REASONING
IMPLEMENTATION TASK FORCE THAT
INCLUDES THE FOLLOWING. SEE IS
YOU REPRESENTATIVES. STUDENTS
FACULTY STAFF AND
ADMINISTRATION. AS WELL AS
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION STATE BOARD OF
EDUCATION AND K. TWELVE
STAKEHOLDER GROUPS. RESEARCH
COMMUNITY ORGANIZATIONS AND
LEGISLATIVE REPRESENTATION.
THIS GROUP WOULD ONE
INDEPENDENTLY ASSESS
IMPLEMENTATION AT SPECIFIC
BENCHMARK POINTS TO RECOMMEND
THAT RECOMMENDED THE TRUSTEES
WHETHER THE ADMISSIONS CHANGES
SHOULD TAKE A FACT AND TWENTY
TWENTY SIX OR BE DELAYED IF
NECESSARY. THREE OVERSEE
ASSESSMENT AND EVALUATION
CRITERIA AND ANNOUNCES IF.
IMPLEMENTATION TAKES PLACE. SO
MY QUESTION. WOULD CSU COMMIT
TO THE CREATION OF SUCH A TASK
FORCE SHOULD SUCH A PROPOSAL AS
YOU ARE PROPOSING PASSED BE
PASSED BY THE TRUSTEES. SALT SO
THANK YOU ASSEMBLYMEMBER I
THINK. IF IT DOES GO WITH HOUSE
AND I CANNOT COMMIT ON BEHALF
OF THE CHANCELLOR BUT WHAT I
CAN SAY ARE HERE TODAY IS THAT
I THINK YOU WOULD FIND A HIGH
DEGREE OF COOPERATION AND WITH
AN IMPLEMENTATION TASK FORCE.
THAT GIVES ROOM FOR DIVERSE
CONSTITUENTS AND STAKEHOLDERS
TO CONSIDER WHAT THE CHALLENGES
ARE IMPLEMENTATION POINTS OF
EMPHASIS SHOULD BE AND THE SIX
OR SEVEN YEARS PRECEDING UP THE
EFFECTIVE DATE OF THE POLICY
CHANGE IF IT IS ADOPTED BY THE
BOARD SO WHILE I CAN'T ANSWER
FOR THE CHANCELLOR I CAN'T
ANSWER FOR THE BOARD OF
TRUSTEES I THINK. THE CSU HAS
REMAINED COMMITTED TO WORKING
WITH A BROAD AND DIVERSE GROUP
OF STAKEHOLDERS AS WE MOVE
FORWARD. AND I DID NOT MEAN FOR
MY QUESTIONS TO IMPLY THAT I
APPROVE AS SUCH A PROPOSAL. AND
I AND I THINK IN A MINUTE SOON
OPEN IT UP TO. PUBLIC COMMENT.
AND I THINK JUST THE NUMBER OF
SCHOOL DISTRICTS ORGANIZATIONS.
YOU KNOW THE LETTER FROM THE
CHAIR OF HIGHER ED OF EDUCATION
COMMITTEE MISTER O'DONNELL THE
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATIVE BLACK
CAUCUS. I WOULD VERY MUCH
CAUTION CSU TO MOVE FORWARD.
YOU KNOW I IT I THINK IT IS ONE
OF THE THINGS THAT HAVE BEEN
HEARD HEAR LOUD AND CLEAR WAS
THAT THERE WAS NOT ENOUGH
CONVERSATION WITH ALL THE
DIFFERENT GROUPS K. TWELVE.
THEY'RE GONNA BE IMPACTED
COMMUNITY COLLEGE SO I WOULD
ASK CSU AND THE TRUSTEES TO
SLOW DOWN THE PROCESS AND TO.
RETHINK THIS. BUT I THANK YOU
AND I TAKE THAT AS A
COMMITMENT. AND AM NOW GOING TO
OPEN IT UP TO PUBLIC COMMENTS.
THANK YOU SOME OF THAT THANK
YOU. SO ON PUBLIC COMMENTS WE
WILL HAVE ONE ONE MINUTE PER
SPEAKER. IF YOU WOULD PLEASE
IDENTIFY YOURSELF BEFORE
SPEAKING. GOOD AFTERNOON SIR
MEDINA AND ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MCCARTY MY NAME IS SUSAN GREEN
AND I'M A FACULTY MEMBER AT CAL
STATE CHICO AND I'M HERE ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
FACULTY ASSOCIATION THE
CALIFORNIA FACULTY ASSOCIATION
OPPOSES THE EXPANSION OF THE
QUANTITATIVE REASONING
ADMISSIONS REQUIREMENTS. IN ITS
CURRENT FORM THE CSU
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE PROPOSAL TO
EXPAND THE A THROUGH G.
ADMISSIONS REQUIREMENTS TO
INCLUDE THIS FOURTH YEAR OF
QUANTITATIVE REASONING IF
RUSHED WILL HAVE SERIOUS
CONSEQUENCES FOR STUDENT ACCESS
TO HIGHER EDUCATION
PARTICULARLY FOR THE
UNDERSERVED AND UNDERPRIVILEGED
COMMUNITIES THAT YOU'VE HEARD
ABOUT BEFORE. SEE IF A AGREES
WITH THE STATEWIDE ACADEMIC
SENATE. THAT SUPPORTING STUDENT
SUCCESS WHERE CHANGES AN
ENTRANCE REQUIREMENTS COULD
ALSO SIMULTANEOUSLY
DIFFERENTIALLY HARMS STUDENTS
WITH EITHER LESS ACCESS TO
LOWER AWARENESS OF THESE MORE
EXPENSIVE PREPARATORY ELEMENTS.
AND THAT ANY SUCH POTENTIAL
EFFECTS BE AMELIORATED AS THE
ASSOCIATED POLICIES ARE
DEVELOPED. PROPOSED REQUIREMENT
WILL CREATE BARRIERS TO ACCESS
TO THE CSU AND EXACERBATE
EDUCATIONAL DISPARITIES ALREADY
EXISTING IN CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITIES AND WITHOUT DUE
DILIGENCE AS YOU HEARD ABOUT
FROM THE OTHER FOLKS HAVE
TESTIFIED HERE TODAY WE WILL
HAVE. AN OPPORTUNITY TO CREATE
EVEN MORE EDUCATIONAL
INEQUALITY. THE PROPOSED WAIVER
FOR STUDENTS WHO CANNOT
COMPLETE THIS REQUIREMENT
THROUGH NO FAULT OF THEIR OWN
AS DR ED LEE JUST TESTIFIED A
FEW MINUTES AGO IS AN
INEFFECTIVE POLICY PATCH AND
NOT A SOLUTION TO THE VERY REAL
EQUITY IN ACCESS CONCERNS.
RAISED BY THIS PROPOSAL. AS A
PARENT. AND A FACULTY MEMBER AT
CHICO STATE WHO HAS WORKED ON
THESE ISSUES I WANT TO SHARE
THIS AND THIS IMPORTANT
PERSPECTIVE WITH YOU. WE JUST
ADOPTED COMMON CORE IN
CALIFORNIA IN TWENTY TEN. AN
OLD MATH CLASSES YOU WERE ASKED
TO MEASURE THE AREA OF A
TRAPEZOID. AND COMMON CORE YOU
ARE ASKED TO SHARE THREE WAYS
TO FIND THE AREA OF A
TRAPEZOID. TO EXPLAIN WHICH WAY
IS BEST AND WHY. THIS IS AN
EXPONENTIALLY DIFFERENT LEVEL
OF QUANTITATIVE REASONING WE
HAVE YET TO BE ABLE TO MEASURE
THE IMPACT OF ADOPTING COMMON
CORE AND ITS IMPACT ON A COHORT
OF STUDENTS THAT HAS COMPLETED
THE ENTIRE K. TWELVE MATH
CURRICULUM WE WILL NOT HAVE
THEIR GROUP OF STUDENTS INITIAL
TWENTY TWENTY THREE. SO THAT'S
THE EARLIEST POINT AT WHICH WE
WOULD HAVE DATA SO THE CSU HAS
DATA BUT I'M NOT SURE IT'S THE
RIGHT DATA. THE CHANCELLOR'S
OFFICE SHOULD SLOW DOWN IT
SHOULD CONSIDER ALL THE
INTENDED AND UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES OF THIS POLICY
SHIFT AND WE SHOULD WORK
TOGETHER WITH THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION WITH K.
TWELVE DISTRICTS WITH CSU
FACULTY PARTICULARLY THOSE WHO
PREPARE THE MATH INSTRUCTORS
TOGETHER DATA. ANALYZE THE DATA
MAKE SURE IT'S THE RIGHT DATA
AND PERFORM MEANINGFUL AN IN
DEPTH ANALYSIS REGARDING. THE
POTENTIAL UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES OF THIS POLICY WE
SHOULD ONLY IMPLEMENTED WHEN
ALL OF THESE CONCERNS ARE
ADDRESSED AND THE NEGATIVE
CONSEQUENCES THAT YOU'VE
ALLUDED TO I HAVE BEEN
DEDICATED THANK YOU THANK YOU.
AND REMINDER THAT I AS FOR
COMMENTS TO BE ONE MINUTE.
UNTIL SHE WAS TALKING THE LOS
ANGELES COMMUNITY COLLEGE
DISTRICT. WE WANT TO COMMENT ON
OF THE UNIT THE INCLUSION OR
EXCLUSION OF COMMUNITY COLLEGE
TRANSFER STUDENTS IN THIS
PROPOSAL UP TO NOW THE PROPOSAL
HAS BEEN SILENT ON THAT POINT
AND AS YOU HEARD FROM A MISTER
EVANS DISCUSSION IT HE ASSERTED
THAT THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE OF
TRANSFER STUDENTS WILL NOT BE
INCLUDING THIS PROPOSAL. I
THINK TO HELP CLARIFY THIS
POINT IT SHOULD BE SPECIFICALLY
STATED ONE WAY OR THE OTHER IF
A PROPOSAL MOVES FORWARD THAT
WITH THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE
TRANSFER STUDENTS ARE SUBJECT
TO THIS PROPOSAL THE ABSENCE OF
ANY STATEMENT IS CREATING
UNCERTAINTY AND CONFUSION
ALREADY OUT IN THE FIELD. AMONG
COMMUNITY COLLEGE STUDENTS
COMMUNITY COLLEGE FACULTY
COMMITTEE COLLEGE COUNSELORS IN
ADMINISTRATION SO I THINK SOME%
STATEMENT TO CLARIFY ONE WAY OR
THE OTHER OF THE OF WHETHER THE
SUPPLIES WOULD BE VERY
IMPORTANT AND SECOND TO THE
POINT YOU'RE RAISING ABOUT THE
ADVISORY COMMITTEE. I THINK IT
WOULD BE HELPFUL TO HAVE THE
INVOLVED WITH THE COMMUNITY
CALL SO REPRESENTATION THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES AS WELL AS
YOU DELIBERATE ON THE IMPACT OF
THIS PROPOSAL. THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON MANY OF THE BIGGEST
ON BEHALF OF THE EDUCATION
TRUST WEST HERE TO OPPOSE THIS
PROPOSAL BECAUSE THE WE BELIEVE
THAT IT WILL EXACERBATE
INEQUITIES CURRENTLY EXISTING
FOR LOW INCOME STUDENTS AND
STUDENTS OF COLOR. AS PROPOSED
ETW HAS FOUR PRIMARY CONCERNS
FIRST THERE HAS BEEN NO
INDEPENDENT A RIGOROUS STUDY.
ON THE FULL IMPACT OF THIS
CHANGE. THE CSU MENTION THAT
THEIR KNOWLEDGE TO SHOWS NO
DISPARATE IMPACT WE ASK THEM TO
SHARE THAT DATA WITH AN
INDEPENDENT. OUTSIDE
ORGANIZATION TO DO THAT
ANALYSIS AND SEE IF THAT HOLDS
TRUE. SECOND CERTAIN KEY
PILLARS OF THIS PROPOSAL HAVE
NOT BEEN FULLY FLESHED OUT. AND
CSU WE BELIEVE DOES NOT HAVE
THE FULL DATA PICTURE. IN ORDER
TO MAKE SURE THIS IS. EQUITABLY
IMPLEMENTED. THIRD ARE CAPABLE
SYSTEM CURRENTLY HAS AN
EQUITABLE ACCESS TO MATH
SCIENCE AND CERTAIN A TO G.
COURSES. FOR SPECIFIC STUDENTS
CERTAIN REGIONS OF ANY SPECIFIC
SCHOOLS. IN SEPTEMBER WE
SUBMITTED A FOR A LETTER TO THE
TRUSTEES WHICH CITED EIGHT OF
THOSE STUDIES COMING FROM
RELIABLE SOURCES SUCH AS PPRC
THE STATE AUDITOR'S OFFICE
SUPPORT CENTER PACE AND THE
CHANCES OFFICE THEMSELVES.
LASTLY ADDING AN ADDITIONAL
YEAR OF MATH SCIENCE A
QUANTITATIVE REASONING WELL AT
FURTHER COMPLEXITIES TOWARD
TEACHER SHORTAGE SPECIFICALLY
IN THE STEM FIELDS A SYSTEMATIC
CHANGE LIKE THIS SHOULD HAVE
PLENTY OF ENGAGEMENT WITH KATE
WILL STAKEHOLDERS AND THE CABLE
SYSTEM AS ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MEDINA SAID. AND IT HAS NOT
THAT IS WHY SO MANY OF IN OUR
POST AND ALL OF THEM ARE LISTED
BEFORE YOU. THANK YOU THANK YOU.
WELL LEGISLATORS AND STUFF MY
NAME IS ALYSSA LEE I'M A SACK
STATE STUDENT AND THE VICE
CHAIR OF. THE CALIFORNIA STATE
STUDENT ASSOCIATIONS
LEGISLATIVE AFFAIRS COMMITTEE.
SO CSSA AS OF YESTERDAY IS
OFFICIALLY OPPOSED TO THIS FOR
THE A QUANTITATIVE REASONING
PROPOSAL. FOR A FEW MAIN
REASONS WE DON'T OPPOSE STUDENT
SUCCESS. WE DO FEEL THAT THE
CURRENT PROPOSAL FAILS TO
PROVIDE EVIDENCE THAT THE Q. R.
COURSE WORK. FOR INCOMING
FRESHMEN LEAD TO AN INCREASE IN
STUDENT SUCCESS. AND IT WILL
HAVE A DISPROPORTIONATE IMPACT
ON LOW INCOME AND BLACK AND
LATIN LIKE STUDENTS. AS WELL AS
STUDENTS FROM RURAL REGIONS. SO
I JUST WANT TO KNOW A FEW
THINGS YOU GUYS THAT HAVE
ALREADY BEEN ITERATED I MEAN
THIS YES USE MEANT TO BE MORE
ACCESSIBLE. THIS IS POSING
OTHER BARRIER. AND HOW DOES IT
HELP NON STEM STUDENTS. AND THE
WAIVER IS REDUNDANT IF YOU
THINK ABOUT IT. THE C. S. USING
KNOWLEDGE BEING THAT CERTAIN
STUDENTS WILL BE EFFECTIVE AND
IF THE CSU IS MEANT TO BE MORE
ACCESSIBLE AND MEANT TO INCLUDE
ALL STUDENTS AS I BELIEVE
MISTER EVANS HAD MENTIONED.
WHERE WE KICKING THE 9% TO THE
CURB. AND. DOCTOR MINOR HAD
MENTIONED THE COMMENT YESTERDAY
THAT HE DOES BELIEVE THAT HE
HAS STUDENTS BEST INTERESTS IN
MIND I DISAGREE WITH THAT IF
HE'S REFERRING TO CSU STUDENTS
THE CAL STATE SOON ASSOCIATION
BE RECOGNIZED VOICE OF CSU
STUDENTS IS A POST SO WITH THAT
BEING SAID. JUST ONE BELIEVE
THAT YOUR PRINCE THANK YOU.
ALMOST GOOD EVENING MISTER
CHAIR A LOWER EASTERLING ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
TEACHERS ASSOCIATION WE
REGISTERED OUR OPPOSITION TO
THE CSU TRUSTEES AND WE WERE
THERE TO SPEAK IN PERSON AFTER
OCTOBER MEETING. WE DON'T DO
THAT THAT OFTEN RIGHT I CAN'T
EVEN THINK OF MY TWENTY TWO
YEARS WITH ETA THAT WE'VE COME
TO THE CSU. AND SAID TO THEM
OUR CONCERNS OVER STUDENT
ACCESS. AN ON THE TEACHER
SHORTAGE AND SO WE SHARE WITH.
THE PEOPLE LINED UP BEHIND HERE
AND ALL THE TESTIMONY THAT YOU
HEARD TODAY ALL OF THOSE
CONCERNS AT ABOUT HOW STUDENTS.
COULD BE DENIED ACCESS AND SO
WE SHARE AND AGREE WITH THE
CHAIR'S POSITION AT THE CSU
SHOULD PUT A PAUSE ON THIS AND
WORK WITH THEIR STAKEHOLDER
OTHER EDUCATION STAKEHOLDERS.
THANK YOU THANK YOU. GOOD EARLY
EVENING CHAIR MEDINA ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MCCARTY JAKE BREMNER
WITH THE CAMPAIGN FOR COLLEGE
OPPORTUNITY AND I WILL BE BRIEF
AS MICHELLE HAS ALREADY OF MORE
EFFECTIVELY AND ELOQUENTLY
COMMUNICATED OUR CONCERNS THAT
I MIGHT BE ABLE TO. BUT I DO
WANT TO EXPRESS OUR GRATITUDE
FOR YOUR CONVENING THIS
CONVERSATION ON TO YOUR POINT
SUCH A TIMELY IMPORTANT TOPIC
TO STUDENTS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. AS WELL AS THE
LEADERSHIP THAT YOU BOTH HAVE
DEMONSTRATED IN FIGHTING FOR
GREATER ACCESS TO. OUR
UNIVERSITY SYSTEM BOTH CSU AND
YOU SEE AND ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MEDINA AT YOUR POINT IN REALLY
SPENDING THAT PARK OF HISTORY
TOWARDS GREATER INCLUSION. AND
SUPPORT FOR ALL STUDENTS IN
TRYING TO PURSUE HIGHER
EDUCATION AND APPRECIATE YOUR
YOUR WORDS OF CONCERN AND
CAUTION TO THE CSU AS THEY TRY
TO MOVE FORWARD AT THIS POINT
ALL JUST UNDERSCORE TWO POINTS
THAT BUT YOU BOTH REYES AND
CAME UP IN THE CONVERSATION
TODAY. FIRST THAT THIS PROPOSAL
HAS BEEN DEVELOPED WITHIN A
SILO CSU BOARD OF TRUSTEES
WOULD ESTABLISH THIS
REQUIREMENT AND LEAVE IT TO THE
K. TWELVE SYSTEM TO TRY TO
INSTITUTE AND MAKE THAT A
REALITY. WHEN AS YOU BOTH ARE
AWARE IN THE CONTEXT OF
RELATIVELY FLUSH STATE BUDGET
WE SEE REALLY THE FULL RANGE OF
K. TWELVE STAKEHOLDERS
EXPRESSING THEIR CONCERNS TODAY
AND THE WRITTEN COMMENT. AND
THEN FINALLY ON THAT SAME NOTE
WE FOR RELATIVELY FLUSH STATE
BUDGET BUT THERE ARE MORE
WARNING SIGNALS THAT ARE A
BLINKING RED ABOUT AN IMPENDING
POTENTIAL RECESSION. AND HOW
WILL DESPITE. FOUR YEARS OF
POTENTIAL IMPLEMENTATION HOW
WOULD THAT REALLY UNDERMINE THE
ABILITY OF OUR K. TWELVE SYSTEM
TO DO THIS EFFECTIVELY. AND
MAKE IT SO IT'S NOT A BARRIER
TO STUDENT ACCESS THANK YOU
BOTH THANK YOU. GOOD EVENING
DAVID NEVIN ON BEHALF OF SANTA
ANA UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT ALL
PRIOR SPEAKER SO AS NOT TO TAKE
UP TOO MUCH MORE TIME. ONE OF
THE POINTS THAT I'D LIKE TO
RAISE THAT HASN'T BEEN RELEASED
YET. AND SANTA ANA 52% OF OUR
STUDENTS AT OUR COMPREHENSIVE
SCHOOLS. COMPLETE A RIGOROUS
COLLEGE PREP CURRICULUM WHICH
MEANS THAT THE STUDENTS ARE
STILL RELYING ON. CREDIT
RECOVERY OPTIONS AND GIVEN OUR
ATG CURRICULUM. FOR DIPLOMA.
TRACK THAT COULD BE. COME A
LITTLE BIT OF A CHALLENGE GIVE
IN THIS NEW PROPOSAL. WE THINK
THAT IT'S A IT WILL ESSENTIALLY
FOR ALL OF THE STUDENTS WILL
CREATE. A TWO TIERED SYSTEM OF
HIGHER ADD. AND PROVIDE THE
ADVANTAGE IN THOSE SCHOOLS TO
ONLY THE STUDENTS WHO HAVE
INTERESTS AND THE SCIENCE
TECHNOLOGY MATHEMATICS.
ANYTHING THAT'S WHAT'S IN THE
STEM AREAS. OUR COMPREHENSIVE
SCHOOLS DO YOU HAVE A
GRADUATION PERCENTAGE RATE OF
NINETY TWO PERCENT. AND AS WELL
A COLLEGE GOING RATE OF SEVENTY
SIX AND A HALF PERCENT WHICH IS
FAR HIGHER ALMOST MORE THAN 10%
HIGHER THAN. THE STATEWIDE
AVERAGE SO WE THINK THAT THE
STUDENTS COULD BE HEAVILY OF
MUCH MORE HEAVILY IMPACTED. BY
THIS PARTICULAR PROPOSAL THANK
YOU THANK YOU. GOOD EVENING MY
NAME IS JENNA CARPENTER I
MONDAY I'M HERE ON BEHALF OF
THE ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
SCHOOL ADMINISTRATORS. AND AS
PREVIOUSLY MENTIONED BY THE
POOR PRESIDENT FROM WASHINGTON
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT. AND
THAT CAMPAIGN FOR COLLEGE
OPPORTUNITY WERE IN OPPOSITION
OF THIS PROPOSAL. AND WE
REPRESENT EIGHTEEN THOUSAND
SCHOOL LEADERS AND PRIMARILY
FOCUS ON AND THE NEEDS OF ALL
STUDENTS AND THE PROPOSAL. IT
DOESN'T TAKE INTO CONSIDERATION
VULNERABLE POPULATIONS AND
OTHER STUDENTS OF COLOR. AND IT
WOULD NEGATIVELY IMPACT THOSE
STUDENTS AND LAST WEEK AT OUR
LEADERSHIP ASSEMBLY THAT ACCESO
BOARD OF DIRECTORS TOOK A
FORMAL VOTE AND IT WAS. IN
OPPOSITION OUR OPPOSITION.
LETTER IS FORTHCOMING THANK YOU
THANK YOU. HELLO MY NAME IS
NOELLE MORA AND I REALLY GOT
MORE OF A TESTIMONIAL I'D LIKE
TO PUT MAYBE A LITTLE BIT MORE
OF A STUDENT FACE ON THIS ISSUE
TO SAY THAT I HAVE BENEFITTED
FROM THE OPPORTUNITIES OF GOING
TO A CSU. QUITE A BIT AND HAVE
YOU KNOW BEEN AN HONOR STUDENT
BEEN ON DEAN'S HONOR ROLL
ACTUALLY SERVED AS STUDENT
PRESIDENT AT MY SCHOOL SUCKS
THE LOS YOU'RE- NOT BEING SAID
I RETOOK ALGEBRA TWO MICE MY
LAST YEAR OF HIGH SCHOOL. TO
GET THAT PASSING GRADE SO THAT
I WOULD BE ACCEPTED INTO THE
CSU SO WHEN I HEARD ABOUT THIS
ISSUE I REALLY WANTED TO COME
HERE AND GIVE THAT QUICK STORY
BECAUSE IT WAS REALLY PERSONAL
I COULD HAVE EASILY NOT. HAVE
BEEN ACCEPTED INTO THE CSU YOU
KNOW GRADUATING FROM HIGH
SCHOOL SO I DON'T I WANT TO
BELIEVE THAT EVERY ONE IN THIS
MET ENDEAVOR HAS WELL
INTENTIONS BUT I. BEG TO POSE
THE QUESTION IS THAT OUR
STUDENTS THAT ARE UNDERPREPARED
OR IS THAT THE INSTITUTION THAT
IS UNDER PREPARED TO
ACCOMMODATE FOR THE INCREASED
AMOUNT OF HIGH SCHOOL
GRADUATES. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
WITH THAT I THANK. EVERYONE FOR
ATTENDING AND WE ARE DOING. AND
EVERYTHING ELSE